WELCOME TO TODAY'S JOINT
HEARING AS THE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW
COMMITTEE AND THE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE ON COVERED
NINETEEN FAXING DISTRIBUTION
BEFORE WE AS DIVE INTO OUR
WITNESSES I NEED TO READ A
COUPLE OF ANNOUNCEMENTS SO
FIRST DUE TO ONGOING COBIT
NINETEEN SAFETY CONSIDERATIONS
WE ARE HOLDING A PHYSICALLY
DISTANCED PUBLIC HEARING THIS
LIVE STREAMED ON THE ASSEMBLY
WEBSITE SPACE IS LIMITED FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND MEDIA
ALL INDIVIDUALS IN THE HEARING
ROOM ARE REQUIRED TO WEAR MASKS
AND OBSERVE SOCIAL DISTANCING.
THOSE PRESENT WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY DURING THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PROCESS AT THE END OF
THE HEARING ME DO SO THERE IS
ALSO AN OPTION TO CALL IN THE
PHONE NUMBER WHICH WILL ALSO BE
SHARED LATER IS. 877-692-8957
THE ACCESS CODE IS. TWO FOUR
TWO SIX TWO THREE SEVEN WRITTEN
COMMENTS WILL ALSO BE ACCEPTED
THROUGH A PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE OR BY
EMAILING OUR COMMITTEE STAFF
THE ACCOUNTABILITY COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE IS. A A. A. R. DOT
ASSEMBLY DOT C. A. DOT GOV. AND
AS WE PROCEED WITH THE
WITNESSES AND PUBLIC COMMENTS I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
HAS RULES TO ENSURE THAT WE
MAINTAIN ORDER AND RUN AN
EFFICIENT HEARING. WE SEEK TO
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF ALL WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
EFFECTIVE DELIBERATIONS AND
DECISIONS ON THE CRITICAL
ISSUES FACING CALIFORNIA. IN
ORDER TO FACILITATE THESE GOALS
WE WILL NOT PERMIT CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS AND DISTURBS OUR
OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF LEGISLATIVE
PROCEEDINGS. IN ADDITION THIS
YEAR WE WILL BE COMPLYING WITH
ALL PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS
ARISING OUT OF THE COBIT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. ACCORDINGLY
TODAY WE WILL BE ENFORCING OUR
RULES AND PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS
TO PROTECT ALL PARTICIPANTS IN
TODAY'S HEARING. AS YOU CAME
INTO THE HEARING ROOM TODAY THE
SERGEANTS DIRECTED YOUR
ATTENTION TO THE RULES FOR
PUBLIC ATTENDANCE AND
PARTICIPATION. WHICH WERE
POSTED OUTSIDE THE DOOR THOSE
RULES INCLUDE THE FOLLOWING.
WEAR A MASK OVER YOUR NOSE AND
MOUTH AT ALL TIMES IN COMPLY
WITH PHYSICAL DISTANCING NO
TALKING OR LOUD NOISES FROM THE
AUDIENCE PUBLIC COMMENT MAY BE
PROVIDED ONLY AT THE DESIGNATED
TIME AND PLACE AND AS PERMITTED
BY THE CHAIR. THE COMMENT MUST
RELATE TO THE SUBJECT OF
TODAY'S HEARING COVERED
NINETEEN VACCINE DISTRIBUTION.
ANY PERSON ATTENDING THIS
HEARING SHALL NOT ENGAGE IN
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT AT THIS HEARING
PLEASE BE AWARE THAT VIOLATIONS
OF THESE RULES MAY SUBJECT YOU
TO REMOVAL FROM THE CHAMBER WE
WILL NOT ACCEPT DESTRUCTIVE
BEHAVIOR OR BEHAVIOR THAT
INCITES OR THREATENS VIOLENCE
EVEN IN THE FORM OF A FAILED.
THREATS HI AND WITH THAT. THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE CODE
NINETEEN VACCINE IS THE MOST
URGENT PRIORITY FACING
CALIFORNIA TODAY WE ARE PLEASED
TO SEE THAT THE PACE OF VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION HAS IMPROVED
MARKEDLY IN RECENT WEEKS. AND
WE ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT MANY
QUESTIONS REMAIN ABOUT
CALIFORNIA'S VACCINE ROLLOUT
STIR STRATEGY FROM HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE FROM OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS AND FROM FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS TODAY OUR GOAL IS
TO ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS UPDATE.
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION ON THE
STATUS OF VACCINE DISTRIBUTION.
OUR GOALS FOR CALIFORNIA THE
PLAN TO GET US THERE AND
SPECIFICALLY THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE STATE'S NEW DELIVERY
SYSTEM WITH BLUE SHIELD. FOR
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS THE
COVER NINETEEN VACCINE IS A
LIGHT AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL.
WE NEED TO WORK TOGETHER TO
ENSURE THAT DISTRIBUTION IS
SWIFT SAFE AND EQUITABLE SO
THAT WE CAN DEFEAT THIS
PANDEMIC AND BEGIN THE REPORT
OF REBUILDING CALIFORNIA.
THANKS I'LL HAND IT OVER TO MY
CO CHAIR FOR TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATRICK. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON AND WELCOME EVERYONE
FOR JOINING US THIS AFTERNOON
LOOKING FOR TO CANDID AND
PRODUCTIVE DISCUSSION. THEM
FIRST LIKE MY COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATRICK
RECHARGE FOR CODE SHARING THIS
TURN ON THE STATUS OF STATUS OF
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO
DISTRIBUTE THE COVERT NINETEEN
VACCINE. I THINK ALL OF US CAN
AGREE THAT MORE NEEDS TO BE
DONE TO PROVIDE VACCINES TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AS A THIRTY YEAR
VETERAN OF RICH MEDICAL
SERVICES THE FATHER OF A SON
WHO'S A DEPUTY SHERIFF AND A
DAUGHTER WHO IS A RESPIRATORY
THERAPIST I KNOW ALL TOO WELL
THE CHALLENGES ARE FIRST
RESPONDERS AND FRONTLINE HEALTH
CARE WORKERS HAVE. BEEN FACING
ON A DAILY BASIS THROUGHOUT MY
CAREER I'VE BEEN A CHOPPER
PROVIDING THE TRAINING
RESOURCES AND PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT THESE
EVERYDAY HEROES NEED TO SAVE
LIVES AND KEEP OUR COMMUNITY
SAFE. READ THE MINISTRATION AND
BUILT SIGNIFICANT CHANGE OF
DIRECTION IN ITS APPROACH TO
DELIVERING AND ADMINISTERING
VACCINES ACROSS THE STATE. THE
STATE HAS CONTRACTED WITH
CRUCIAL TO ALLOCATE VACCINES
DIRECTLY TO PROVIDERS. THAT
EFFORT TO IMPROVE DISTRIBUTION
EFFICIENCY. AND PROVIDE THE
STATE WITH THE BETTER
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS OF WHAT
IS ACTUALLY HAPPENING AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. AS A PERMANENT
JERRY WILL ALSO RUN A SEPARATE
VACCINATION PROGRAM FOR NINE
MILLION MEMBERS. ADMINSTRATION
ALSO STATED ITS GOAL OF
SIMPLIFYING THE ELIGIBILITY FOR
VACCINES SO. THAT HEALTHCARE
WORKERS INDIVIDUAL SIXTY FIVE
AND OVER EDUCATION AND CHILD
CARE EMERGENCY SERVICES AND
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE WORKERS
WILL ALSO BE ELIGIBLE START
MAKING APPOINTMENTS TO BE
VACCINATED. BY MID FEBRUARY
ADMINISTRATION LAUNCHED ITS NEW
SYSTEM CALLED MY TURN. WITH THE
GOAL OF ESTABLISHING AN ONLINE
TOOL FOR CALIFORNIANS TO LEARN
WHEN AND WHERE THEY CAN BE
VACCINATED. GIVEN ALL THESE NEW
INITIATIVES TODAY'S THE PERFECT
OPPORTUNITY FOR DENTURES
ADMINISTRATION. TO PROVIDE US
WITH AN UPDATE ON THE OVERALL
VACCINATION TIME GOES. AND IS
ALSO AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
HEAR ABOUT ALL THESE RECENT
CHANGES IN HOW WHAT IMPACT
OPERATIONS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
THE LAST THING ANYONE WANTS TO
DO IS TO STRIP SUCCESSFUL LOCAL
OPERATIONS. FOR THAT REASON I
AM PLEASED THAT WE HAVE DOCTOR
AMY SYSTEM OF THE YOLO COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND DR
PAUL SIMON FROM THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HELP PROVIDE. A BOOST ON THE
GROUND PERSPECTIVE. THIS IS
ISN'T GOING TO BE HEARING ABOUT
HINDSIGHT THIS HEARING IS ABOUT
CLARITY GOING FORWARD.
SPECIFICALLY WHAT ARE THE
VACCINATION GOES MOVING
FORWARD. HOW WAS RESIDENTS KNOW
WHEN AND WHERE THEY CAN BE
VACCINATED AND HOW CAN WE BE
SURE THE VACCINES ARE BEING
ADMINISTERED AND EQUITABLE
MANNER TO REACH OUR MOST
UNDERSTOOD UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. IN ADDITION TO
MAKING SURE WE HAVE THE BEST
POSITION MOVING FORWARD ALSO
WANT TO HEAR ABOUT MORE
PARTNERSHIPS. EVERY SIX. I
RECENTLY BECAUSE OF THE HEARD
FROM MANY IMAGE PROVIDERS AND-
SERVICE PERSONNEL. THAT THEY
ARE BEING UNDER UTILIZED IN
BOTH TERMS OF THEIR EXPERIENCE
AND ESTABLISHING AND RUNNING
INCIDENT MANAGEMENT COMMAND
TEAMS. AND IN THE TERMS OF
BILLION FOR THE CREW TO
MINISTER VACCINES. THERE'S NO
DOUBT IN MY MIND THAT WE NEED.
TO DO MORE TO DOUBLE DOWN
EFFORTS TO LIST THESE TRUSTED
PARTNERS IN THE FIGHT AGAINST
COVERT NINETY. AGAIN THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING HERE AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR TESTIMONY AND
PARTICIPATION. IN WITHOUT SAID
WE CAN MOVE ON TO OUR FIRST. A
PANEL PANEL ONE FROM THE LOCAL
PERSPECTIVE AN UPDATE. AND I
THINK WE HAVE DOCTOR PAUL SIMON
CHIEF SCIENCE OFFICER LOST
JONES COUNTY DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH. AND DR AMY SAYS ON
PAPER PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER
YOLO COUNTY HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY- FOR YOUR ON
THE LINE OR VIDEO YOU CAN GO
FIRST. HOWEVER WOULD LIKE TO GO
FIRST. WELL GOOD AFTERNOON
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS I'M DOCTOR AB
SYSTEM THE HOLD OFFICER FOR
YOU'LL COUNTY AND I'M GRATEFUL
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU THIS AFTERNOON
ABOUT THE COBRA NINETEEN
VACCINE ROLLOUT IN YOLO COUNTY.
AS WE DISCUSSED VACCINE OR
ALLOCATION IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THERE ARE TWO MAIN
STREAMS THROUGH ITS THROUGH
WHICH VACCINE COME INTO YOUR
COUNTY. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
DIRECTLY ALLOCATES DOSES TO
YOUR COUNTIES HELP DEPARTMENT
AND THESE ARE DOSES THAT I AS
THE HEALTH OFFICER HAVE CONTROL
OVER. CDPH ALSO ALLOCATES DOSES
TO LARGE HEALTH SYSTEMS CALLED
MULTI COUNTY ENTITIES OR M. C.
E. IS AT A STATEWIDE LEVEL.
EACH M. C. EAT DISTRIBUTES
DOSES WITHIN ITS REGIONAL
NETWORKS. THERE ARE FOUR MULTI
COUNTY ENTITIES THAT SERVE YOLO
COUNTY RESIDENTS DIGNITY KAISER
SUTTER AND UC DAVIS HEALTH. I
HAVE NO CONTROL AND ONLY
LIMITED VISIBILITY OVER THE MC
ITO SAYS THAT MAY BE AVAILABLE
FOR YOLO COUNTY RESIDENTS. I
RECEIVED TWO WEEKLY EMAILS
ANNOUNCING VACCINE ALLOCATIONS
ONE ON SUNDAY NIGHT FOR SECOND
DOSES OF VACCINE FOR THE
FOLLOWING WEEK AND ANOTHER ON
TUESDAY NIGHT FOR FIRST DOSES.
AFTER RECEIVING THESE
NOTIFICATIONS I MEET WITH OUR
VACCINE PLANNING TEAM TO
DETERMINE HOW MANY DOSES TO
KEEP FOR COUNTY USE AND HOW
MANY THE ALLOCATE TO PARTNERS.
IN PHASE ONE B. TIER ONE WE ARE
ALLOCATING 25% OF DOSES TO
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS TO
VACCINATE UNDERSERVED CLIENTS.
DOSES CAPPED BY THE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT OR ADMINISTERED
THROUGH DRIVE THRU VACCINATION
CLINICS AT SITES THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTY USING A SMALL TEAM OF
COUNTY STAFF PAIRED WITH A
LARGE CONTINGENT OF VOLUNTEERS.
OUR TEAM HAS THE ABILITY TO
ADMINISTER MUCH MORE VACCINE
THAT WE ARE RECEIVING.
RETRACTORS IS ALLOCATED TO THE
COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENT USING
SPREADSHEETS AND GOOD OLD
FASHIONED COUNTING OF WILES IN
COLD STORAGE. DOSES
ADMINISTERED BY THE COUNTY ARE
ENTERED INTO A SPREADSHEET AND
UPLOAD IT ON MOSS INTO THE
STATE'S IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY
CARE TO WITHIN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS. AS OF FEBRUARY FIFTH
YOU'LL COUNTY HEALTH DEPARTMENT
HAS RECEIVED JUST OVER FOURTEEN
THOUSAND DOSES AND ADMINISTER
TEN THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
DOSES. WE KNOW THESE NUMBERS
ARE CORRECT BECAUSE WE HAVE
PAPERWORK FOR EVERY DOSE
ADMINISTERED. HOWEVER THE STATE
IS CURRENTLY REPORTING THAT
YOU'LL COUNTY HAS RECEIVED
FOURTEEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
DOSES ADMINISTERED JUST SEVENTY
FIVE HUNDRED DOSES. NEITHER THE
NUMBER RECEIVED NORTHERN NUMBER
ADMINISTERED BEING REPORTED BY
THE STATE MATCHES WHAT WE KNOW
TO BE TRUE IN YOLO COUNTY WITH
NEARLY 30% OF DOSES
ADMINISTERED MISSING. YOLO
COUNTY STAFF HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE STATE CONTRACTOR TO
TROUBLESHOOT THE DISCREPANCIES
TO NO AVAIL. I'M PARTICULARLY
CONCERNED THAT THE
DISCREPANCIES WILL RESULT IN
REDUCED FUTURE ALLOCATIONS. IF
THE STATE USES ITS CURRENT DATA
TO DETERMINE FUTURE ALLOCATIONS
YOLO COUNTY COULD BE PENALIZED
FOR WHAT THE STATE SEES AS AN
ADMINISTRATION RATE OF 51% BUT
IT'S ACTUALLY AN ADMINISTRATION
RATE OF SEVENTY FOUR PERCENT.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT
ALLOCATION DECISIONS BE BASED
ON ACCURATE DATA RIGHT NOW CDPH
DOES NOT HAVE ACCURATE DATA FOR
YOLO COUNTY. A DECISION BASED A
DECISION BASED ON BAD DATA WILL
BE A BAD DECISION. CALIFORNIA'S
VACCINE ROLLOUT IS HAMSTRUNG BY
POOR DATA QUALITY AT THE STATE
LEVEL AND ITS EMPHASIS ON SPEED
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO BENEFIT
THE PRIVILEGED MORE THAN THE
UNDERSERVED. WELL I DISAGREE
WITH THE DECISION TO BRING IN A
THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR WITH
NO EXPERIENCE IN VACCINE
ALLOCATION NOW THAT THE STATE
HAS COMMITTED TO THIS CHANGE IT
IS CRITICAL THAT DATA TRACKING
BE IMPROVED BY ELIMINATING THE
DATA UPLOAD ERRORS THAT PLAGUE
THE CURRENT CARE TO SYSTEM. IN
ADDITION MORE ATTENTION MUST BE
PAID THE BACKSEAT EQUITY BY
ENGAGING LOCAL HEALTH OFFICIALS
WITH ON THE GROUND ALL AGE TO
DIRECT- SISTER PROVIDERS THAT
SERVE THE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. AND TO ALLOW
APPOINTMENTS TO BE SET ASIDE
FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE AND
SCHEDULED USING A SIMPLE PHONE
CALL IN THEIR PREFERRED
LANGUAGE. GUIDANCE FROM THE
STATE ABOUT BOXING
PRIORITIZATION HAS CHANGED MANY
TIMES MAKING PLANNING DIFFICULT.
CALIFORNIA AND YOLO COUNTY-
CURRENTLY VACCINATING IN PHASE
ONE B. TIER ONE WHICH INCLUDES
THOSE SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER
ALONG WITH FRONTLINE WORKERS IN
THE SECTORS OF EDUCATION CHILD
CARE AND URGENCY RESPONSE AND
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE. THE
LIMITED VACCINE SUPPLY MEANS
THAT WE MUST PRIORITIZE WITH IN
THE CURRENT YEAR THE DATA ARE
CLEAR TO SAVE THE MOST LIVES
WITH THE FEW DOSES WE HAVE WE
MUST PRIORITIZE THOSE SIXTY
FIVE AND OLDER OVER YOUNGER
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. IN YOLO
COUNTY WE ANALYZED MORTALITY
RATES BY AGE AND FOUND THAT A
VACCINE GIVEN TO A YOLO COUNTY
RESIDENTS SIXTY FIVE OR OLDER
IS ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO SAVE A
LIFE THAT A VACCINE GIVEN TO
OUR RESIDENTS YOUNGER THAN
FIFTY. DESPITE COMPELLING DATA
SUPPORTING THE NEED TO
VACCINATE OUR OLDEST RESIDENTS
BEFORE ESSENTIAL WORKERS STATE
PRIORITISATION GUIDANCE HAS
ACTUALLY MOVED IN THE OPPOSITE%
DIRECTION. CDPH SHIFTER
GUIDANCE ON JET SHIFT SHIFTED
FROM GUIDANCE ON JANUARY
THIRTEENTH TO PRIORITIZE OLDER
ADULTS OVER YOUNGER ADULTS
WITHIN PHASE ONE B. THE
GUIDANCE ON FEBRUARY FOURTH
THAT MAKES NO DISTINCTION IN
PRIORITY BETWEEN OLDER ADULTS
AN ESSENTIAL WORKERS WITHIN
PHASE ONE B. TIER ONE.
DECISIONS ABOUT VACCINE
PRIORITIZATION MUST BE ROOTED
IN SCIENCE AND INSULATED FROM
POLITICAL PRESSURES. THE
VACCINE ROLLOUT IS PROCEEDING
FASTER THAN STATE DATA SUGGEST
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS ARE
PUTTING DOSES INTO ARMS AS
QUICKLY AS WE RECEIVE THEM
UNFORTUNATELY THE STATE DATA DO
NOT REFLECT THE TREMENDOUS
SUCCESSES OF LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS TO DATE. THE SYSTEM
ISN'T BROKEN IT JUST LOOKS LIKE
IT IS BECAUSE DOSES BEING
ADMINISTERED AREN'T SHOWING UP
ONE CDPH HAS ACCURATE DATA THE
DATA WILL REFLECT THE YEOMAN'S
WORK BEING DONE AND HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
TO GET RESIDENTS VACCINATED.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU WITH THAT WE HAVE OUR
NEXT- PERSON A PAUL SIMON OF
BELIEVE HE'S ON THE PHONE VIA
AT&T AT&T OPERATOR CAN CONNECT
OUR NEXT SPEAKER. HELLO THIS IS
THE A. T. AND T. OPERATOR WE DO
NOT HAVE A WHOLE I'M ON OUR
LINE. ABILITIES IN THE QUEUE IF
YOU CAN CONNECT THEM. AT&T.
THREE PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE- DO
YOU KNOW WHICH WHICH LINE
NUMBER IS. LOOKS LIKE IT COULD
BE TWO ONE THREE. A PAUL SIMON
IF YOU ARE ON THE LINE PLEASE
PRESS STAR TO. ARE IT LOOKS
LIKE I FOUND JUST ONE OF THE.
IN LINE TWENTY TWO YEAR LINE UP.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME THIS IS
DOCTOR PAUL SIMON. YEAH
SPEAKING AND I APOLOGIZE FOR
NOT BEING ABLE TO CONNECT VIA
WEBEX TODAY BUT UP. I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU ABOUT- I. L. A. COUNTY
EXPERIENCE WITH THE CULVERT
NINETEEN VACCINATION- EFFORTS.
AS OF FEBRUARY FOURTH I AM
PLEASED TO REPORT THAT L. A.
COUNTY IS ADMINISTERED OVER ONE
POINT TWO MILLION DOSES OF
VACCINE ACROSS THE COUNTY. BUT
OVER 80% OF VACCINES
ADMINISTERED WITHIN FOUR DAYS
OF RECEIPT. TODAY OVER 10% OF
OUR COUNTY POPULATION SIXTEEN
OLDER HAS RECEIVED AT LEAST ONE
DOSE OF VACCINE. SO I WILL SAY
ARE CONSISTENT WITH WHAT DOCTOR
SYSTEM TALKED ABOUT I'M NOT
CONFIDENT AT ALL OF THAT IS
REFLECTED IN IN THE STATE- DATA
SYSTEMS. WE HAVE MORE THAN
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
VACCINATION SITES ACROSS THE
COUNTY INCLUDING SIX LARGE
COMMUNITY VACCINATION SITES AND
A LARGE NETWORK OF HOSPITALS.
COMMUNITY CLINICS FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTERS
PHARMACIES AND MANY PRIVATE
PROVIDERS. UNFORTUNATELY THE
BIGGEST ISSUE WE CONTINUE TO
FACE. IS THE SCARCITY OF
VACCINE SUPPLY AND VERY ABILITY
IN THE AMOUNT OF VACCINE WE
RECEIVED FROM WEEK TO WEEK.
WHILE THE SUPPLY WE RECEIVED
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL WEEKS HAS
SLIGHTLY INCREASED. IT REMAINS
FAR SHORT OF THE NEED GIVEN
THAT NEARLY TWO MILLION COUNTY
RESIDENTS ARE CURRENTLY
ELIGIBLE. TO RECEIVE VACCINE
UNDER THE- STATE'S FRAMEWORK.
AND MORE PEOPLE ARE VACCINATED
WE ARE WATCHING VERY CLOSELY TO
ASSESS PROGRESS IN ENSURING
EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION OF THE
VACCINE. WE ARE GREATLY
CONCERNED ABOUT CONDITIONS IN
WHICH PEOPLE WITH FEWER
RESOURCES HAVE LESS ACCESS TO
THE VACCINE. EITHER BECAUSE OF
LIMITED ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY
INFORMATION LET'S ABILITY TO
SPEND TIME GETTING AN
APPOINTMENT. AND OR LESS
ABILITY TO TRAVEL TO OTHER
AREAS OF THE COUNTY TO GET THE
BACKS THE- DATA FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HUMANIZATION
REGISTRY WILL BE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR GAINING A BETTER
pVACCINATED AND WHERE THE GAPS
ARE OCCURRING. FOR EXAMPLE AN
INITIAL ANALYSIS OF THE
REGISTRY DATA WE DID THIS WEEK
INDICATED THAT LATINO AND BLACK
RESIDENTS ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
UNDER REPRESENTED AMONG THOSE
WHO HAD BEEN VACCINATED SO FAR
IN OUR COUNTY. THESE EARLY
RESULTS ARE EXTREMELY ALARMING
AND INDICATE THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE IT MUCH EASIER FOR BLACK
AND LATINO RESIDENTS AND
WORKERS TO BE VACCINATED IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES BY PROVIDERS
THEY TRUST. IT IS A TOP
PRIORITY FOR THE COUNTY'S BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH. WE
ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
OUR COMMUNITY PARTNERS AND
ELECTED OFFICIALS TO ENSURE
THAT ALL DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED GROUPS ARE ABLE TO GET
VACCINATED AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. THIS INCLUDES A
COMMITMENT TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF VACCINATION SITES IN
HARD HIT COMMUNITIES.
PENITENTIAL VACCINATION BY
TOURE ADDED THIS WEEK IN EAST
LA AND SOUTH LA. WE ARE ALSO
LOOKING AT STRATEGIES TO
IMPROVE ACCESS TO VACCINE FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE OLDER AND HAVE
LIMITED MOBILITY AND NEED
ASSISTANCE SECURING
APPOINTMENTS. FOR EXAMPLE WE
ARE ORGANIZING MOBILE TEAMS TO
BRING VACCINATIONS NEXT WEEK
DIRECTLY TO SENIORS LIVING IN
SENIOR HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS OR
ACCESSING SENIOR CENTERS THAT
ARE HARDEST HIT COMMUNITIES. WE
ALSO HAVE COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS IN THE HIGHLY IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES WHO ARE PROVIDING
INFORMATION TO RESIDENTS ABOUT
HOW TO GET VACCINATED. AND TO
DISPEL MYTHS AND MISINFORMATION
ABOUT THE VACCINE. AS YOU KNOW
THE GOVERNOR HAS ANNOUNCED THAT
IN THE NEXT SEVERAL WEEKS THE
VACCINATION EFFORTS STATEWIDE
WILL BE COORDINATED BY A THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR. BLUE
SHIELD OF CALIFORNIA WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH BLUE
SHIELD AND THE STATE TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE AN EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE VACCINE DISTRIBUTION
SYSTEM. THAT MEETS THE NEEDS OF
OUR COMMUNITIES- THING I WOULD
LIKE TO SHARE SEVERAL
RECOMMENDATIONS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. FIRST TO ENSURE
EQUITABLE EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF VACCINE WE URGE
THE STATE TO ALLOW LOCAL JR
HEALTHCARE SECTIONS TO IDENTIFY
THE OPTIMAL. PROVIDER NETWORKS
TO SERVE THEIR COMMUNITIES IN
PARTICULAR FQHCS ARE KEY
COMMUNITY PARTNERS IN OUR
COUNTY ESPECIALLY IN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES AND THEY NEED
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AND
FUNDING TO BEST MEET THE NEEDS
OF THEIR CLIENTS. SECOND
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL AND STATE
REVENUE IS CRITICAL IN
PROVIDING LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS WITH THE
RESOURCES AND FLEXIBILITY TO
IMPLEMENT. THE MERRY OUT OF
ACTIVITIES NECESSARY TO SLOW
THE SPREAD OF THIS VIRUS.
INCLUDING THE SWIFT AND BROAD
ADMINISTRATION OF A COVER
NINETEEN VACCINES. IN ADDITION
TO THE STATE CENTRALIZE ROLE
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH WILL
CONTINUE TO DELIVER VACCINES AS
WELL AS CONDUCT COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT COMMUNICATIONS DATA
TRACKING AND ANALYSIS. AND
INSURING EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION.
THIRTY WILL BE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT A LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS HAVE I'M GOING AND
TIMELY ACCESS TO DATA. ON
VACCINE ALLOCATIONS AND DOSES
ADMINISTERED WITHIN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS TO SUPPORT LOCAL
PLANNING AND EVALUATION AND LET
ME UNDERSCORE WHAT DOCTOR
SYSTEMS THAT IT REALLY MUST BE
ACCURATE DATA. LASTLY GIVEN THE
URGENCY OF SCALING UP
VACCINATIONS QUICKLY FACING
LIMITED VACCINE SUPPLIES
CONSISTENT AND COORDINATED
MESSAGING FROM THE STATE WILL
BE ESSENTIAL IN SUPPORTING
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. IN
THEIR EFFORTS TO MANAGE PUBLIC
EXPECTATIONS AND MAINTAIN THE
PUBLIC'S TRUST AND SUPPORT FOR
THE VACCINATION ROLLOUT. THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO DISCUSS LA COUNTY'S CULVER
NINETEEN VACCINATION.%
IMPLEMENTED IMPLEMENTATION
EFFORTS WITH YOU I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. DR PAUL SO AT THIS
TIME WILL OPEN UP FOR
DISCUSSION I JUST HAVE ONE
QUICK QUESTION WHEN ASKED WE'RE
TALKING A LOT ABOUT EQUITY
SEEMS A BIG. ISSUE DAILY THAT
THERE WERE WILL BE TALKED ABOUT
HERE AND THE LEGISLATURE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES IS THERE A WAY HOW
IN OUR LOCAL LEVELS WERE
MEASURING SUCCESSES PROVIDING
BOXING STAR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. WELL I WILL SAY
AGAIN THIS REQUIRES ACCURATE
DATA WE THERE'S A GREAT
INTEREST IN UNDERSTANDING WHAT.
WHAT THE LANDSCAPE LOOKS LIKE
HERE AND WE ARE STRUGGLING.
WITH THE DATA THEY MENTION WE
DID AN INITIAL ANALYSIS LOOKING
AT. HOWEVER PRESENTED. OUR
RACIAL AND ETHNIC GROUPS ARE
AMONG THOSE VACCINATED AND
FOUND THAT CERTAIN GROUPS ARE
UNDERREPRESENTED BUT- THE RACE
AND ETHNICITY DATA IS NOT
PARTICULARLY COMPLETE. IN THE
CARE SYSTEM. AND IN ADDITION
THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
ACCURACY IS AS WELL. THIS IS
DOCTOR SAYS IT ALL ECHO WHAT
WHAT DOCTOR PAUL L. A. COUNTY
SAID- WE DID INITIAL ANALYSIS
OF THOSE VACCINATED AND YOU'LL
COUNTY SO FAR BY RACE AND
ETHNICITY AND WE'VE SEEN THAT
ONLY ABOUT 15% OF THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN VACCINATED ARE
HISPANIC OR LATINO YET THEY
REPRESENT 32% OF OUR
POPULATION- BUT APPROXIMATELY A
THIRD OF PEOPLE WHO'VE
EXACERBATED THERE IS NO DATA.
ON THEIR RACE OR ETHNICITY SO
THAT THE DATA IS INCOMPLETE AND
THEN WE ALSO KNOW THAT THAT
SOME OF THE DATA. SOME OF THE
DOSES THAT HAVE BEEN
ADMINISTERED AREN'T SHOWING UP
AT ALL IN THE IMMUNIZATION
REGISTRY WHERE WERE PULLING UP
RACE AND ETHNICITY DATA FROM.
ON THE BACK AND SO I THINK
THERE'S WE HAVE SEVERAL
CONCERNS ABOUT THE QUALITY OF
THE DATA THAT WE'RE USING TO
DETERMINE. THE EQUITY OF OUR
VACCINE ROLLOUT. OKAY THANK YOU
SO ANY. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAD A QUESTION. A
QUESTION OF VICE CHAIR KELLY
HAD A QUESTION THANK YOU- FIRST
OFFER EACH YEAR COUNTIES DO
EACH OF YOU HAVE THE MAXIMUM
NUMBER OF THEIR DISTRIBUTION
CAPABILITY FOR YOUR COUNTY.
VETERANS HOW MANY HOW MANY
DOSES CAN YOU GIVE A WEEK. SO
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY IDEALLY
WE'D LIKE TO SEE UPWARDS OF
ABOUT A HALF A MILLION. DOSES A
WEEK. THAT MAY SOUND LIKE AN
AWFUL LOT BUT WE HAVE TEN
MILLION PEOPLE IN THE COUNTY
AND EIGHT MILLION ADULTS. AND
DIFFICULT HOLLISTER VACCINATE
75% OF THEM WITHIN A- SIX MONTH
PERIOD WE NEED ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOSES A WEEK
RIGHT AND WE HAVE A VERY ROBUST
NETWORK OF PROVIDERS AND I
THINK WE COULD BARELY VERY
QUICKLY RAMP UP. TO THAT LEVEL
THE VACCINATION- IF WE HAVE
SUFFICIENT SUPPLY. SORRY DO YOU
HAVE THE CAPABILITY TO DELIVER
THAT FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND IF
YOU IF YOU WERE ABLE TO GET. WE
DO WE DO OKAY I WILL SAY THOUGH
THAT I HAVE NO CONCERNS ABOUT
THE VALUE MY BIGGER CONCERN IS
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
REACH THOSE POPULATIONS THAT
MAY BE HESITANT. TO BE
VACCINATED OR FOR WHATEVER
REASON HAVE DIFFICULTY
ACCESSING NEEDED SERVICES SO I
THINK WE HAVE TO SACRIFICE.
SACRIFICE VOLUME IN SOME CASES
TO TRY TO REACH THOSE. ARE
GROUPS THAT HISTORICALLY OF THE
HAVE- NOT BEEN ADEQUATELY
SERVED THAT WAS GONNA BE A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION FOR ME FROM
YOLO COUNTY CAN I HEAR YOUR
MAXIMUM CAPABILITY PER WEEK.
YEAH I THINK IT WOULD BE
SOMEWHERE AROUND TEN THOUSAND A
WHICH WOULD HAVE A SAID
MINISTERING ABOUT FOURTEEN
HUNDRED DOSES A DAY. WE CAN
EASILY DO A THOUSAND DOSES A
DAY AND NIGHT IN A DRIVE
THROUGH CLINIC AND WE'VE WE'VE
DONE. MULTIPLE OCCASIONS SO I
THINK GETTING TO TEN THOUSAND
IN A WEEK OUR WOULD BE WOULD BE
DOABLE AND THAT BY COMPARISON
WERE WE GOT TWO THOUSAND THIS
WEEK SO WE COULD DO AT LEAST
FIVE TIMES WHAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
RECEIVING. OKAY THANK YOU AND
THEN. ON TO THE SECOND QUESTION
ABOUT THE DISTRIBUTION INTO.
AREAS WHERE WE ARE INTO
MINORITY COMMUNITIES WHERE WE
MAY NOT BE GETTING- DID THE-
COOPERATION WE WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO GET PEOPLE. DO WE KNOW
WHY- THIS IS IT ACCESS IS IT
INFORMATION OR IS IT HESITANCY
ON THEIR PART. BECAUSE OF. VS
NOTIONS THAT- R. FX AND THEY'VE
HAD WITH OUR EFFORTS TO THEY'VE
HAD WITH THE VACCINES ARE THEY
AFRAID TO GET IT OR THEY JUST
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO GET. WELL
I GUESS I'LL START I THINK IT'S
A COMBINATION OF THOSE FACTORS
YOU'VE MENTIONED I THINK THERE.
YOU KNOW THEY'RE AFRAID BUT BUT
IT'S MORE COMPLEX THAN THAT IN
SOME CASES IT'S ALSO JUST A
GENERAL LACK OF TRUST GIVEN.
RIGHT HISTORICAL EXPERIENCES OF
GROUPS OR YOU KNOW EXPERIENCE
OF EXPERIENCES HAVE GIVEN
INDIVIDUALS IN IN OUR SYSTEMS
OF CARE. THEY'RE JUST AS A
GENERAL LACK OF TRUST. AND-
SOME DOUBT AS TO WHETHER THE
VACCINES ARE SAFE AND REALLY
WORK. BUT IN ADDITION THERE IS
NO QUESTION THAT WE'RE SEEING
CHALLENGES. AMONG SOME GROUPS
AND NAVIGATING OUR SYSTEM IS.
HIM TO WRAP UP VOLUME L. A.
COUNTY WE'VE WE'VE OPENS-
STICKS VERY LARGE POTS POINTS
OF DISPENSING. AND THAT'S BEEN
VERY SUCCESSFUL IN GETTING MORE
VACCINE IN PEOPLE'S ARMS BUT IT
HAPPENED. ADDRESSING THE EQUITY
ISSUE THAT THOSE GROUPS THAT.
YOU KNOW MAY MOST NEED VACCINE
ARE ALWAYS WELL SERVED BY THESE
LARGE POTS PARTICULARLY SENIORS.
BUT ALSO- RACIAL AND ETHNIC
GROUPS I THINK. THE BEST
SUCCESS WILL BE SEEN IF WE'RE
ABLE TO PROVIDE VACCINE TO
TRUSTED PROVIDERS WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITIES CLINICS AND ALSO
PHARMACY'S- AS WELL. AND YOUR.
YEAH I AGREE WITH WHAT. DR PAUL
HAS HAS SAID IN AN L. A. COUNTY
I THINK THERE ARE SEVERAL
FACTORS FOR WHY IT'S BEEN
DIFFICULT TO REACH CERTAIN
POPULATIONS AND SOME THAT ARE
REALLY SPECIFIC TO THE FACT
THAT IT'S THE OVER OR SIXTY
FIVE AND OLDER POPULATION WHICH
IN GENERAL TEND TO BE LESS
CONNECTED THROUGH TECHNOLOGY
AND- YOU KNOW COMPUTERS EMAIL
TEXT MESSAGES OR SOCIAL MEDIA
EASIEST WAY FASTEST WAY TO GET
INFORMATION OUT BUT THAT IS NOT
HOW WE ARE HAVING SUCCESS IN
REACHING THE SIXTY FIVE AND
OLDER COMMUNITY SELF. SO SLOWER
OUTREACH WITH MORE DOOR TO DOOR
BOOTS ON THE GROUND PHONE
CALLS- IS NECESSARY TO GET THAT
GROUP ENGAGED- WE ALSO SEE
LANGUAGE BARRIERS AND SO NEEDED
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
ADVERTISING EFFORTS ARE MULTI
LINGUAL ARE THERE ARE SOME
MISCONCEPTIONS AND FEARS ABOUT
THE VACCINE BUT WE'RE ALSO
SEEING WHERE UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITIES MAY BE NERVOUS
ABOUT MAKING AN APPOINTMENT IN
ADVANCE AND SO WHAT WE'VE DONE
AND YOU'LL COUNTY IS SETTING
ASIDE DOSES. OF FOR PEOPLE WHO
DON'T HAVE AN APPOINTMENT SO
THAT THEY CAN WALK IN- AND THEY
DON'T HAVE TO GIVE INFORMATION
TO THE GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENT IN
ADVANCE SO THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE BARRIERS THAT WERE SEEING
TO OUT REACH PARTICULARLY TO
THE LATINO AN OLDER ADULT
COMMUNITY. GREAT THANK YOU I
HAVE ONE MORE HOUR EACH
QUESTION BUT I'D RATHER WAIT
AND LET OTHERS ASKING QUESTIONS.
AND THEN I'LL ASK LATER THANK
YOU. OKAY I THINK SOME. A
DARKER. GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THANK YOU A BOTH- DR
SIMON IN THE SUN AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE HARD WORK
YOU'RE DOING YOU'RE DOING
INCREDIBLE JOB. DESPITE
EVERYTHING THAT WE ARE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT FOR YOU. HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS- WHAT
RESOURCES THE STRATEGIES ARE
BEING EMPLOYED TO CONNECT
PEOPLE WHO CAN'T ACCESS ONLINE
SCHEDULING PLATFORM WITH
VACCINATION APPOINTMENT. I KNOW
YOU MENTIONED GOING DOOR TO
DOOR PHONE CALLS BUT I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE ONLINE
SCHEDULING PLATFORM. YEAH ALL
RIGHT OF HEAD DOCTORS THAT.
STEPS THANK YOU A LOT OF ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THAT WERE DOING
IT IN YOLO COUNTY IS LEVERAGING
OUR TWO ONE ONE A RESOURCE SO
WE'VE PROVIDED THEM WITH
SCRIPTS AND I PUT THE WORD OUT
IN THE COMMUNITY THAT THEY IF
THEY DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
GO ONLINE TO MAKE AN
APPOINTMENT THAT THEY CAN CALL
TWO ONE ONE. AND TWO ONE ONE
HAS MULTIPLE LANGUAGE
CAPABILITIES AS AS WELL- SO IN
ADDITION TO OUR DOOR TO DOOR
OUTREACH WHERE WHERE PEOPLE CAN
GO DOOR TO DOOR WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY TO SIGN PEOPLE UP
THERE ALSO NOTIFYING PEOPLE
THAT THEY CAN CALL TWO ONE ONE
TO GET AN APPOINTMENT. THANK
YOU. I LIKE QUITE A LOT ANGELES
COUNTY REUSING TWO ONE ONE AND
WE'VE ALSO ESTABLISHED OUR OWN
CALL CENTER. YOU KNOW
ELIGIBILITY FOR VACCINATION WAS
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE THOSE SIXTY
FIVE AND OLDER. WHICH IS. ONE
POINT THREE MILLION PEOPLE IN
L. A. COUNTY. THE SYSTEM WAS
JUST ABSOLUTELY OVERWHELMED AND-
THAT'S WHY WE'VE I THINK ALSO
DECIDED TO ROLL OUT A MORE-
TARGETED APPROACH WERE USING A
MOBILE- UNITS TO ACTUALLY GO
DEEPER INTO COMMUNITIES TO TRY
TO HELP REGISTER PEOPLE FOR
VACCINATION WE HAVE A WHOLE
CADRE OF COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS THAT ARE. DIRECTLY OFF
WORKING WITH HIGH RISK GROUPS
AND THEN I THINK AS WE
TRANSITION INCREASINGLY INTO
THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
DELIVERING VACCINE IT WILL BE
EASIER I THINK FOR PEOPLE TO
GET. APPOINTMENTS HOPEFULLY
WITHIN THE SYSTEMS THAT THEY'RE
ALREADY FAMILIAR AND
COMFORTABLE WITH. CAN THE-
STATE DETAIL WHAT THE DATA
CHALLENGES CURRENTLY ARE AND
THE STEPS BEING TAKEN TO
ADDRESS THIS INCLUDING HOW MY
TURN CAN HELP CORRECT THEM. AND
I'M ASKING THIS IS BECAUSE OF
THE LEGISLATOR- I WANT TO KNOW
HOW CAN WE HELP YOU. IS THAT A
GOOD GOT A QUESTION FOR THE
STATE BOTH SIDES IN. I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
ALONG THE LINE AS WELL WITHOUT.
WITH THEIR WITH YOUR IMPORTANCE
OF HOW CAN THE STATE WHAT KIND
OF THE IT CHALLENGES DO YOU
FIRST SEE THEM HAVING RIGHT NOW
I DON'T KNOW. YOU KNOW IT'S
PRETTY OBVIOUS THAT THERE'S
MANY SYSTEMS THAT WE WERE ALL
WORKING WITH AND- OBVIOUSLY
SOUNDS VERY VERY COMPLICATED-
BUT WE'RE JUST WONDERING HOW
CAN WE HELP YOU. YOUR DOCTOR
SAYS AND ALL ALL THE- TIME AND-
I THINK THERE'S A THERE'S A FEW
CHALLENGES- SOME HAVE TO DEAL
WITH JUST A LARGE NUMBER OF
PROVIDERS IN THE VARIOUS
SYSTEMS IN WHICH DATA ARE BEING
IMPORTED AND SO- THERE AT THAT
THE STATE IS CURRENTLY DEALING
WITH A LOT OF ON MATCH DATA-
WHERE THEY HAVE SOME
INFORMATION BUT NOT ENOUGH
INFORMATION TO LINK THOSE DOSES
TO THE RIGHT PROVIDER IN THE
RIGHT COUNTY SO THEY'RE SHOWING
UP- AS- UNACCOUNTED FOR. BUT
THERE ARE AN ON MATCHED BUT
THERE'S ALSO SOME DOSES THAT
WE'RE SEEING IN IN YOLO COUNTY
THE 30% OF DOES IS THAT I
MENTIONED ARE MISSING FROM OUR
DATA. THEY'RE NOT ON MATCH THEY
JUST AREN'T SHOWING UP AT ALL
AND WE THINK THAT IT HAS%
SOMETHING TO DO WITH- SO. THE
WIN THAT DATA IS UPLOADED ON
THE BACK AND INTO THE
IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY THAT EVEN
THOUGH WE RECEIVE A
CONFIRMATION. THAT IT THE
UPLOAD HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL BUT
THAT SOMEHOW THAT DATA IS NOT
SHOWING UP IN THE REGISTRY
AFTER ALL. AND- IT SO I WOULD-
I CAN'T SPEAK TO WHY THAT'S
HAPPENING- BUT I DO THINK THAT
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PLACE FOR
THE STATE TO WALK BECAUSE I'M-
HEARING FROM MULTIPLE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS. IN THE
GENERAL IN THE GREATER
SACRAMENTO REGION THAT THEY'RE
EXPERIENCING THE SAME ISSUE
WITH MISSING DOSES. YEAH THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT POINT WHERE
WE'RE WE'RE- SEEING THE SAME
THING YOU'RE A LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND ARE CONCERNED. ON
THE REGISTRATION SITE MIGHT
TURN THEIR SOME FUNCTIONALITY.
PETER IS THAT I THINK WOULD BE
VERY VERY HELPFUL AND MAYBE THE
STATE IS ALREADY WORKING ON
THESE BUT FOR EXAMPLE WHEN
SOMEONE GOES IN. TO TRY TO MAKE
AN APPOINTMENT OR UNABLE TO DO
SO IF THERE WAS- AND I'M A
FUNCTION THAT WILL ALLOW THEM
TO LEAVE THEIR- NAME AND
WHATEVER OTHER INFORMATION IS
NECESSARY SO THAT ONE OF THE
APPOINTMENT DOES BECOME
AVAILABLE. THEY ARE IMMEDIATELY
NOTIFIED. AND CAN REGISTER SO
IN OTHER WORDS SORT OF LIKE A
WHIPPING WAITING LESS. AND IN
ADDITION IF THERE WAS A WAY FOR
FOLKS TO. PUT IN THE ZIP CODE.
OF RESIDENTS AND THEN- BE
NOTIFIED OF AVAILABLE POINT
APPOINTMENTS AT ANY SITES NEAR
WHERE THEY LIVE THAT WOULD ALSO
BE HELPFUL THESE ARE JUST A
COUPLE OF EXAMPLES WE HEAR LOTS
OF FEEDBACK FROM. OUR COMMUNITY
PARTNERS ON WAYS ASSISTANCE
COULD BE IMPROVED. FINAL
QUESTION BECAUSE SOME RUMOR
PETRIE-NORRIS THE QUESTION.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU BOTH AT
THINK YOU BOTH FOR BEING HERE
AND SHARING- THAT THAT LOCAL
PERSPECTIVE I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT I'M STRUCK BY THE
FACT THAT WE KIND OF GOT THE A
SMALLER COUNTY AND THEN WE HAVE
THE LARGEST COUNTY IN THE STATE
AND YOU ALL HAVE ACTUALLY
REALLY SIMILAR PERSPECTIVE ON
SOME OF THE KEY CHALLENGES AND
AT. THE KEY ISSUES THAT WE NEED
TO CONFRONT I HAVE A QUESTION
RELATED TO- THE- ANNOUNCED THE
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT WE ARE GOING
TO BE TRANSITIONING TO A THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR SYSTEM AND
THAT- RULING THAT OUT SHORTLY I
THINK FROM MY PERSPECTIVE ONE
OF THE MOST IMPORTANT FACTORS
IN OUR ABILITY TO SUCCEED IN
VACCINATING CALIFORNIANS
QUICKLY SAFELY AND EQUITABLY IS
ENSURING THAT THERE'S CLARITY
AROUND EVERYBODY'S ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES AND WHO'S
DOING WHAT AND HOW THE PIECES
OF THE PUZZLE FIT TOGETHER. I
KNOW WHEN THAT ENHANCEMENT WAS
FIRST MADE THERE WAS A LOT OF
QUESTIONS FROM A LOT OF
COUNTIES ABOUT WHAT THAT MEANT
FOR THEM AND I THINK THAT THAT
CREATED A LOT OF CONFUSION- I'M
FOR BOTH OF YOU HAVE THOSE
QUESTIONS BEEN ANSWERED AND HAS
THAT THAT AREA OF CONFUSION
BEEN CLARIFIED OR IS THAT IS
THAT STILL SOMETHING THAT- THAT
NEEDS TO BE CLARIFIED FOR YOU.
YEAH FROM MY PERSPECTIVE HERE
IN IN YOLO COUNTY WE STILL
HAVE. MANY QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT
THE THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR
BEING BROUGHT ON WILL WILL MEAN
FOR US AT THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT LEVEL IT'S BEEN
SUGGESTED THAT WILL RECEIVE
FEWER DOSES. AND THAT OUR ROLE
WILL BE TO FOCUS ON THE
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES- BUT
THAT'S REALLY KIND OF ALL WE
KNOW ABOUT- WHAT THINGS WILL
LOOK LIKE IN THERE THERE REALLY
IS A SHORTAGE OF. OF DETAIL FOR
WHAT THIS WILL LOOK LIKE ON A
DAY TO DAY BASIS FOR HOW THINGS
WILL BE DONE DIFFERENTLY AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL UNDER THE THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR- SEVERAL
REALLY AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY
WE HAVE. UNANSWERED QUESTIONS
AND- I BELIEVE OUR DIRECTOR AND
HEALTH OFFICER. WILL VERY
SHORTLY BE IN DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE STATE TO. TRY TO. ADDRESS
THOSE THOSE QUESTIONS. THANKS
THAT'S HELPFUL. ALL RIGHT IN
NEW MANAGER COULD I HAVE ONE
MORE CLASS ONE LAST QUESTION I
HAD. SO I BELIEVE THE
DISTRIBUTION AND HOW IT'S DONE
IS BEING DECIDED AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL IS THAT NOT YOUR
UNDERSTANDING FOR BOTH OF YOU.
IT DEPENDS ON IF THEIR DOSES
THAT CALM TO THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT OR DOSES THAT GO TO
A MULTI COUNTY AND CITY OR
LARGE HOSPITAL SYSTEM. SO IF
IT'S DOSES THAT COMES OF THE
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT ON THE
HELP OFFICER OR SOMEBODY ELSE
AT THE LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT
DETERMINES HOW THOSE DOSES
ARGUES USE WHETHER THEY'RE
CAPPED BY THAT THE COUNTY
HEALTH DEPARTMENT- IT.
ALLOCATED SO FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTERS OR OR
OTHER PROVIDERS BUT IF IT'S A
DOES THAT'S ALLOCATED DIRECTLY
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO A LARGE
HEALTH SYSTEM THAT'S DONE AT
THE STATE WIDER THE REGIONAL
LEVEL. AND THEN WITHIN THEIR AT
THEIR HEADQUARTERS OR OUR
MOTHER SHIP IF IT WORKS THEY
MAKE THE DECISIONS ABOUT HOW TO
DISTRIBUTE WITHIN THEIR OWN
SYSTEMS- AND THAT'S NOT
CONNECTED TO A COUNTY LEVEL IT
IN MANY CASES SO FOR EXAMPLE.
KAISER DOES NOT HAVE A HOSPITAL
IN YOLO COUNTY BUT THEY DO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO MANY OF OUR
OUR RESIDENTS BUT THEY DON'T
KAISERDOESN'T HAVE A PIECE OF
THE VACCINE PIE THAT GETS
DIVIDED UP. FOR YOU'LL COUNTY
RESIDENTS INSTEAD YOU'LL COUNTY
RESIDENTS WOULD RECEIVE A
VACCINE FROM KAISER OUT OF
FACILITY AND EITHER SOLANO
COUNTY OR SACRAMENTO COUNTY SO
THE EMBASSY IS DON'T
NECESSARILY THINK ABOUT DOES
THIS FROM THE PERSPECTIVE. OF
THE COUNTY OF RESIDENCE AT ALL
OKAY. SO THE REASON I ASK THAT
QUESTION IS BECAUSE I WAS
WONDERING IF THE COUNTIES HAVE
CONSIDER THAT COUNTY HEALTH
DEPARTMENT HAVE CONSIDERED
USING BECAUSE THIS IS A BIG
LOGISTICS ISSUES WHAT IT IS.
AND IN ORDER TO DO A
DISTRIBUTION YOU NEED TO GET
EVERYTHING ORGANIZED AND PUT
HIM IN THE DIFFERENT PARTS OF
WORK. AND WE DO HAVE AGENCIES
DISTRICTS AS CENTER OUT THERE
LIKE A SCHOOL DISTRICT. THAT
HAVE THE CAPABILITIES TO
ORGANIZE COMMUNICATE. AND
DISTRIBUTE- USING PERSONNEL
THERE ARE AND- THAT CAN
ACTUALLY CARE OF PROBLEM ONE
THING ONE OF A IS GETTING OUR-
BACK TO SCHOOL. AND THE OTHER
ONE IS GETTING THE TEACHER
PACKAGE TEACHERS VACCINATED
WHICH CAN ALSO TRANSLATE INTO
FURTHER IF THEY'RE SUCCESSFUL.
GETTING THE PARENTS OF THOSE
STUDENTS VACCINATED ALSO. SO
I'M WONDERING IF THERE IS AN
OUTREACH EFFORT TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO PERHAPS GET THEM
INVOLVED IS A POD- TO. BE ABLE
TO COORDINATE AND DISTRIBUTION
PROCESS BECAUSE THEY'RE DIVIDED
INTO CLASSROOMS THEY CAN EASILY
MANAGE PEOPLE. THEY HAVE
COMMUNICATION SYSTEMS IN PLACE
TO COMMUNICATE WITH EVERY
SINGLE PARENT. IT TAKES CARE OF
ALSO TAKES CARE OF THE ISSUE
OF- ACT IT'LL PULL
DISTRIBUTION- I KNOW IN OUR
DISTRICT IN THE AREA THAT WE
COULD HAVE EVERY TEACHER
VACCINATED IN TWO DAYS USING
THE R. ENDS THAT WE HAVE. AND
SO I'M WONDERING IF THAT HIS
BAND BECAUSE THAT'S LIKE TO ME.
A LOT OF TIMES IT'S ABOUT
GETTING THE LOCAL LOW HANGING
FRUIT AND THATSEEMS TO BE
SOMETHING THAT. HAS BEEN
OVERLOOKED IN A IN A POTENTIAL
WHEN DID TO GET THESE
VACCINATIONS OUT. AND TAKE CARE
OF ANOTHER PROBLEM BESIDES JUST
TRYING TO GET TO THE SIXTY FIVE
AND OLDER IS. BECAUSE ALL OF
ANY OF IT HELPS. BECAUSE IT
TAKES THEM OUT OF THE SYSTEM OF
NEED. AND AND THEY CAN DO IT A
LOT QUICKER THAN WE CAN ALL
MEN. AND THEY ALSO HAVE A LOT
OF PARENTS THAT ARE MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS DOCTORS NURSES.
AND PROBABLY CAN ASSEMBLE A
PRETTY GOOD VOLUNTEER NETWORK-
TO ASSIST IN THAT AND- SO I WAS
JUST CURIOUS IF YOU GUYS HAVE.
THOUGHT OF THAT I KNOW MIGHT BE
A LITTLE HARDER IN L. A.
COUNTY- BUT SOME OF THE SMALLER.
AIRCRAFT MIGHT. CIGRAND ACTUAL
A LOT OF INTEREST IN L. A. K.
AMONG SCHOOL DISTRICTS- LA
UNIFIED UP FOR EXAMPLE IS
ALREADY MOVING IN THIS
DIRECTION AND- PARTNERING WITH
SOME CITIES. IN ADDITION CITIES
ARE VERY INTERESTED- AND THEY
HAVE- YOU STAFF THE MERGES C.
RESPOND YOURS WHO ACTUALLY CAN
ADMINISTER BACKSTAGE AND THEY
HAVE GREAT LOGISTICS SUPPORT.
COOL DISTRICTS EAGER TO HELP
OUT YEAH REALLY THE LIMITING
STEP HERE GIVEN HIS VACCINE. SO
WE WERE ABLE TO GET MORE
VACCINES WE MAY BE ABLE TO HELP
THAT DISTRIBUTION PROCESS. AND
THEY COULD BE LOCALIZED IN THAT
WAY. AND SPEED THAT UP
ABSOLUTELY. YEAH THAT'S ALL I
HAVE RIGHT THANK YOU I'M HAPPY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER YEAH.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND- JUST
JUST A COMMENT NOT A QUESTION-
BUT JUST SOME OBSERVATIONS I
THINK FROM WHAT I HEARD OF THE
PANELISTS I THINK ONE IDEA THAT
I THOUGHT WAS PRETTY GOOD AS
MAY BE UTILIZING FQHCS- A LOT
MORE THAN WE HAVE BEEN AND I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE- I THINK
THE PRESIDENT AND THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS STARTED
SAYING HEY WE'RE GOING TO SEND.
VACCINES DIRECTLY TO IT FQHCS
IN MY EXPERIENCE ANYWAY. THEY
DO OFTEN HAVE A LOT BETTER
CONNECTION TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. AND HELP AND OUT
REACH ALREADY IN PLACE THAT I
THINK COULD BE HELPFUL SO I
THINK THAT WAS A GOOD. THE
THING THAT CAME OUT OF THIS- I
THINK WE ALL HEARD. POOR DATA.
AND SO YOU KNOW WE NEED BETTER
TRANSPARENCY ON. HOW MUCH
VACCINE IS ACTUALLY BEEN OUT
THERE HAS IT GOT NOW- AND
BETTER DATA TRUCK TRACKING. AND
SO THAT WAS ANOTHER THING THAT
I THINK I HEARD- IN THIS PANEL-
ONE OTHER THING WE DIDN'T TALK
ABOUT SO MUCH BUT I THINK IT'S
STILL A BIG ISSUE IS. THERE'S A
LOT OF DISPARITY AS TO HOW THIS
THING IS BEING DONE AND SO FOR
INSTANCE. IT WAS MEANT IT WAS
REFERENCE LITTLE BIT THE
GOVERNOR ANNOUNCED THAT SIXTY
FIVE AND OLDER AND FRONTLINE-
WORKERS IN ONE B. WOULD BE ABLE
TO BE VACCINATED TOGETHER. SOME
COUNTIES ARE NOT DOING THAT YOU
KNOW- SOME KIND YOU'RE SAYING
NO ONLY SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER.
AND IT CREATES CONFUSION
BECAUSE PEOPLE THEN GO TO SIGN
UP AND THINK THAT THEY CAN GET
VACCINATED. AND THEY CAN'T AND
SO. AS MUCH AS THERE IS SOME
CONCERN ABOUT. YOU KNOW THIS
CHANGE MAY WHAT WE DO REALLY
NEED IS A UNIFIED- SYSTEM THAT
EVERYBODY KNOWS THIS IS YOU CAN
SIGN UP AND YOU ARE AVAILABLE
TO GET VACCINATED THAT WE DON'T
HAVE DISPARITIES IN MY OWN
DISTRICT. BUTTE COUNTY FOR
INSTANCE IS HAS DONE A
TREMENDOUS JOB OF DOING BOTH.
THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO GET BOTH
SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER. AND
EDUCATORS AND OTHERS AND ONE BE
VACCINATED. NO OTHER COUNTIES
DECIDED NOT TO DO THAT BUT- IT
SHOULD BE DIFFERENT DEPENDING
ON WHERE YOU LIVE RIGHT. OR
WHAT YOUR ZIP CODE IS. ARE
CERTAINLY WHAT YOU'RE RACES
RIGHT AND SO WE NEED TO. REALLY
ENSURE THAT THAT'S UNIFIED AND
WE'RE GETTING ALL TO. ALL THESE
AREAS AND MUCH AS I THINK
THERE'S BEEN GREAT JOB DONE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL- WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS NOT WORKING WE DO NEED
SOMETHING DIFFERENT. WORK WE
ARE LATINO AGAIN WE SEEM MORE
LIKE CLOSE TO LAST PLACE IN
GETTING THE VACCINE OUT SO.
THERE DOES NEED TO BE SOME
CHANGE. AND HOW WE MOVE FORWARD
I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE ON
THAT. WITH THAT GIVE PERFECTLY
TEED UP OUR SECOND PANEL THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER.
AND THANK YOU DOCTOR SIMON AND
DOCTORS TO SEND BOTH FOR
JOINING US TODAY AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY FOR. I'M JUST THE
REALLY HERCULEAN WORK THAT YOU
AND YOUR TEAMS HAVE BEEN DOING
FOR COMMUNITIES OVER. OVER THE
PAST YEAR- THANK YOU. ALRIGHT
WITH THAT WE'LL MOVE TO OUR
SECOND PANEL WHICH- WILL BE AN
UPDATE FIVE STATE UPDATE AND
AFFECTS IN DISTRIBUTION
PLANNING. WE WILL BE JOINED BY
A NUMBER OF REPRESENTATIVES
FROM THE MINISTRATION DR THOMAS
ARAGON WHO IS THE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. YOUR LENDER
RICHARDSON THE SECRETARY OF THE
CALIFORNIA GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY MARTA GREEN
THE PROJECT COORDINATOR AT THE
STATE WIDE VACCINE NETWORK T.
PA. TINA CURRY THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FROM CALLAWAY EST
LORENA SERRA THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF PLANNING FROM HELLO
YES. MARICELA RODRIGUEZ THE
DIRECTOR OF CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
AND STRATEGIC PARTNERSHIPS FROM
THE OFFICE OF THE GOVERNOR- I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
JOINING US TODAY AND WE'RE
LOOKING FOR TO YOU REALLY
INFORMATIVE AND PRODUCTIVE
DISCUSSION. I WITH THAT I WILL
GO AHEAD AND DO THAT HE HANDED
OVER TO AFTER ARAGON TO BUS
STARTED. WHAT GOOD AFTERNOON
AND MEMBERS I'M DOCTOR THE LAST
ARTICLE STAPLE HEALTH OFFICER
AND DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH MY
PRIOR TO BECOMING THE DIRECTOR
OF C. PH I WORKED IN SAN
FRANCISCO OVER TWENTY YEARS AND
HEALTH OFFICER ROLES WAS A
HEALTH OFFICER SERVICES
CURRENTLY WORK FOR TEN YEARS I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE TO OUR PRESENT
INFORMATION CALL WITH FAXING
DISTRIBUTION IN CALIFORNIA. TO
BRING YOU UP TO DATE THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS
HAVE BEEN WORKING TIRELESSLY TO
ADMINISTER OVER FIVE MILLION
VACCINES IN THE LAST NINE WEEKS
WE ARE NOW DOING IS A STATE
MORE THAN A HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND FIVE VACCINES PER WEEK
GARY THE ELIGIBILITY YOU'RE
CURRENTLY AWARE OF WHICH IS
HEALTH CARE WORKERS LONG TERM
CARE RESIDENTS INDIVIDUALS OVER
SIXTY FIVE AND WORKERS IN
EDUCATION AND CHILD CARE FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE. AND EMERGENCY
SERVICES. COUNTIES MAY BE INTO
PLACES ALONG THIS CONTINUUM
DEPENDING ON THE POPULATION
SIZE SO SOME HAVE SOME HAVE
MOVED FORWARD AND ARE DOING OUT
OF THISWORK SECTORS IN SUMMER
STILL FOCUSING ON A SIXTY FIVE
THAT'S ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT
WE NEED TO IMPROVE ON. THE
FEDERAL PHARMACY PARTNERSHIP
FOR LONG TERM CARE PROGRAM
WHICH IN CALIFORNIA INVOLVED
CVS TO WALGREENS. HAS
VACCINATED OVER FOUR HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THOUSAND OF OUR
ACTUALLY HAVE ADMINISTERED OVER
FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
VACCINES. IN THE STATE OF
NURSING HOMES. CURRENTLY WE
HAVE FOUR THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED SIX PROVIDERS WERE
SIGNED UP TO PROVIDE VACCINES
THROUGHOUT. THE STATE. STARTING
ON FEBRUARY TWELFTH THE FEDERAL
RETAIL PHARMACY PROGRAM WILL
BEGIN NATION WIDE OR FORTY
THOUSAND LOCATIONS INCLUDING
HUNDREDS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
WILL INVOLVE CVS AND RITE AID.
AND THEY WILL BE RECEIVING-
DIRECTOR ALLOCATION FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. I THANK GOD
THAT ISN'T IN ADDITION TO WHAT
THIS. WHAT ARE CALIFORNIA'S
GETTING. HELLO PER RIGHT NOW
TELL REMAINS THE AMOUNT OF
VACCINE AVAILABLE THE STATE.
ULTIMATELY OUR SUCCESS AND
BACKS DISTRIBUTION IS DEPENDING
ON RECEIVING A SUFFICIENT AND
RELIABLE SUPPLY OF VACCINES
FROM. THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
I'M GOING TO MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS ON A PRIORITIZATION
VACCINE ARE PLENTY BEGAN IN
APRIL OF- TWENTY TWENTY AND IT
RELY PRIMARILY ON. GLOBALIZING
OUR WELL ESTABLISHED EXISTING
UTILIZATION AND EMERGENCY ROOM
RESPONSE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
EXISTS THAT HAD ALREADY
EXISTED. THE BIG CHALLENGE
THERE ARE ALWAYS REALLY THE
SCALE AND SPEED OF DISTRIBUTION
THAT'S REQUIRED FOR KOBE
NINETEEN VACCINATION IT'S MUCH
LARGER THAN ANYTHING WE'VE EVER
SEEN BEFORE THEIR EXTRA
CHALLENGES WITH FAXING.
ESPECIALLY THE FIRST TWO THAT
ARE- THAT APPROVED WHICH IS
ULTRA COLD STORAGE REQUIREMENT
TO USE A VACCINE IMMEDIATELY
REQUIRING PERSONS TO COME BACK
FOR THE SECOND DOES TWO TO
THREE WEEKS LATER. THAT'S PART
OF PLANNING GOVERNING USING
CREATED THREE ADVISORY
COMMITTEES INCLUDING THE
SCIENTIFIC SAFETY REVIEW
WORKGROUP. A GUIDELINE DRAFTING
WORK GROUP. AND THE COMMUNITY
VACCINE ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
THESE THREE COME OF HOW KILL
SURE BACK SAFE. PROVIDE A
FRAMEWORK FOR DISTRIBUTION
PRIORITIES TO RECEIVE FEEDBACK
FROM KEY STAKEHOLDERS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY OF THE PUBLIC. ON
OUR ON A REGULAR BASIS WE ALSO
COMMUNICATE DIRECTLY WITH THE
HEALTH EXECUTIVES IN THE HEALTH
OFFICERS ARE CALIFORNIA TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE GETTING THEIR
INPUT AS WELL. I WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT THE FIRST SHIPMENTS
CAME TO CALIFORNIA ON DECEMBER
FOURTEENTH AND I DO WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT THIS IS REALLY
HISTORIC THAT WITHIN A YEAR OF
A- OF A OF A GLOBAL PANDEMIC OF
THE SEVERITY THAT WE ACTUALLY
EVEN HAVE A VACCINE- SO IT'S
BOTH IT'S BOTH POSITIVE BUT THE
CHIP BUT WE STILL HAVE CHECK
OUR CHALLENGES AHEAD. THE
FAXING PRIORITIZATION APPROACH
WAS STARTED WITH THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE ON IMMUNIZATION
PRACTICES ARE WHAT WE CALL A C.
I. P. OUR OUR- GUYS. GROUP IN
OUR COMMUNITY FAXING ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WORKED WITH THIS
INFORMATION AND SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE. TO DEVELOP A VACCINE
PRIORITIES FOR CALIFORNIA THIS
IS WHAT WE NOW CALL PHASE ONE
A. AND ONE B. WHICH IS OUR AND
OUR- OUR COBIT. NINETEEN DOT CA
DOT GOV WEBSITE. THE CURRENT
ALLOCATION WORKS LIKE THIS. WE
TAKE WEEKLY AMOUNTS OF VACCINE
FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
DIVIDE THEM CURRENTLY TO TWO
POLES. 20% OF THE VACCINES GO
TO THE MULTI COUNTY ENTITIES
THAT YOU HEARD ABOUT THE
KAISER'S INSIDERS THE DIGNITY.
THE UC SYSTEM. AND 80% OF THE
VACCINES GO TO LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS AS YOU HEARD FROM
THE HEALTH OFFICERS. UNDER THE
CURRENT SYSTEM ALLOCATION
FORMULA. IS BASED ON THE SIZE
OF THE PRIORITY GROUP IN THEIR
IN THEIR COUNTY- MULTI COUNTY
ENTITY. WE ARE TO BECAUSE WE
TRANSITION INTO ONE BEING. THAT
THE FORMULA IS NOW MORE
POPULATION BASED AS OPPOSED TO.
INITIALLY. WHICH WAS PRIMARILY
HEALTH CARE BASED. ONE THING WE
RELY THAT ALL OF THIS WOULD
HAPPEN AT THE VERY TIME VERY
SAME TIME THAT WE HAVE THIS
TREMENDOUS SURGE. THE SURGE
REALLY FOCUS NOT FORCES TO
REALLY THINK ABOUT HOW. WE CAN
IMPROVE OUR RACKS AND
VACCINATION APPROACH REALLY
FOCUSING ON SAVING LIVES TO
ACHIEVING EQUITY. AND REALLY
THERE IS THREE THREE KEY WORDS
ARE REALLY SORT OF CAME OUT OF
AND THAT IS REALLY FOCUSING ON
SPEED SIMPLICITY AND SCALE. BOB
BECAUSE HE REALIZES THAT WEEK
IN ORDER FOR IN ORDER FOR US TO
IMPACT THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
MOST IMPACTED NOT JUST PEOPLE
WHO ARE OLDER. BUT AMONG THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE OLDER. THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THEM ARE PEOPLE WHO-CAME FROM FROM
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES PRIMARILY LATINO.
AND AFRICAN AMERICAN. SO FOR ME
AS A CDPH DIRECTOR PART OF MY
ROLE IS TO REALLY SORT OF FOCUS
ON HEALTH EQUITY. WE'VE BEEN
WORKING CLOSELY WITH DR NADINE
BURKE HARRIS OF THE SURGEON
GENERAL CALIFORNIA TO DEVELOP
EQUITY METRICS AND ALLOCATION
PRINCIPLES ENSURE VACCINE IS
DISTRIBUTED TO THE MOST
IMPACTED AREA. ACCORDING WITH
THE AIM OF THIS AS LAUNCHING A
VACCINATION A PILOT SITES IN
OAKLAND AND LOS ANGELES THERE
WILL ALSO BE. ALSO BE WORKING
TO SET OF SIGHTS AND OTHER
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE
BEEN HIGHLY HIGHLY IMPACTED. I
WANTED KNOWLEDGE THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF LESSONS LEARNED AND
AGAIN JUST TO GO BACK TO THE
IDEA HERE IS SPEED SIMPLICITY
AND SCALE. YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD
A LOT OF ISSUES AROUND THE DATA
WE HAVE TO IMPROVE THE DATA. WE
WANT TO WE WANT TO MINIMIZE THE
VERY ABILITY THAT'S AND THAT'S
UNNECESSARY. AND THE OTHER
THING THAT WE NEED TO DO IS WE
NEED TO SUPPORT. NEED TO
SUPPORT THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES
THE LOCAL HEALTH SYSTEMS THE
PHARMACY SYSTEMS ARE CLINICS OR
SOMETHING AND ALL OF US NEED TO
COME TOGETHER TO WORK ON OUR
STRENGTH. TO DO WHAT WE'RE BEST
AT TO DO WHAT WE'RE BEST AT
DOING AND THAT'S REALLY WHY THE
THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR WAS
BROUGHT ON BOARD. THE SCALE OF
THE MAGNITUDE OF THE WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH. WE NEED EVERY HAND
ON DECK WE NEED EVERY WE NEED
IT EVERYBODY EVERYBODY THE
HOUSE THE CORE COMPETENCIES
THAT'S GOING TO MAKE A LARGE
SCALE- VACCINATION PROGRAM
SUCCESSFUL. IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING OUR LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS OUR COUNTIES AND
OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS SO THAT'S WHY
WE'RE PITTING WERE- COMMITTEE
TO THIS APPROACH. I'M GONNA
TURN IT OVER NOW TO SECONDARY
ALONG THE RICHARDSON WHO'S
GONNA BEGIN TO PRESENT YOU BY
THE THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR.
AND THE GOALS OF THE
PARTNERSHIP I WILL BE AVAILABLE
HERE FOR QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE
TRICIA BLOCKER. WHO'S R. C. PH
ARE- PROGRAM READY FOR
VACCINATIONS AND WILL BE
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS LATER.
BOB BAKKEN TRIP OVER TO
SECRETARY. RICHARDSON THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DR DON APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENTS GOOD AFTERNOON
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR TODAY TO
SHARE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
INTENSIVE WORK UNDER WAY TO
BUILD THE STATEWIDE VACCINE
DELIVERY NETWORK. AS YOU MAY
KNOW IN EARLY JANUARY GOVERNOR
NEWSOM ASKED ME TO BRING
OPERATIONS THINKING TO THE JOB
OF DELIVERING THE CULVERT
NINETEEN VACCINE IN CALIFORNIA
AND TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
ACCELERATING THE DELIVERY OF
VACCINE ENSURING EQUITABLE
ADMINISTRATION AT THE EXACT
SAME STATEWIDE. AS YOU'VE HEARD
US SAY WE WANT TO ENSURE. THERE
IS TO BE NO BARRIERS TO THE
EQUITABLE AND SPEEDY DELIVERY
OF VACCINATIONS EXCEPT THE PACE
WITH WHICH VACCINE SUPPLIES I'M
TO THE STATE. MY INVOLVEMENT
COMES AT A TIME WHEN THE
STATE'S PUBLIC HEALTH LEADERS
AND COUNTIES HAVE DONE A
TREMENDOUS WORK TO PLAN FOR
VACCINE DELIVERY IN EACH OF THE
STATE'S LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS. I AM SO GRATEFUL
FOR THE IMPORTANT WORK FOR DR
ERICA PAN AM AND DR NADINE
BURKE HARRIS DID IN COLLECTING
INPUT FROM THE COMMUNITY. AS
WELL AS THE EXPERT WORK I
PUBLIC HEALTH BURKE EXPERTS
FROM THE STATE'S SCIENTIFIC
SAFETY ENTRAPPING GUIDELINES
WORKGROUPS. THIS IS THE WORK
THAT WILL SERVE AS THE
GROUNDWORK FOR THE STATEWIDE
PROGRAM. NOW COMES THE HOUSE
HOW DO WE ACCELERATE THE
DELIVERY OF VACCINE IN
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
TO ACHIEVE TRANSPARENCY EQUITY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY. AFTER SIX
AFTER ASSESSING OUR INITIAL
APPROACH WE IDENTIFIED A NEED
TO SCALE UP QUICKLY AND
DETERMINED THAT USING A TRUSTED
HEALTH PLAN PARTNER WOULD BE
THE BEST APPROACH. SO THAT WE
COULD VACCINATE THE STATE AT
THE PACE WE NEED WHILE ALSO
ENSURING WE HAVE THE DATA WE
NEED TO MAKE A STRATEGIC
DECISIONS TO ALLOCATE TAXING
FOR OPTIMAL RESULTS. YOU MAY
HAVE ALSO HEARD THAT RECENTLY
THE STATE HAS ENTERED INTO
NEGOTIATIONS WITH BLUE SHIELD
OF CALIFORNIA. TO CREATE A
SINGLE STATEWIDE NETWORK.
SERVING AS THE STATE'S THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR. GOING
FORWARD USING A SINGLE
STATEWIDE NETWORK GIVES US THE
INSIGHTS WE NEED TO ENSURE.
THAT WE HAVE AN EYE ON EQUITY
NOT JUST A COUNTY BY COUNTY
LOOK. AS WELL AS THE FACT THAT
WE CAN FOCUS ON COMMUNITIES
MOST AFFECTED BY COVERT NINETY.
DEATH AND ILLNESS WHERE VACCINE
IS SO DESPERATELY NEEDED. AT
THE GOVERNOR'S REQUEST WORKING
WITH OFFICIALS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH. AND THE HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY. WE
ASSESS WHAT IS WORKING AND
WHAT'S NOT WORKING CERTAINLY
THE LACK OF SUPPLY. IS WHAT WE
HAVE ALL BEEN FOCUSED ON IS THE
PROBLEM THAT WE SEE NOW. BUT IN
RECENT WEEKS I'M SORRY IF IN
RECENT WEEKS IT'S BECOME
APPARENT THAT WHAT WE WERE
DOING WAS TAKING TOO LONG TO
GET THE VACCINES ADMINISTERED.
AND A SYSTEM IN PLACE FAVORED
INDIVIDUALS WITH TIME AND
RESOURCES. TO NAVIGATE COMPLEX
PORTALS AND LIMITED APPOINTMENT
AVAILABILITY. ADDED FAVOR THOSE
WITH TIME AND RESOURCES TO
TRAVEL LONG DISTANCES TO GET
BACKSTAGE. FOR THIS REASON THE
STATE CHAU ANY TOM WORKING WITH
THE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS AT
THE STATE LEVEL AS WELL AS LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BROUGHT UP THE
MY TURN TOOL FOR STATEWIDE USE.
MY TURN HAS THREE COMPONENTS
HELPING THE PUBLIC LEARNED WHEN
IT IS THEIR TIME AND TO
SCHEDULE APPOINTMENTS HELPING
VACCINATORS SCHEDULE
APPOINTMENTS AND MANAGE THEM ON
THE BACK IN AND HELPING
VACCINATORS STATEWIDE REPORT
THEIR DATA ON VACCINE DOSES
ADMINISTERED. THE FRONT END
PORTAL ANSWERS THE QUESTION ON
THE MINDS OF SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS WHEN WILL IT BE MY
TURN TO GET THE VACCINE. TODAY
MY TURN ENABLES ANYONE TO
REGISTER FOR NOTIFICATION TO
LEARN WHEN IS THERE TIME. THIS
WILL BE THE PRIMARY PLACE
CALIFORNIANS CAN GO TO SCHEDULE
APPOINTMENTS. TO GET VACCINATED
IN THE COMING MONTHS. ARE MY
CURRENT OR MY TURN DOT CA DOT
GOV SYSTEM SHOWS THE FOCUS WE
PLACE. ON MAKING OUR TOOLS
ACCESSIBLE TO AS MANY
CALIFORNIANS AS POSSIBLE. MY
TURN IS AVAILABLE IN BOTH
ENGLISH AND SPANISH AND IT WILL
BE AVAILABLE AND ADDITIONAL AN
ADDITIONAL SIX LANGUAGES BY
MALE MID FEBRUARY. IT IS ALSO
SUPPORTED BY A TOLL FREE NUMBER
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET WITH
OPERATORS WHO SPEAK ENGLISH AND
SPANISH. WITH THE ABILITY TO
ADD A THIRD PARTY TRANSLATOR
FOR ANOTHER TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FOUR LANGUAGES. AS OF
MONDAY ONE POINT THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS HAVE SIGNED UP FOR
NOTIFICATIONS TO KNOW WHEN IT'S
THEIR TURN. AND TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND VACCINE
APPOINTMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE VIA
MY TURN MOSTLY IN LA AND SAN
DIEGO WHERE WE WILL CONTINUE TO
FIGHT WITH THE TOOL IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH COUNTY HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. AS YOU HAVE HEARD
YES TREMENDOUS WORK BEING DONE
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL TO
VACCINATE CALIFORNIANS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. AND I KNOW
THE PASSION THESE PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKERS HAVE AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL. STILL ARE EARLY METRICS
SUGGEST THE VACCINE IS NOT
REACHING THE COMMUNITIES MOST
AFFECTED BY THE DISEASE. AND WE
MUST DO BETTER. IF EVER EQUITY
IN THIS MATTER IN THE STATE IT
SHOULD MATTER AND THE
DISTRIBUTION OF A SHOT THAT'S
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN LIFE AND
DEATH. AS WE SHIFT TO USING
BLUESHIELD AS A THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR TO ADMINISTER
VACCINES STATE WIDE. EQUITY IS
OUR NORTH STAR AND IT WILL BE
BAKED INTO EVERYTHING FROM THE
CONTRACTUAL AGREEMENT TO THE
SELECTION OF VACCINE PROVIDERS.
WILL USE IT TO BUILD STATEWIDE
PROVIDER NETWORK THAT DOESN'T
LEAVE COMMUNITIES MOST IMPACTED
BY THIS PANDEMIC BEHIND. AND
WILL USE MY TURN. TO ENSURE
APPOINTMENTS ARE ALLOCATED
EQUITABLY SO MASS VACCINATION
CLINICS DON'T ONLY SOME OF
THOSE WHO HAVE THE TIME. AND
THE RESOURCES AND OUR ONLINE
STAFFING. USING BLUESHIELD TO
HELP US BUILD STATE VACCINE.
NETWORK IS ALSO ABOUT SCALE. AT
THE END OF JANUARY WE DELIVERED
APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS DOES THIS FOR WEEKS
THAT WILL NOT GET AS CLOSE TO
WHERE WE NEED TO BE. WE ARE
BUILDING CAPACITY FOR THE STATE
TO DELIVER FOUR MILLIONS
D'EUROS DOSES PER WEEK WHICH IS
FOUR TIMES WHAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO DO. THAT WILL HELP US GET TO
A COMMUNITY IMMUNITY FASTER AND
IT WILL ADVANCE HE EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF VACCINES STATE
WIDE. WE ARE COMMITTED TO
WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
COUNTIES. WHO HAVE DONE SO MUCH
TO LAY THE GROUNDWORK AS
PARTNERS IN THE STATE NETWORK
OUR LOCAL HEALTH JURISDICTIONS.
WILL CONTINUE. TO RECEIVE
VACCINE SUPPLY TO ASSIST WITH
HELPING HARD TO REACH
COMMUNITIES GET VACCINATED.
ROSS THE STATE HOWEVER THERE
WILL BE A FASTER DISTRIBUTION
PROCESS WITH STANDARDIZED
REPORTING TO THE STATE TO
OPTIMIZE THE ALLOCATION OF
VACCINES. AND ACHIEVE THE
TRANSPARENCY EQUITY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY WE NEED. DR
GALLEON I WILL PARTNER ON
ENSURING THAT VACCINES ARE
DISTRIBUTED ACROSS CALIFORNIA
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES WITH A
FOCUS ON TRANSPARENCY AND
EQUITY AND WE WILL BE MAKING
THE VACCINE DISTRIBUTION DATA
AVAILABLE ON THE COBIT NINETEEN
DOT CA DOT GOV WEBSITE. OVER
THE NEXT MONTH BLUESHIELD WILL
BE PARTNERING WITH OUR COUNTY
HEALTH PROVIDERS TO BUILD THE
STATE WIDE NETWORK. PROVIDERS
WHO WISH TO BECOME PART OF THE
NETWORK WILL BE CONSIDERED
BASED ON CRITERIA THAT ENSURE
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY AND
WILLINGNESS TO ACCELERATE
VACCINES ACROSS THE STATE. IN A
WAY THAT IS SAFE EQUITABLE AND
EFFICIENT. PROVIDERS WILL ALSO
COMMIT TO USING THE SYSTEMS AND
DATA REPORTING NEEDED TO TRACK
PERFORMANCE. ALL PROVIDERS IN
THE STATE MY BACKS THE NETWORK
WILL BE REQUIRED TO USE MY
TALENTS TO ENSURE THE STATE HAS
WHAT WE NEED TO ENSURE WE ARE
MEETING OUR GOALS. UNDER THE
STATEWIDE NETWORK WE WILL OFFER
INCENTIVES TO PROVIDERS FOR
MEETING EQUITY SAFETY HALL YOU
AND EFFECTIVENESS TARGETS.
START UP COSTS TO GET PROVIDERS
ON THE NETWORK WHO WILL HELP US
MEET EQUITY GOALS. AND FUNDING
FOR DISTRIBUTION SITES MOBILE
CLINICS AND FUNDING TO SUPPORT
IN HOME VACCINATIONS FOR THOSE
WHO CANNOT TRAVEL TO VACCINES
SITES. I'M CONFIDENT THAT OUR
STATE WIDE NETWORK IN THE
RESOURCES BEING DEDICATED TO
SUPPORTING VACCINATION AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES. GIVES
US THE BEST CHANCE OF ACHIEVING
A CRITICAL GOAL OF ENSURING OUR
PROGRAM IS A VACCINATION
PROGRAM FOR ALL NOT JUST THOSE
WHO ARE WELL RESOURCE AND TIME
RESOURCE TO CHASE DOWN
VACCINATION. AT EVERY STEP WE
ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING
CLOSELY WITH OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
PARTNERS. I KNOW THAT THE WORK
WE'RE DOING IS COMING ON VERY
QUICKLY. BUT YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT THAT WE WILL OPERATE
WITH TRANSPARENCY AND WE WILL
SHARE DATA IN THE WEEKS AND
MONTHS TO COME. AS THIS NETWORK
IS BUILT OUT COMPLETELY AND
ADDITIONAL VACCINE SUPPLY
ARRIVES. AT THIS TIME I WOULD
LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO MARK
GREEN OUR PROJECT COORDINATOR
FOR THE PARTNERSHIP WITH BLUE
SHIELD BLUESHIELD TO TELL YOU A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THE
PARTNERSHIP. AT I THINK THAT.
OR MAYBE EVEN YOUR. I THINK
YOUR MIKE YOUR MIKE IS ON MUTE.
MY APOLOGIES FOR HAVING A
LITTLE BIT OF A CAMERA
CHALLENGE HERE. THANK YOU
SECRETARY RICHARDSON MEMBERS OF
THE OMMITTEE I'M MARTHA GRAHAM
THE PROJECT COORDINATOR FOR THE
STATE BY TAKING PROGRAM. WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY TO EXPLAIN
WHAT A THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR IS AND HOW YOU
INTEND TO WORK WITH BLUE SHIELD
TO HELP ADVANCE THE EQUITABLE
AND EFFICIENT DELIVERY OF
CONNECTING VACCINATION STATE. I
WOULD HAVE TO BE A PART OF THIS
IMPORTANT EFFORT BECAUSE MY
PERMANENT CAPACITY. I OVERSEE
THE TPO THAT ADMINISTERS
CALPERS SELF FUNDED HEALTH
PLANS AS WELL AS ALL OF ITS
INSURED HEALTH PLANS ON BEHALF
OF STATE. LOCAL PUBLIC AGENCY
AND SCHOOL EMPLOYEES.
ADDITIONALLY PRIOR TO CALPERS
HAVE A LONG HISTORY OF THE
HEALTH PLAN REGULATOR WHICH
GIVES YOU UNIQUE INSIGHT. HOW
TO SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT
EFFORT. BUT THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATORS SIMPLY SERVES.
AS AN ADMNISTRATIVE OR
COORDINATING ENTITY FOR THE
DELIVERY OF HEALTHCARE
SERVICES. BLUE SHIELD OF
CALIFORNIA IS A STATE WIDE NOT
FOR PROFIT HEALTH PLAN. AT THE
STATE WIDE REACH WE NEED TO
HELP US WITH THE MASSIVE
COORDINATION INVOLVED. IN THE
EQUITABLE AND EFFICIENT
DELIVERY OF VACCINES TO THE
TENS OF MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS AT THE FACT THE-
SUPPLY ROUTES. BASED ON OUR
GUIDELINES BLUESHIELD WILL
SELECT PROVIDER STRATEGICALLY
THE MY TERM APPOINTMENT TOOL.
FOR TERRY SAID WE MEAN BUSINESS
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO EQUITY.
ACTIVE WILL BE ALLOCATED TO
COMMUNITIES DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY COVERT NINETEEN
PERFORMANCE PAYMENTS WILL BE
MADE TO PROVIDERS WHO WORK WITH
TO VACCINATE INDIVIDUALS THE
HARDEST HIT COMMUNITIES. START
UP COSTS WE MADE AVAILABLE TO
SUPPORT PROVIDERS LOCATED
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES TO GET
ON THE STATEWIDE NETWORK AND
MOBILE VACCINATION SITES WE
DEPLOYED TO COMMUNITIES THAT
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO BRICK AND
MORTAR. VACCINATION SITES TO
ENSURE WE REACH ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THERE WILL ALSO
BE HOME BASED VACCINATIONS FOR
PEOPLE UNABLE TO LEAVE THEIR
HOMES DUE TO THEIR DISABILITIES.
THE STATE WOULD PROGRAM A LARGE
WITH ITS FIRST MAJOR PROVIDERS
INCLUDING PRESENCE. WITH THE
COUNTY BY COUNTY ON BOARD
APPROACH THROUGH THE MIDDLE OF
MARCH AS THE SECRETARY SAID
BLUESHIELD AND STATE LEADERSHIP
WILL MEET WITH EACH FUNDING
PARTNER TO ENSURE THE MOST
CRITICAL PROVIDERS TO HELP US
MEET OUR EQUITY TARGETED EACH
COMMUNITY. OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN
THE NETWORK. I AM CONFIDENT
THAT OUR STATEWIDE NETWORK AND
RESOURCES BEING DEDICATED TO
SUPPORTING TAXATION UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES THIS IS THE BEST
CHANCE OF ACHIEVING A CRITICAL
GOAL OF ENSURING OUR PROGRAM IS
A VACCINATION PROGRAM FOR ALL.
NOT JUST THOSE WHO ARE WELL
RESOURCE AND TIME RESOURCE TO
CHASE DOWN TACTIC. AT EVERY
STEP WE ARE COMMITTED TO
WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH PARTNERS AND BEING
TRANSPARENT IN ALL WE DO. AT
THIS TIME I'D. LIKE TO TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES AT THE
OFFICE OF. AFTER YOU CAN HEAR
ME OKAY YES YOU CAN RATE ADD
SHARES PETRIE-NORRIS AND
RODRIGUEZ THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND INCLUDING HELLO
YES AND THEN SOME PORN
DISCUSSION AGAIN MY NAME IS
TINA COREY AND I AM THAT CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS
HERE AT ALL YES AND I'M HERE
WITH MY- COLLEAGUE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR LAURIE MISSOURI AND I
HOPE WE BETWEEN THE TWO OF US
WE CAN TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
HELLO YES IS ROLE IN THE IN THE
BACKSEAT I'VE HEARD AND I JUST
WANT TO START BY- BY- HARKENING
BACK A LITTLE BIT TOO OBVIOUSLY
OVER A YEAR AGO AND WE ALL
BEGIN TO CONTEND WITH THE
PANDEMIC AND HELLO YES- HAS
BEEN INTEGRAL IS AS A PARTNER
YOUR ARE AT HELLO AGENCIES AT
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AND
CDPH TO HELP COORDINATE THIS
EMERGENCY AS CALIFORNIA IN THE
NATION IN THE WORLD HAS
CONTENDED WITH IT. FOR ALL THIS
TIME AND EVEN THOUGH WE'RE HERE
TO TALK ABOUT THAT SCENE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO- TO
KIND OF ODD TO GO BACK TO THE
START OF THE ROLE OF YOUR BIRDS
THESE SERVICES AGENCY AND IT
YOU KNOW WHEN WE HAVE THESE
COMPLEX OF ACTORS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE LEVERAGING THAT
STATE RESOURCES AND FAMILY TO
BE USED AS COMMUNICATIVE AND
COORDINATED AS WE POSSIBLY CAN
SO THAT WE ARE PROFICIENT IN
THE DELIVERY OF SERVICES. TO
OUR COUNTY COUNTY GOVERNMENTS
AND COMMUNITIES ARE ON THE
FRONTLINE OF THIS DISASTER IS
JUST AS THEY ARE IN EVERY OTHER
TYPE OF DISASTER AND SO WE'VE
DONE THAT IN A WAY THAT HAS
ALLOWED US TO MOVE TO THE
CONTINUUM OF THIS EVENT AND ALL
THE DIFFERENT COMPLICATED
THINGS AND IT'S PRESENTED FROM
MEDICAL SURGE TO P. P. ET ARE
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
CHALLENGES. TO AT YOU KNOW
OTHER RESOURCE CAPABILITIES ALL
THESE THINGS FOR THE STATE NEED
TO BE ORGANIZED AND- DELIVER TO
IN ITS SUPPORT TO LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND WHEN IT AND NOW
THAT WE ARE MOVING I HAVE MOVED.
INTO THIS STAGE OF THE VACCINE-
THAT THAT ROLE PER CALORIE
ASKING TO PULL THAT TOGETHER A
LOT OF EFFORTS DOVETAIL TO
MODERNIZE- WE JUST HAD- YOU
KNOW BY FOR THE LAW. SEARCH
ADVOCATE BACK IN THE SAN AND
START EVER GONE MENTION A
TREMENDOUS NUMBER OF RESEARCH.
WERE NEEDED FROM THE STATE SET
TO HELP WITH THE WITH THAT. AND
NOW. YOU KNOW WE'RE HELPING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WERE EFFICIENTLY
MOVING DOWN- YOU KNOW
ABSOLUTELY AS WE CAN. INTO
VACCINE AND OTHER EFFORTS- SO
THAT WERE CONTINUING THAT
SUPPORTIVE. POSTURE WE'VE DONE
THAT REALLY ON VACCINE OKAY AND
pWE'LL TALK ABOUT THE FEDERAL
STATE SITES THAT WERE WERE
MENTIONED EARLIER WE'LL TALK
ABOUT THAT IN A MINUTE BUT I
WANTED TO ALSO SAY THAT. EVEN
BEFORE AND THOSE SITES WHICH
REPORTER COMING ONLINE VERY
QUICKLY- HELLO YES WAS
SUPPORTING THE VACCINE EVER
WITH OUR COMMUNITIES AND THAT
IS THE ACT- CONTINUING TO
PROVIDE PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT SO THE GLOVES AND
THE- THE MASKS AND ALL THOSE
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN NEEDED
ALL ALONG. OR NOT ONLY MEDICAL
PERSONNEL BUT ALSO FOR THE SAFE
OPERATING OF OUR SOCIALSERVICES ARE ALSO NEEDED FOR
THE VACCINE OPERATIONS THAT
WERE USING THE SAME PIPELINE.
TO PUSH THOSE NEED A RESOURCE
WITHOUT HER COMMUNITIES. AND
THEY NEED FOR A VACCINE IN OUR
IN OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
FOR PERSONNEL. SO TO DATE WE
HAVE ABOUT TWELVE HUNDRED.
PERSONNEL THAT THE COMBINATION
OF. NATIONAL GUARD. AND MEDICAL
PERSONNEL AS WELL AS AT AND
SOME OF OUR EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES TEAMS CONTRACTED
RESOURCES. AS WE SPEAK- YOU
KNOW WE HAVE THAT YOU KNOW OVER
TWELVE HUNDRED. A PERSONALITY
DEPLOYED AND I THINK UP TO
ELEVEN DIFFERENT COUNTIES. IN
DIFFERENT AMOUNTS FOR EACH
DEPENDING ON WHAT THEIR NEED IS
TO SUPPORT THEIR VACCINE OFFERS
FOR YOU KNOW MATH SITES MALL
SITE. WHAT HAVE YOU- SO WE'RE
CONTINUING TO DO THAT- OF
COURSE IS THE- WHEN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION. ANNOUNCED THEIR
DESIRE TO STAND UP A HUNDRED
SITES AROUND THE COUNTRY THAT
ARE FEDERALLY SUPPORTED. WE OF
COURSE IN CALIFORNIA- I WANTED
TO BE A OF THAT IN FACT WILL BE
THE FOR. ONE STILL. THESE
FEDERAL SIDE. AND THERE'S TWO
OF THEM AT THE POINT I WANTED
OAKLAND ONE OF ANGELES. WE WILL
BE- YOU CAN WORK CLOSELY WITH
US. OF THIS GOVERNOR AND HOW
CAN BEST POSITION I WAS. IN TO
MAKE THAT THERE SERVING. THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN-
VERY MUCH IMPACTED. BY A
PROBATE AND AS WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER AND ALSO IN A MANNER
THAT DELIVERS THAT BACKSEAT.
YEAH IN A WAY THAT IS
EQUITABLE- SO THAT'S A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF EFFORT I
KNOW THAT IS OF INTEREST TO THE
COMMITTEE. AND SO I WILL- TURN
OVER TO LAURIE MISSOURI MY
COLLEAGUE WHO'S GOING TO TALK A
LOT MORE ABOUT THE SITE
SPECIFICALLY AND THEN OF
COURSE- LOOK TO AND- SO. YOU
ARE AT THE HELPFUL WITH ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE FOR
HELLO WE ASK BUT I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO LAURIE AT THIS POINT.
THANK YOU. IT HAPPENED CARES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. IN ADDITION.
THAT SUPPORT CAN. YOU CAN
EITHER FOR. HE'S THE SITE IS.
SITE HAVE BEEN KIND OF A- AT.
NEEDED EVER FROM. YES HE- FEMA
AND U. S. YES. AND THERE
COMMUNITY BACK CENTER IN A WE-
SOME BACK. CLINIC AGAIN PART OF
BIDEN THE NATURE. TO RAPIDLY
STAND MULTIPLE SITES IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES THE
COUNTRY. EMAIL WILL PROVIDE
MANY OF THE RESOURCES NOT THE
LEAST OF WHICH IS THE
ALLOCATION OF VACCINE THAT IS
IN ADDITION TO THE STATE OUR-
THAT MEANS THAT IN SETTING UP
THE SITES WE WILL NOT DRAW
DOWN. ON ANY OF THE COUNTY'S
ALLOCATION. FEMA IS ALSO
HELPING COORDINATE FEDERAL
AGENCIES PROVIDE STAFFING FOR
THE COMMUNITY VACCINATION
CENTERS. THE DATE U. S. H. K.
KAT THE MATH DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE AND U. S. FOREST
SERVICE STAFF HAVE BEEN
MOBILIZED AND THE NATIONAL
DISASTER MEDICAL SYSTEM I'VE
BEEN CALLED UP FOR THIS MISSION.
HEARING BESIDES YEAH CDPH.
CALIFORNIA NATIONAL ENDS
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
OTHER STATE AGENCIES LOCAL
OFFICE OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AND A
PLETHORA OF NONPROFIT NON
GOVERNMENTAL AND VOLUNTEER
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
WORKING HARD TO GET THE SIZE.
I'VE BEEN READY TO BEGIN MATH
VACCINATION. AND WHERE WE CAN
WE WILL HIRE AND CONTRACT
LOCALLY. WE'RE LOOKING AT YOU
THINK LOCAL- RESOURCES FOR
EVERYTHING FROM FEEDING OF
STAFF BECAUSE WE ARE DOING TEN
HOURS YES- TWO WHAT DO YOU
THINK SECURITY POTENTIALLY YOU
TRAFFIC CONTROL AND MANY OTHER
AREAS. WE'RE LOOKING BACK ON
FEBRUARY SIXTEENTH AND ALL THE
APPOINTMENTS WILL BE SCHEDULED
FOR MY TURN GOT THE I GOT THAT.
EACH DAY A PERCENTAGE OF THE
APPOINTMENT SLOTS WILL BE SET
ASIDE FOR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES I WILL BE WORKING
WITH A VAST NETWORK OF UNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION RIGHT SURE
THAT THEIR CONSTITUENTS ARE
ABLE TO ACCESS THOSE
APPOINTMENTS. ALTHOUGH WE STAY
THERE WILL BE A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF APPOINTMENT SLOTS MADE
AVAILABLE FOR THE GENERAL
PUBLIC. WHO MEET ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS. FOR THOSE THAT DO
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO THE INTERNET
OR TO MAKE RESERVATIONS ONLINE
OR PERHAPS NEED A LITTLE EXTRA
HELP SCHEDULING THE APPOINTMENT
THEY CAN CALL BECAUSE THE
NINETEEN HOTLINE WHICH
SECRETARY RICHARDSON MENTIONED
EARLIER. THE VACCINATIONS WILL
FOLLOW STEVEN CANNY BIDEN FOR
ELIGIBILITY AND MENTIONED BY DR
ERICA. THAT MEANS THAT FACE ONE
A INDIVIDUALS AND ALL TEARS SO
THE HEALTHCARE MEDICAL FIRST
RESPONDER LONG TERM CARE STAFF
AND RIGHT IN THE THAT ARE UP.
AS WELL AS THOSE WHO ARE SIXTY
FIVE YEARS AND OLDER IT'S
SCHEDULED APPOINTMENT AT THIS
LOCATION. AND THAT INCLUDES
ALSO INTENTIONALLY THE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AT HIGH RISK
OF EXPOSURE. IN OUR SCHOOL
PH
RGING THE SERVICES AND NOW
GRATEFUL FOR. BIG SITES ARE
CLOSE TO PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
AND WILL HAVE BOTH DROPPED I
THROUGH THE WALK THROUGH AREAS.
THEY'LL BE INTERPRETERS ON SITE
OR AVAILABLE BERKELEY. READERS
AND ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF TO
CHECK PATIENTS IN AND DIRECT
THEM APPROPRIATELY. IN ADDITION
TO THOSE SIX AYE THERE WILL TO
BE TWO MOBILE UNITS OPERATING
OUT OF THE SITE AS WELL SO GO
OUT INTO UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES DAILY TO BRING BACK
THINK CLOSER TO WHERE PEOPLE
LIVE AND WORK. ONCE WE GET OUR
STRIDE. WHICH SHOULDN'T TAKE
TOO LONG AT ALL THE FIXED
COMMITTEE VACCINATION CENTERS
WILL HAVE A THROUGHPUT OF ABOUT
SIX THOUSAND DOSES ADMINISTERED
PER DAY. EACH MOBILE UNI WILL
HAVE THE CAPACITY FOR TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY DOSES
ADMINISTERED PER DAY. WE ARE
COORDINATING BE FAXING EFFORTS
WITH ALL THE OTHER EFFORTS.
CHAIRED BY THE SECRETARY I
SECRETARY RICHARDS ANDTHAT ARE
BEING UNDERTAKEN BY THE YEAH.
THE NEXT SPEAKER MY CELL
RODRIGUEZ WILL THINK MORE ABOUT
HOW WE HOPE TO ENGAGE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHER
GROUPS TO HELP US SERVER
CALIFORNIA'S MOST HARD HIT
COMMUNITIES. BUT I'M SURE THAT
ALL THOSE WHO WANT TO AND GET
FASCINATED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR EVERYONE CAN HEAR ME
OKAY. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK
YOU TO OUR CHAIRED AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
THAT YOU'RE A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THE STATE'S PUBLIC
EDUCATION CAMPAIGN- AND
COMMUNITY OUTREACH EFFORTS-
SOME OF YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR BUT
A PART OF MY ROLE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WITH TO HELP
OVERSEE THAT ABSENCES CAMPAIGN
ARE TWENTY TWENTY SENSES
EFFORTS AND WE'RE TAKING A LOT
OF THOSE LESSONS LEARNED. AND
APPLYING THEM NOW TURKOMAN
NINETEEN RESPOND AND ACTING
EDUCATION EFFORT. THE GOAL OF
THE RECTORY OFFICE CAMPAIGN IS
TO HELP EDUCATE MOTIVATE AND
ACTIVATE. CALIFORNIANS TO GET
VACCINATED WHEN IT'S THEIR
TURN. THE KEY MESSAGING TOPICS
FOR THE CAMPAIGN INCLUDES.
PROVIDING BASIC OF ACTING FACT.
ADDRESSING BARRIERS LIKE
HESITANCY AND AXES. HELPING
CALIFORNIA'S NAVIGATE ACTING
OUT ABILITY AND PROCESS. WHAT
EQUITY AND THEIR CORE FOCUS THE
CAMPAIGN IS FOCUSED ON REACHING
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
CO THE NINETEEN. THROUGH THREE
KEY STRATEGIES. FIRST THE
TAKING ON A DATA DRIVEN
APPROACH. SECOND IS LEADING
COMMUNICATION EFFORTS WITH
CULTURAL HUMILITY AND THREE IS
DRIVING COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
THROUGH TRUSTED MESSENGERS. AS
I MENTIONED OUR FIRST
STRATEGIES TO LEVERAGE DATA TO
INFORM OUR EFFORTS TO ENSURE WE
ARE REACHING CALIFORNIANS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED. BY
THE PANDEMIC AND THIS INCLUDES
LEVERAGING THE HEALTHY PLACES
INDEX AND COVERED POSITIVITY
RATE. IN ADDITION WE WILL BE
MONITORING THIS AND
DISINFORMATION AND DIFFICULT-
RUMORS IN IDENTIFYING
INTENTIONAL ACT TO MISLEAD
PEOPLE USING. SOCIAL LISTENING
TOOLS. WE WILL ALSO COLLECT
INPUT FROM OUR COMMUNITY GROUPS
ON THE GROUND- MAYBE-
IDENTIFYING AND EXPERIENCING
THAT KIND OF ACTIVITY ON THE
GROUND. LASTLY THE CAMPAIGN IS
ROOTED IN BOTH QUALITATIVE AND
QUANTITATIVE RESEARCH
PROTECTING MESSAGES AND
CREATIVE ACCESS WITH OUR TARGET
COMMUNITIES TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHICH MESSAGES WILL
RESONATE MOST. ENTERED INTO BY
BARRIERS AND MOTIVATORS TO HELP
ACTIVATE CALIFORNIANS TO
UNDERSTAND THE BENEFITS BACK
THE APPLICATION. THE SECOND OF
OUR STRATEGY IS TO ALWAYS
COMMUNICATE WITH CULTURAL
HUMILITY. THIS INCLUDES
DEVELOPING MESSAGES AND
MATERIALS NOT ONLY INFORMED BY
THE COMMUNITY RESEARCH I JUST
MENTIONED. AND IN MORE THAN A
DOZEN LANGUAGES BUT ALSO
LEVERAGES TRUSTED MESSENGERS AS
WE KNOW FROM OUR OUR OTHER
CAMPAIGNS THE MESSAGE IS
CRITICAL AND EVEN MORE SO WHO
DELIVERS THAT. SIX STRATEGY
LEANS IN ON TRUSTED MESSENGERS
WHO HAVE THE ABILITY TO TRULY
IN FRONT THE TRADITIONALLY HARD
TO REACH POPULATIONS. THIS IS
ALSO WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR
A PUBLIC EDUCATION CAMPAIGN IN
OUR COMMUNITY OUTREACH EFFORTS
TO BE CLOSELY COORDINATED. THE
CAMPAIGN ALSO RELIES HEAVILY ON
ETHNIC AND MULTICULTURAL MEDIA
WHICH HAS IN MANY CASES A MUCH
HIGHER RATE OF TRUST THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA AMONG THOSE
WHO SEEK TO REACH. ETHNIC MEDIA
OUTLETS ARE OPEN OVER
ADVOCATING FOR THEIR AUDIENCES
AND ISSUES OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE. AS AN EXAMPLE
CURRENT EFFORTS REPORTING
ETHNIC MEDIA BRIEFING. ENGAGING
TRUCKED MESSENGERS. REPORTING
LIVE FRIEDMAN RADIANT YOUR
FORTY ETHNIC MEDIA OUTLETS AND
COVERING EIGHTEEN DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES. AB AND INVESTING IN
PAID MEDIA EFFORTS INCLUDING
SPANISH TELEVISION. THE THIRD
ASPECT OF OUR STRATEGY IS A
TESTAMENT TO LEVERAGE COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT FOR TRUSTED
MESSENGERS. WE ARE PRIORITIZING
QUALITY AND ENGAGEMENT. ON
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
CALIFORNIANS CAN PROTECT
THEMSELVES AND THEIR COMMUNITY
FROM COVER NINETEEN. PROVIDING
REFERRALS TO THINKING THAT
SERVICES INFORMATIONAL WORKERS
RIGHT AND THE COMPANY CAME BACK
CLEAN. THE RESOURCES ALLOCATED
FOR SB ONE ONE FIVE AT THE
STATE IS INVESTING THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR WORKPLACE
AND COMMUNITY HEALTH OUTREACH
PROJECT. ITS INVESTMENT SUPPORT
THE HUNDRED FIFTY COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS LEVERAGING
THE HISTORY AND ESTABLISHED
NETWORKS THEY HAVE WITH HARPER
TO REACH POPULATIONS. TO HELP
US MEET PEOPLE WHERE THEY ARE.
HELP THAT RICH PROJECT WILL
FOCUS ON TOP PRIORITY
POPULATIONS INCLUDING ASIAN
AMERICAN BLACK AFRICAN.
AMERICAN INDIAN NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBAL LATINO MIDDLE EASTERN
AND NORTH AFRICAN NATIVE
HAWAIIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS
LGBT Q. FIVE PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES OLDER ADULT WOMEN
IN ENGLISH PROFICIENT PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
PEOPLE LIVING IN MULTI
GENERATIONAL HOUSEHOLDS. WHAT
THE COMMUNITY OUTREACH PROJECT
OR STATEWIDE THE COMPANY TO
WORKPLACE SAFETY EFFORTS ARE
FOCUSED FOR HIGHER RISK
INDUSTRIES ARE LOCATED. THESE
INCLUDE AGRICULTURE FOOD
PROCESSING SERVICE JANITORIAL
WAREHOUSING LOGISTICS AND
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY. TODAY
AT SEVENTEEN POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS HAS BEEN
AWARDED TWO HUNDRED TEN CEOS
MORE EXPECTED BY THE END OF
FEBRUARY. THIS VIDEO NETWORK IS
BEING MANAGED IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE CENTER OF THE YEAR
HEALTH FOUNDATION. AND AMERICA
CALGARY COMMITTEE FOUNDATION.
WE WANT TO BE WORKING HAND IN
HAND WITH OUR SIXTY ONE LOCAL
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS ARE
UNIQUELY EQUIPPED TO ENGAGE THE
COMMUNITY. THE STATE IS ALSO
CASACORNELIA WITH THE TOGETHER
TOWARDS HEALTH EDUCATION
CAMPAIGN A PROJECT SUPPORTED BY
PHILANTHROPY TO FUND ADDITIONAL
CBO TO MAXIMIZE THE REACH AND
IMPACT. AND SIMILAR TO OUR
TWENTY TWENTY PRESENT EFFORTS
WE WANT TO LEVERAGE OUR STATE
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS AND
WORK WITH MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO HELP EACH
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THIS
CRITICAL WORK. THANK YOU AN
ALTERNATE CALL HIM TURN IT
BACK. TO THE CHAIR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I THANK YOU TO TWO OF
OUR PRESENTERS FOR BEING HERE
TODAY. THAT WILL MOVE TO NUMBER
QUESTIONS. CARE RODRIGUEZ
DURING THE START OR- YES
SEVERAL QUESTIONS BUT LET ME
JUST. GET TO ABOUT THE WAY US
SECRETARY RICHARDSON I WAS
REALLY IMPRESSED WITH THE
PRESENTATION ONE THING THAT
STRUCK MY MIND RIGHT AWAY WAS
YOU SAID EVENTUALLY WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO A PLACE WILL BE ABLE
TO GIVE FOUR MILLION BUCKS IN
THE WEEK- DO WE HAVE A TIME
FRAME WHEN THAT WILL OCCUR.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE WORKING ON
NOW WE ARE WORKING ON
PROJECTIONS TO SEE WHEN WE'RE
GOING TO BE THERE I THINK YOU
HEARD A LITTLE BIT TODAY. ABOUT
WHAT THE CURRENT CAPACITY IS
STILL AS WE TRANSITION TO THE
CPA THAT WILL BE THEIR FIRST
ORDER OF BUSINESS TO FIGURE OUT
WHATKIND OF CAPACITY IS SO WE
CAN SEE WHERE THE GAPS ARE SO
WE CAN WORK ON THE GAPS. OKAY
JUST ONE MORE. QUICK QUESTION.
OF SOMEBODY ELSE. OF BEING THAT
OUR PHARMACEUTICAL
MANUFACTURERS OR- IN THE
BUSINESS OF MAKING THE VACCINE
TO. AND MEDICATIONS OUT. AND
WHATNOT. HAVE WE'VE CONSULTED
WITH THEM TO LEARN ABOUT. ANY
EXISTING DISTRIBUTION PROCESS
AND THEY HAVE SINCE THEY'VE-
COME IN THAT REALM ALREADY SO
JUST KIND OF CHRISTOPHER. REEVE
REACHED OUT TO EVERY THE
PHARMACEUTICAL INDUSTRIES ABOUT
WHAT THEY DO TO DISTRIBUTE
VACCINES OR MEDICATIONS.
ANOTHER WOULD HELP US IN
CALIFORNIA. YEAH WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING DIRECTLY WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NOT DIRECTLY
WITH THE MANUFACTURERS ABOUT
THE DISTRIBUTION PROCESS. BUT
WE HAVE BEEN HEARING FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION HOW THEY HAVE
BEEN IN TALKS WITH THE
MANUFACTURERS TO REALLY TRY TO
EXPEDITE GETTING MORE VACCINE-
TO THE STATE'S. MEDINA THANK
YOU FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO
THANK BOTH OF THE CHAIRS OF
BOTH COMMITTEES FOR- BRINGING
US TOGETHER FOR THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT- HEARING. I WANT TO
STATE THE OBVIOUS WHEN I SAY
THAT THERE IS NOTHING MORE
IMPORTANT. TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. OR TO THIS
LEGISLATURE. THAN THE
SUCCESSFUL. EXECUTION OF THE
VACCINE A ROLLOUT. AS I HEARD
SPEAKERS SAY IT IS A MATTER OF
LIFE AND DEATH- AND I. WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE CHALLENGES THAT
IT HAS BEEN FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND FOR ALL THE
PRESENTERS RIGHT HERE THIS
AFTERNOON- BUT I WANT TO SHARE.
A CALL THAT I HAD THIS
AFTERNOON ON MY WAY OVER HERE.
I REPRESENT- THE CITIES OF
RIVERSIDE MORENO VALLEY AND
PERRIS AND ONE OF MY
CONSTITUENTS. EIGHTY SIX YEAR
OLD COLLEGE EDUCATED- MAN-
CALLED ME. HE IS MORE
TECHNICALLY SAVVY AND COMPUTER
LITERATE THAN I AM. BUT HE'S
EIGHTY SIX YEARS OLD. AND HE
SHARED WITH ME THAT SINCE THE
VACCINE HAS BEEN AVAILABLE. IN
RIVERSIDE. HE'S AT HOME WITH
HIS WIFE THEY HAVE LOTS OF TIME
ON ON THEIR HANDS AND HE'S BEEN
SPENDING HIS TIME TRYING TO GET
AN APPOINTMENT FOR THE VACCINE.
AND HE'S EIGHTY SIX YEARS OLD.
ADD UP TO THIS AFTERNOON HE WAS
UNABLE TO GET AN APPOINTMENT OR
EVEN TO KNOW ACTUALLY WHERE TO
GO. HE WAS OF AT A LOSS AT A
LOSS LIKE MOST. ESPECIALLY
ELDERLY PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT
HAVE BEEN. AT A LOSS OF KNOWING
WHAT TO DO WHERE TO GO HELLO
WHAT HOW TO MOVE FORWARD- WITH
THAT SAID. I WILL HAVE TO AGREE
I REQUEST MY COLLEAGUES- FROM
CHICO THAT WHAT WE ARE DOING
NOW IS NOT WORKING. AND THAT'S
WHAT I'VE SEEN SO FAR- IT IN
THIS ROLLOUT HAS BEEN NOTHING
SHORT OF CHAOTIC. IN AT THE
BOTH THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS MEETING
YESTERDAY AND THE RIVERSIDE
CITY COUNCIL. THERE WAS-
FRUSTRATION EXPRESSED THE BOTH
OF THOSE MEETINGS RIVERSIDE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS-
POINTED TO THE NUMBERS THE
NUMBER VACCINES PER POPULATION
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY. THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY HAD THE LOWEST
PER THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED THREE
THOUSAND- IN RIVERSIDE. FOREIGN
I HEARD DR I DON'T SAY THAT THE
REASON FOR THAT IS THAT AT
FIRST THE ROLLOUT WAS BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF HEALTH CARE
WORKERS. IN THE COUNTY AND IF
YOU KNOW I CAN ACCEPT THE FACT
THAT THAT MAY VERY WELL BE BUT
THOSE DISPARITIES DO NOT SIT
VERY WELL WITH THE COUNTY WITH
THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS- OR OR THE CITY'S-
HOW HOW DO WE HOW TO AND HERE'S
MY QUESTION HOW HOW CAN WE BE
ASSURED THAT RIVERSIDE COUNTY
WILL NOT BE LEFT BEHIND DID
RIVERSIDE COUNTY WILL GET ITS
FAIR SHARE OF THE- DOSES OF THE
VACCINE. IF SOMEONE COULD
ANSWER THAT QUESTION FORM. THE
DOCTOR ARE GOING I'LL GO AHEAD
AND GO AHEAD AND START AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR YOUR
COMMENTS- AND WE COMPLETELY
AGREE WITH WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
AND THIS IS WHY THE DATA ISSUES
ARE VERY IMPORTANT EARLY ON YOU
HEARD THE HEALTH OFFICERS- AT
FROM BOTH- YOU'LL COUNTY LOS
ANGELES DESCRIBED THE
CHALLENGES WE'RE HAVING WITH
DATA. AND SO OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL WEEKS THIS HAS BEEN AN
INCREDIBLY INTENSE FOCUS FOR
US. CLEANING UP THE DATA. GET
IMPROVING THE PROVING THE
QUALITY MAKING SURE THAT EVERY
DOES GETS ADMINISTERED. BECAUSE
WITHOUT GOOD DATA WE'RE NOT
GOING TO HAVE VISIBILITY ON THE
CHEAP IN ANY OF OUR GOALS- AND
AS YOU HEARD FROM LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. THEY'VE ALREADY DONE AN
ANALYSIS OF THEIR DATA AND YOU
CAN SEE THAT THEY ARE OUT OF
REACH THE MOST IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES. HAS NOT BEEN WHERE
WHERE WE WANTED AND THAT'S ALSO
GOING TO BE TRUE ACROSS
COUNTIES. SO THE DATA IS GONNA
BE VERY IMPORTANT TO ALL OF US
ACCOUNTABLE TO MAKING SURE THAT
THERE'S AN EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION. ACROSS THE STATE-
I'M GONNA I WILL ALSO LEAVE IT
IF ANYBODY ELSE WANTS TO ADD
MORE TO THE. NOT HEARING.
ANYONE SPEAKING UP. I WAS GONNA
SAY I WAS GOING TO SPEAK UP AND
SAY TO TALK ARTICLE IT'S POINT.
IS WHY. IN THE STATEWIDE
NETWORK WE'RE REALLY
EMPHASIZING THE USE OF MY TURN
I THINK THE EXAMPLE THAT YOU
GAVE WAS A GREAT EXAMPLE. OF
MAKING SURE THAT IN THAT SCHOOL
WE WILL BE ABLE TO ALLOCATE.
APPOINTMENTS TO THOSE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE SO THAT THEY CAN GET
IN TO SEE SEEN. ALSO MAKING
SURE THAT THERE IS A CALL
CENTER THAT HAS THAT SAME
CAPACITY AND MAKING SURE THAT
WE CAN REACH PEOPLE IN THE
LANGUAGES THAT ARE- MOST
COMFORTABLE FOR THEM. I THINK
WILL HELP US TO MAKE SURE NOT
ONLY IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY. BUT
WE'RE REACHING ALL OF OUR
TARGETED POPULATIONS ACROSS THE
STATE. AND AS FAR AS MY TURN OF
THE PLATFORM- THAT'S NOT
AVAILABLE YET CORRECT ACROSS
THE STATE. THAT'S CORRECT RIGHT
NOW IT'S STILL BEING PILOTED IN
LOS ANGELES AND SAN DIEGO AND
WE REALLY APPRECIATE OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH THEM BUT IT
WILL BE AVAILABLE YOU'LL BE
ROLLED OUT AFTER THE FIFTEENTH
OF THIS MONTH. WELL YOU LANDA
AND DEAD THAT'S CORRECT IN
TERMS OF THE THAT BACK IN FOR
THE CLINICAL DELIVERING
CLINICAL SERVICES BUT YOU CAN
GO RIGHT NOW WE JUST REGISTER
YOUR NAME AND INFORMATION. BUT
THE PUBLIC THE PUBLIC ONE IS
AVAILABLE. AT AND YOU'LL BE
CONTACTED FOR AN APPOINTMENT
AND YOU CAN TELL WHEN YOUR-
RETURN IS. NOT NOT YET. OKAY
BUT YOU CAN REGISTER YOU COULD
YOU COULD YOU CAN SHE SHE
BROUGHT UP THE STATISTICS
EARLIER ABOUT- I THINK I
BELIEVE YOU SAID YOU WANTED
IT'S MORE THAN A MILLION PEOPLE
HAVE READY TO RIP JUST
REGISTERED. THAT IS CORRECT SO
WHAT POINT THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS HAVE GONE ON TO BE
NOTIFIED WHEN THEY'RE ACTUALLY
GOING TO BE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
A NOTIFICATION THAT THEY CAN
ACTUALLY LOOK AT AN APPOINTMENT
ABSOLUTELY THAT'S AVAILABLE
RIGHT NOW ACROSS THE STATE. I'M
SURE I HAVE OTHER QUESTIONS BUT
I WILL STOP AND BUT I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT- YOU KNOW AS FAR
AS THIS- LEGISLATORS CONCERNED
YOU'RE- ASKING US TO HAVE MORE
FAITH- IN IN. YOU'RE GOING TO
DO GOING FORWARD. THAN WHAT
WE'VE SEEN IN THE PAST THAT
THANK YOU. LET ME JUST ASK A
COUPLE OF QUICK FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS AROUND MY TURN SO-
YOU'VE EMPHASIZED THE
IMPORTANCE OF MY TURN BOTH A
THINK IS A FRONTEND INTERFACE
FOR CONSTITUENTS AND- BACK IN
FOR DATA MANAGEMENT. CAN YOU
GIVE US SOME MORE SPECIFIC
MILESTONES FOR THE STATEWIDE
LAUNCH AND ROLLOUT OF THE MY
CURRENT SYSTEM. HI EVERYONE-
THIS IS INCOME AND THAT THE
STATE'S CHIEF INFORMATION
OFFICER I'M ACTUALLY- LOGGING
IN FROM YOUR LOT THAT SECRETARY
RICHARD RICHARDSON CAMERAS SO
YOU SEE HER NAME BUT I'M HERE
TO- CHIME IN THE SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT THE QUESTION OF MY TURN-
YES THERE ARE- I ALSO THOUGHT
WE MARCHING TOWARDS TO. GET AS
MANY COUNTY AS POSSIBLE IF NOT
ALL OF THEM BY MARCH I'M SORRY
FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH. AND GETTING
THEM ONBOARD IS ONE THING IS
MOST IMPORTANT THAT THE
COUNTIES ARE STILL STARTING TO
PUT THEIR SCHEDULE INVENT A
VACCINATION SITES ONTO THE MY
TURN SYSTEM. SO THAT WHEN THE
RESIDENT UP THAT COUNTY. OF
ELIGIBLE FOR THEIR TURN BIG
COULD TURN AROUND AND SCHEDULE
THOSE APPOINTMENTS USING MY
TURNED. IN SO FAR- THERE ARE
ONLY SAN DIEGO AND LOS ANGELES
ARE PUTTING THEIR SCHEDULE ON
MY TURN AND THIS IS THE PROCESS
WE'RE GOING THROUGH I'M FOR
REST OF THE COUNTY. ON TO THE
METRIC SYSTEM. GREAT THANK YOU
WHAT IS WHAT'S THE SCALE FOR
THAT. AB CAN YOU GIVE US THAT
CAN YOU GIVE US THAT SCHEDULE
AS A FOLLOW UP TO THIS HEARING.
YES WE CAN SEND THE- SCHEDULE
BUT THE TOP LINE. DO THEY THAT
WE'RE SHOOTING FOR IS TO GET
EVERYBODY ON BOARD AGUIAR-CURRY
FIFTEEN HOWEVER WE DO
UNDERSTAND SOME OF THE COUNTY
FUTURE FINISH THEIR CURRENT
SCHEDULE EMAIL WILL GO BEYOND
THAT SO WE ARE. WORKING WITH
COUNTY ONE BY ONE FIGURE OUT
WHAT IS THE BEST TIME TO
TRANSITION THEIR NEW SCHEDULES
INTO MY CAR FOR THE ONBOARDING
SHOULD FINISH BY FEBRUARY. OKAY
SO THE GOAL IS TO HAVE ALL
COUNTIES ONBOARDED. ON TOP MY
TURN BY FEBRUARY FIFTEENTH.
THAT'S OUR GOAL I KNOW THERE
ARE COUNTIES ARE. WORKING
THROUGH SOME OF THEIR CONCERNS
BUT THAT IT'S OUR INTENTION TO
GET THE CHILD HE'S ON BOARD IT
AND THEN AND THEN- ACTUALLY
AFTER THAT HAVE ALL OF THEIR
SCHEDULES TO BE ON MY TRUCK.
OKAY GREAT IN IN AYE I THINK IT
IS IMPORTANT JUST FIVE DOCTOR
ARE GONE TO CLARIFY THAT YOU
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF FORTY
MILLION CALIFORNIANS THAT MIGHT
TURN SYSTEM IS NOT LIVE
STATEWIDE IT'S KIND OF LIVE FOR
LIKE A PRE REGISTRATION- IT'S
ONLY WHEN YOU CAN ACTUALLY.
WHEN IT'S ACTUALLY CONNECTED
WITH COUNTY DATA AND YOU CAN
ACTUALLY UTILIZE TO MAKE
APPOINTMENTS THAT I THINK IT'S
FAIR FOR US TO SAY THAT THAT
SADDAM HAS GONE LIVE- AND IT
DOESN'T ABOUT THAT'S EVEN.
LOWER CONFUSING EXPECTATIONS.
FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS. RIGHT I.
WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THANK
YOU- ALL THE MEMBERS OF
MINISTRATION- HERE TODAY TO
ANSWER SOME OF THESE TOUGH
QUESTIONS AND HOPEFULLY- HELP
US IMPROVE WHAT'S HAPPENING AS
FAR AS EXPERIENCEBURKE
CONSTITUENTS UNDERCOVER
NINETEEN AS IT RELATES TO
VACCINES- AND FRANKLY
BUREAUCRACY- YOUR THIS IS BEEN.
LET LET LET ME START WITH THIS
CAN ANYONE ON HERE TELL ME. HOW
MANY MASS VACCINATION SITES ARE
IN L. A. COUNTY. ANYBODY ON THE
PANEL HAVE THAT INFORMATION.
I'LL BE DARNED IF THEY DON'T.
DR GOD YOU KNOW HOW MANY SITES
THROUGH THE WEEKEND. I DO NOT
KNOW HOW MANY I KNOW THEY I
WITH A PRESENTED THEY PRESENTED
THAT THEY HAVE THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FIVE SITES. THE I
KNOW THEY HAVE ONE A DOCTOR
STADIUM WHICH IS PROBABLY THEIR
BIGGEST SITE. AND I'M SURE THEY
HAVE SOME MEDIUM MEDIUM SIZED
SITES BUT THAT I I'M NOT AWARE
OF THE SIDES OF THE- OF THOSE
SITES. IT AT THE POPULATION OF
L. A. COUNTY IS ROUGHLY- TEN
MILLION IS THAT. YOUR
UNDERSTANDING. YES THAT IS A
LITTLE OVER TEN MILLION THAT'S
CORRECT. AND YOU KNOW WHAT
POPULATION OF THE SILICON
VALLEY THIS. I KNOW I DO NOT
IT'S ROUGHLY FOUR AND A HALF
MILLION PEOPLE RUNNING FROM-
BAKERSFIELD UP- THROUGH STUFF
STOCKTON SAN JOAQUIN- THERE'S
CURRENTLY ZERO MASS VACCINATION
SITES- THERE WAS A PRESS
CONFERENCE TODAY I THINK WE HAD
AN ANNOUNCEMENT THAT WE STILL
DON'T HAVE A VACCINATION THAT
SPECULATION SITE- OBVIOUSLY NOT
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR. BUT
IT'S INEXCUSABLE THAT THERE'S
MULTIPLE LARGE SCALE
VACCINATION SITES IN LA AND
ZERO- IN FOUR AND A HALF
MILLION PEOPLE IN MULTIPLE
COUNTIES IF THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY WAS ITS OWN STATE WOULD
BE THE TWENTY FIFTH LARGEST
STATE IN THE COUNTRY. NO MASS
VACCINATIONS ARE. D. DATA. THAT
I KEEP GETTING. POINTS THERE
WERE BACK TO THE GOLDEN RULE.
HERE SHE WHO HAS THE GOLD MAKES
THE RULES. AND LET ME SHARE A
FEW DATA POINTS WITH YOU. I
WENT LOOKED AT ALL THE COUNTIES
BY MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD INCOME.
TURNS OUT THAT- SAN FRANCISCO
COUNTY WITH A MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD
INCOME OF A HUNDRED AND
210-007-0090 FIVE. HAS TWELVE
POINT 83% OF THE POPULATION
BACKS AND. NAPA COUNTY WITH A
MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD INCOME OF
NINETY THOUSAND DOLLARS HAS 17%
SANTA CRUZ AT EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND AS 14% LOS ANGELES
SEVENTY TWO THOUSAND HAS 11%
WELL NOW LET'S LOOK AT THE HAVE
NOTS. MERCED COUNTY MY HOME
TOWN WELCOME. FIFTY NINE
THOUSAND SEVEN THREE THREE
MEDIAN INCOME FIVE POINT 49% OF
THE POPULATION TAXES. KINGS
COUNTY. 570005% OF THE
POPULATION BACKS TULARE. FIFTY
SIX THOUSAND SIX POINT 9%
TEHAMA COUNTY FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND FIVE POINT EIGHT FIVE
MARIPOSA FIFTY TWO THOUSAND
FIVE POINT ZERO. WE GO ON ON
THE WHAT APPEARS CLEAR IS THOSE
THAT HAVE ARE GETTING
VACCINATED. AND THOSE THAT
DON'T ARE NOT END I DON'T KNOW
YOU'RE A LITTLE FRUSTRATED WE
GET THESE DEEP DIVE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT DATA. WHEN
IT FEELS LIKE WERE SKIRTING THE
QUESTION OF JUST MAKING SURE
THAT WE ROLL OUT RESOURCES AND
EVERY COUNTY AND EVERY PART OF
THE STATE. IN AS EQUAL- YEAH WE
TALK ABOUT EQUITY AND MANY OF
MY COLLEAGUES LED TO GIVE LIP
SERVICE TO EQUITY AS WELL- IT
IT MEANS A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS TO A LOT OF PEOPLE
EVERYBODY HAS THEIR OWN LANDS
BUT SOME SENSE OF FAIRNESS
WE'RE WE CONSIDER CONSTITUENTS
YES. THERE'S A NATIONAL
SHORTAGE BUT WE'RE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER AND WE'RE ALL MOVING
FORWARD TOGETHER. NOT THE
SITUATION WHERE AN HOUR SOME
COUNTIES MOVED FROM. TIER ONE
TO THE NEXT YEAR SOME EXPAND
POPULATIONS OTHERS DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH TO EVEN DO THE
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE AND I WANT
TO FOLLOW UP ON SOME COMMENTS
MY COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE
MADE. LET ME GIVE YOU A LITTLE
BACKGROUND ON THAT THE TWO OF
US HAVE SPENT THE LAST NINE
YEARS IN THIS BODY. TRIED TO
FIGHT. FOR MEDICAL EDUCATION.
IN RURAL AND UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES ELEVEN PRIOR. THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY PLACES THAT.
THE PHYSICIAN TO PATIENT RATIOS
ARE DISMAL YOU KNOW AND IN MY
HOMETOWN MY HOME COUNTY IT'S
NINETY ONE. PHYSICIANS PER ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE. IN SAN
FRANCISCO IT'S FOUR HUNDRED
ELEVEN- ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE. END THOSE INEQUITIES IN
OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM ARE
PLAYING OUT IN THIS PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS AND I KNOW YOU
KNOW THEY'RE LEGITIMATELY
DIFFICULT ISSUES THAT YOU ALL
ARE DRESSING WE'VE HAD MANY
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT AND I
APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT YOU
ALL ARE DOING TO TACKLE THE
DATE ISSUES THAT THIS COMPUTER
DONE TALK TO THAT COMPUTER BUT
IN THE MEANTIME THE BASIC DATA
POINTS THAT WE HAVE. ARE
POINTING TO GROSS INEQUITIES
AND I DON'T FEEL LIKE WE GET
ANY ANSWERS IN THIS HEARING
TODAY. OR IN ANY OF THE PUBLIC
EFFORTS AS TO HOW WE'RE GOING
TO TURN THAT AROUND HOW WE'RE
GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT. THE
NUMBER OF VACCINES IN ANY GIVEN
JURISDICTION RELATES TO THE
NUMBER OF INFECTIONS ARE CASES
OR- OR PERHAPS EVEN THE
FATALITY RATE. OF THESE CASES
RIGHT SOME RATIONAL COURSE THAT
WHERE THE PROBLEM IS WE'RE
SENDING THE MONEY AND THE
RESOURCES INSTEAD WHAT WE SEEM
TO HAVE. IS A MISHMASH OF
REASONS- RATIONALES EXCUSES AS
TO WHY THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT
ALREADY HAVE MORE. ARE STILL
GETTING MORE AND THOSE OF US
THAT HAVE LASSER AND EARNED A
VERY DIFFICULT SITUATION I'VE
GOT ONE ADDITIONAL DATA POINT
HERE I'LL SHARE WITH YOU. THAT-
THAT WAS PASSED ON WITH ANOTHER
MEMBER SO I CAN'T SPEAK TO-
THE- ACCURACY OF THIS DOCUMENT.
BUT AS IT'S BEEN PRESENTED TO
ME THIS COMPARES THE NUMBER OF.
CASES TO THE NUMBER OF VACCINES
RIGHT AND THEN GETS A
PERCENTAGE SO- IN THE CASE FOR
EXAMPLE OF KINGS COUNTY. YOU'VE
GOT 210-002-0090 SEVEN- COATED
NINETEEN CASES. THEY'VE
RECEIVED SEVEN THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FOR VACCINES
SO THAT'S THIRTY SIX PERCENT-
OF THE TOTAL CASE SUMMIT
ACCENTS DOWN OTHER PLACES- FOR
EXAMPLE. LOS ANGELES THEY'VE
HAD ONE MILLION ONE HUNDRED
FORTY NINE THOUSAND CASES AND
THEY'VE RECEIVED ONE MILLION
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
BACK SEEMS THERE ROUGHLY OVER.
A ONE TO ONE RATIO SO YOU CAN
SEE THAT IS A GROSS. INEQUITY
AND SO. LET ME ASK YOU A COUPLE
QUESTIONS. HAVING SHARED THOSE
DATA POINTS WITH YOU- DO YOU
AGREE THAT. WE'RE USING YOU
KNOW BUT BY USING HEALTH
PROVIDERS AND HEALTHCARE
INFRASTRUCTURE AS PART OF THE
FORMULA- AS TO HOW WE ALLOCATE
VACCINES TO COMMUNITIES THAT
WERE BASICALLY USING AN EQUITY
TO JUSTIFY A FURTHER INEQUITY
DO YOU FEEL LIKE THAT'S A FAIR
STATEMENT OR WOULD YOU TAKE
ISSUE WITH THAT- DOCTOR. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION-
I DO I DO UNDERSTAND YOUR
ANALYSIS WE ARE WE ARE LOOKING
YOU'RE DOING THAT SOMEWHERE
ANALYSIS ACROSS THE STATE. AND
WE YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY CORRECT
THE LOWER THE LOWER INCOME
AREAS OF THE STATE- ARE LESS
FACT ARE LESS VACCINATED. AND-
PART OF THE CONTRIBUTION IS
GOING TO BE THE DISTRIBUTION
RELATED TO HEALTH CARE WORKERS.
BUT I THINK EVEN THE MOST
RECENT DATA AS PRESENTED BY LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SHOWING THAT
EVEN MORE RECENTLY WITHIN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY THERE IS-
INEQUITIES IN WHO'S GETTING
VACCINATED. AND I KNOW THAT'S
GOING TO TURN OUT TO BE TRUE
WHEN WE START LOOKING AT THE
STATE DATA. SO I YEP WE
ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH YOU AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
OUR EQUITY PATRICK. IN OUR
APPROACH IS REALLY CRITICAL
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO BE
FCUSED USING THAT HEALTHY
PLACES INDEX. THAT IS GOING TO
ALLOW US TO FOCUS ON THOSE
AREAS OF THE STATE THAT HAVE
LOWER INCOME. SO AREAS LIKE
MERCED WILL HAVE RECEIVE
RECEIVE MORE ATTENTION AND MORE
VACCINE AND MORE RESOURCES SO
THAT WE CAN ADDRESS THE EQUITY
THAT YOU SUMMARIZED REALLY
NICELY. MY PREVIOUS THAT THE-
YOU CAN IMAGINE HOW FRUSTRATING
IT IS- PARTICULARLY COMING FROM
THEIR CULTURAL COMMUNITY WHERE
MANY OF MY CONSTITUENTS HAVE
GONE TO WORK THROUGHOUT THIS
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS TO ENSURE
THAT ALL OF US CAN EAT IN LA
AND SAN FRANCISCO UP AND DOWN
THE STATE. AND WE'VE AT TIMES
BEEN THE SUBJECT MY COMMUNITY
OF KIND OF A HARSH CRITICISM
THAT- WE WERE OUT WORK IN THAT
THERE WEREN'T ENOUGH. SAFETY
MEASURES IN PLACE- WE HAD ONE
OF THE CAUCUSES HERE I THINK
LATINO CAUCUS OR WRITE A LETTER
SUGGESTING- SOME OF OUR
EMPLOYERS WERE ABUSING THEIR
EMPLOYEES BY NOT HAVING THAT
THE NECESSARY- MASS AND
PRECAUTIONARY- THINGS IN PLACE.
NOT I'VE HEARD DEAFENING
SILENCE FROM ALL THE CAUCUSES
NOW THAT THE VACCINES ARE
NOBODY'S WRITTEN A LETTER
SAYING HEY LET'S SEND SOME
VACCINES TO MERCED COUNTY AND
HELP OUT. THESE FOLKS WHO'VE
BEEN FEEDING US ALL FOR MANY
MANY MONTHS SO IT'S FRUSTRATING
TO SAY THE LEAST. I APPRECIATE
HEARING THAT COUNTIES LIKE
MERCED YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'VE GOT
THE FIFTH HIGHEST DEATH RATE
YET WE HAVE THE THIRD LOWEST
ALLOCATION OF VACCINES. ARE
GONNA GET TO INCREASE THE
TENSION AND I KNOW THAT
SOMETHING YOU ALL BEEN WORKING
ON I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING.
THE RESULTS OF INCREASED
ALLOCATIONS INTO THESE
COMMUNITIES. OF NEED. BUT I
HOPE THAT WE CAN SHARE SOME OF
THE STATE OF THAT I'VE RAISED
WITH YOU HERE THIS AFTERNOON
AND WHAT I CAN SHARE SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES. AND WE CAN REALLY
START TO DRILL DOWN ON A- PATH
FORWARD THAT'S NOT. EACH OF US
TRYING TO TAKE FROM EACH OTHER
BUT RATHER JUST A FAIR METRIC
ACROSS ALL COUNTIES ACROSS ALL
COMMUNITIES- WE DESPERATELY
NEED TO GET- A HUGE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE BACKSTAGE NOT JUST HERE
IN CALIFORNIA BUT THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY AND- IT'S NOT LOST
ON ME AND I'M SURE IT'S NOT
LOST ON MY COLLEAGUES WHEN WE
PICK UP THE NEWSPAPERS ARE READ
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING AROUND THE
COUNTRY. IN MANY CASES THE
SMALLER. MAYBE YOU COULD SAY
EVEN MORE CONSERVATIVE. STATES
THAT HAVE BEEN. LESS FOCUSED IN
A WAY ON SPECIFIC POPULATIONS
WERE RATHER JUST ROLLING THINGS
OUT AND KIND OF GETTING RED
TAPE AND BLOCKS ON THE WAY SEEM
TO HAVE HAD SOME SUCCESS AND
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT SAME
SUCCESS REPLICATED IN EVERY
COMMUNITY I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT CALIFORNIA LEAD
THE WAY IN LOOKING THROUGH AN
EQUITY LENS THROUGH- METRICS TO
ENSURE. ACCESS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE ALL COMMUNITIES THAT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT WE JUST MOVED
THINGS FORWARD HERE AND-
SOMETIMES CALIFORNIA LEADS THE
WAY IN BARACK RECEIVE RED TAPE.
I WAS JUST WATCHING BILL MAHER
ON HBO RECENTLY AND MAYBE SOME
YOU SAW THE SHOW APPARENTLY
HE'S BEEN SPENDING FOR FIVE
YEARS TRYING TO SOLDIER ON
THROUGH CAN'T GET ENOUGH. IT
LOOKS LIKE THE DOCTOR SAW THE
SHOW. SO LET'S ALL WORK
TOGETHER IN PLEASE SEE THE
LEGISLATURE YOU KNOW OUR
RESPECTIVE COMMITTEE CHAIRS
HERE WHO YOU KNOW HAD THE
FORESIGHT TO BRING US ALL
TOGETHER AND HAVE THIS
DISCUSSION ON THE OVERSIGHT YOU
KNOW THE PROGRAMS BUT USE THIS
IS A RESOURCE- PLEASE- I KNOW
THERE'S- EVERYBODY'S- DROWNING
IN THE AMOUNT OF. CHAOS AND
DIFFICULTY AND CHALLENGING
TIMES OUT THERE BUT LET'S ALL
WORK TOGETHER HERE TO ENSURE
THAT WE- REYES- EVERYBODY'S
BOAT. RIGHT NOT JUST- THE BIG
COUNTIES YOU KNOW I MEAN I
REALIZE WE HAVE A SPEAKER FROM
LA AND MAYBE THAT'S WHY- IT HAS
ALL THE- RESOURCES WE HAVE A
PRO TEM FROM SAN DIEGO MAYBE
THAT'S HELP IN SAN DIEGO. LET'S
START FOCUSING ON THE WHOLE
STATE I KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR
AGREES WITH ME ON THIS. BECAUSE
THIS IS THE SAME GOVERNOR WHO
ACTUALLY MADE THE INVESTMENT.
IN A MEDICAL SCHOOL IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY. IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET WHO'S HAVE SUPPORTED MY
COLLEAGUE IN RIVERSIDE GROWING
MEDICAL PROGRAMS MORE NURSES
MORE DOCS MORE HEALTH CARE
INFRASTRUCTURE. LESS
BUREAUCRACY LESS RED TAPE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME. RIGHT AT THE
TOP LET'S I TRIED TO- TO GO TO
THE ZOOM AND BRING ON ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD WHO IS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY AND
WOULD LIKE TO. ASK A QUESTION.
GREAT THANK YOU THERE ARE
CHAIRS IF YOU CAN HEAR ME OKAY.
I CAN HEAR OKAY YES WE CAN
THANK YOU WONDERFUL NOW THANK
YOU AND- THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATIONS HERE TODAY FROM
DOWN HERE IN SAN DIEGO- I. WANT
TO ASK A COUPLE QUESTIONS BUT
ALL REALLY- DURING THE LOCAL
SECTIONAL TO TAILOR THEM- TO
THE STATEWIDE PANEL I
APPRECIATE ON THE INFORMATION
THE UPDATES- THAT WE'RE SEEING
HERE- DOWN HERE WE HAVE BEEN
THE BENEFICIARY OF THE EARLY
PILOT WITH THE MY TERM PROJECTS
AND I'VE GOTTA SAY ANECDOTALLY
THAT WE'VE HAD. A LOT OF
POSITIVE CONSTITUENT FEEDBACK
BE EASE AND ACCESSIBILITY OF
THE INFORMATION TO EVEN SIGN UP
FOR AN APPOINTMENT TO BE ABLE
TO GET THAT NOTIFICATION WE
ALSO HAD IT REALLY BECAUSE OF
THE LEADERSHIP WITH OUR NEW
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH UC SAN DIEGO
HEALTH- THE ABILITY TO WORK ON
ONE OF THE SUPERCENTERS THAT I
KNOW WHEN I WAS HAPPY THAT THE
GOVERNOR AND HIS TEAM WAS ABLE
TO BE HERE. JUST THIS PAST
MONDAY REALLY SEE HOW WE'VE
ALREADY GOTTEN A HUNDRED
THOUSAND SHOTS IN ARMS AND
WE'RE ABLE TO DO A LOT MORE
THROUGHPUT IT CAME WITH ITS
INITIAL HICCUPS AND START UP
CHALLENGES AND SO WE REALLY
WORK THROUGH THOSE
OPERATIONALLY ON THE LOCAL
LEVEL BUT- YOU KNOW WE ARE
SEEING SOME POSITIVE EFFECTS
BECAUSE OF THIS ASSISTANCE AND
I AM CERTAINLY GRATEFUL FOR
THAT. I'M ALSO MINDFUL FOR SOME
COLLEAGUES ON THE MY TURN
SYSTEM THAT RECOGNIZE THAT
THEIR LOCAL COUNTIES ARE HAVING
SOME INFORMATION SYSTEMS THAT
THEY FEEL ARE WORKING WELL AND
SO I WOULD WANT TO UNDERSCORE
AND- REALLY SUPPORT THEM IF
THEY FEEL LIKE- THERE IS
SOMETHING THAT IS WORKING GREAT
DON'T BREAK IT- AND MAKE SURE
THAT MY TURN IS INTEGRATED WELL
AND THAT YOU KNOW THEY'RE ABLE
TO NOT HAVE THAT. ADDITIONAL
HICK UPS BECAUSE EVERYDAY
MATTERS IN THE BUSINESS OF WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO- I HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS SPECIFIC TO
MY TURN ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE HAD DOWN HERE IN SAN
DIEGO IS JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE NUMBER OF
VACCINES THAT WE HAVE TO WORK
WITH AND- HOW FAST WE CAN GET
THE NOW. WE HADN'T NOTICED THAT
BECAUSE THEY ARE COMING IN FROM
DISTRICT FROM DIFFERENT TO
DIFFERENT POINTS WHETHER IT'S
DIRECTLY TO THE COUNTY- TO-
INDIVIDUAL PROVIDERS TO
PHARMACIES- UNIQUELY DOWN HERE
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE-
IS MY TURN OR OTHER SOME OF
THESE LARGER SYSTEMS ABLE TO
NOW BETTER TALK TO EACH OTHER.
TO REALLY GIVE US A REAL TIME
SCENARIO- HAT WE HAVE TO WORK.
WHERE IT GOING- THIS IS TO LEAD
AND MY NECK. QUESTION. HI THIS
IS AMY AGAIN- I'LL TAKE A STAB
AT THE- TRYING TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION- BUT I MAY HAVE TO ASK
THE- DOCTOR GOING TO SPEAK TO
THE- ANTICIPATION OF THE
DELIVERY OF THE HOUSE. SO ONE
OF THE INTENT- IS DEFINITELY TO
HAVE A BETTER INTEGRATION ONCE
MY TURN IT'S BEING YOU KNOW I.
WROTE OUT STATEWIDE INTERMIXED
ENJOYING. AND THE GOAL FROM
THERE IS THAT- WITH THE
ANTICIPATED- DOES COMING IN
THERE IS INFORMATION COMING
FROM THE- CDC. DATABASE ARE
TELLING US WHEN THAT THOSE THAT
ARE BEING DELIVERED AND ARRIVE.
BASED ON THAT THERE IS A-
ALLOCATION PROCESS AND BASED ON
ALLOCATION PROCESS AND THE
COUNTY IN THIS CASE. WOULD HAVE
A BETTER KNOWLEDGE WHEN THE-
HENCE THE THEY CAN START. DOES
THIS IS OUT HE SO. THEY HAVE
DIRECT DELIVERY STRAIGHT TO
WALGREENS OR STRAIGHT TO- THE
DOT. IS NOT GOING THROUGH THE
STATE'S EATERS- YOU KNOW
PHYSICALLY GOING THROUGH THE
SYSTEM OF THE STATE- ALLOCATION
PROCESS OR RE LEAST AWARE OF
THAT BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO
GET AN UNDERSTANDING HERE. OF
THE TOTALITY OF WHAT WE HAVE IN
OUR COUNTY REGARDLESS OF WHO
ULTIMATELY RECEIVING IT. RIGHT
SO I DO WANT TO DIFFERENTIATE
SO WALGREEN BELONGS TO WHAT IS
NOT A PHARMACY PROGRAM AND
THAT'S DIRECTLY COMING FOM THE
FEDERAL. IN THE PHARMACY
PROGRAM IN TERMS OF DELIVERY
AND TRACKING NOT COME THROUGH
MY TURN. MY FEET YEAH THAT
THAT'S- IT- SO THAT COULD BE AN
IMPROVEMENT- JUST SO WE KIND OF
REAL TIME KNOW WHAT WE HAVE TO
WORK WITH AND WHAT'S GOING
WHERE ON JUST SO WE CAN ADJUST
IF NECESSARY. WHAT WE HAVE IN
OUR CONTROL AND OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES TO BE ABLE TO
GET OUT THERE AS A WORKING
THROUGH THE TEARS AND THROUGH
OUR PUBLIC SYSTEMS HERE- IT'S
IT THAT THAT'S ONE SORT OF-
OPEN QUESTION IS STILL OUT
THERE HOW DO WE UNDERSTAND THE
TOTALITY. OF WHAT WE HAVE TO
WORK WITH ON THIS DOES GET INTO
MY NEXT QUESTION ABOUT EQUITY
AND- AND IT. LOOKS OF WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLYMEMBER GREAT
SAID TO- THERE ARE SO MANY WAYS
THAT WE LOOK AT THIS I'M
SENSITIVE AND I CERTAINLY AM
EMPATHETIC AND- TO- MAKING SURE
THAT COMMUNITIES OF CONCERN
THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN HIT THE
HARDEST. ARE ALSO THE ONES THAT
ARE RECEIVING EXTRA ATTENTION
TO MAKE SHORE- THAT WE'RE
SUPPORTING THEM THAT WE'RE
GETTING THEM UP TO THE STATUS
OF GOOD HEALTH AND GOOD
SECURITY- FOR THEIR FUTURE
HEALTH- I RECOGNIZE THAT WERE A
DIFFERENT COUNTY LEVELS WORKING
ON YOU KNOW THE DIFFERENT HERE-
THAT YOUR CRITERIA AND
EVERYBODY IS SLIGHTLY IN
DIFFERENT PLACES- DIFFERENT AGE
GROUPS DIFFERENT OCCUPATIONS-
FOR ME I WANT TO KNOW IN THIS
BROAD CALCULUS. ESPECIALLY AS
WERE IMPROVING THIS REAL TIME
DATA THROUGH MY TURN ARE YOU
STARTING TO LOOK AT- WHERE- WE
ARE SEEING REAL TIME INFECTION
RATES SO WHERE WE ARE SEEING.
SOME OF THE BIGGEST- CHANGES IN
MAYBE NEW AT. IF WE HAVE REGION
THE STATE OR S. LOCALITY. THAT
WE ARE DEEPLY. WITH CAN THERE
BE SOME MASSAGING OF THAT
DELIVERY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE GETTING IN THERE BEFORE
THAT OUTBREAK REALLY CAUSES
MAJOR. PROBLEMS IN THE HEALTH
CARE SECTOR. I CAN GO AHEAD.
AND TAKE THAT- THAT'S A THAT'S
A REALLY GOOD QUESTION- FIRST
AYE AYE I WANNA MAKE ONE
COMMENT ABOUT ABOUT MY TURN
THAT I'M GOING TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. THE REGARD REGARDLESS
OF- THE STATE ALSO HAS AN
IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY. WHICH WE
CALL CARE FOR CATS- CALIFORNIA
MUSICIAN REGISTRY. REGARDLESS
THE WORTH OF THE GET THE
MINISTER YOU HAVE TO GO INTO A
SAID ELECTRONIC SYSTEM SOME
SYSTEM. EVENT COMMUNICATES TO
CARE. ITSELF THE KAISER'S MOST
OF MOST THE MUSIC APPLIQUE LIKE
TRONIC HEALTH RECORD IT
COMMUNICATES TO CARE IF YOU GET
AT A MEGASITE THE USING MY
TURN. IT CAN IT COMMUNICATES
INTO CARE SO CARRY VASTLY
BECOMES OF. THE PLACE OF RECORD
OF EVERYBODY THAT'S BEEN
VACCINATED CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING TO REGIONAL
IMMUNIZATION REGISTRIES UPDATED
TO CARE WHICH IS SAN DIEGO THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. SO THAT'S
ONE ISSUE THE OTHER ISSUE IS
REALLY OUR TESTING SYSTEM
RIGHT. SO THIS IS YOUR BREAKING
UP A REALLY IMPORTANT POINT
BECAUSE YOU'RE BRINGING UP
INFECTION RATES. START WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE TO CONTINUE TO GET
TESTED. YES IF YOU HAVE
SYMPTOMS EVEN IF YOU DON'T EVEN
IF YOU DON'T HAVE SYMPTOMS AND
YOU WANT TO KNOW YOUR STATUS.
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE YOU MAY BE
EXPOSED TO HIGHER RISK
ABSOLUTELY GET TESTED BECAUSE
OTHERWISE WE WILL NOT PICK UP
THE SIGNALS WE NEED TO KNOW
WHETHER. I COMMUNITIES HAVING
MORE INFECTION. AND SO THAT'S
THAT THAT'S REALLY VERY VERY
POOR THANK YOU FOR GOING OUT.
SO IF THE TESTING GOES WELL DO
YOU THINK THAT WE CAN GET TO A
POINT SOON THAT THAT'S A PART
OF THE CALCULUS OF. HOW YOU'RE
ALLOCATING FORTHCOMING- THAT
MILES WELL WE HAVE ALL OF A
SUDDEN YOU KNOW A NEW SURGERY
NEW RISE JUST IN SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY OR JUST IN THIS.
COMMUNITY WITHIN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY DOT KNOWN DATA I HOPE
THAT YOU KNOW ON ANTICIPATED
FEDERAL CATIONS CAN HELP TO
SUPPORT THAT SO IT DOESN'T BLOW
UP INTO A HEALTH CARE CRISIS
LOCALLY. YEAH YES SO YOU'RE
BREAKING UP A REALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND THAT IS IT'S ALMOST
LIKE FIRES IF THERE'S A HOT
SPOT YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO
DETECT IT SO YOU CAN GO IN
THERE AND VACCINATE. AND
THAT'LL BE PART OF THE
STATEWIDE STRATEGY IN TERMS OF
SURVEILLANCE OF LOOKING FOR HOT
SPOTS BECAUSE YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT- THAT THE EQUITY METRIC
AND FOCUSING ON. HOW THE PLACES
INDEX AND. LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES HELPS US. HOWEVER
THE HOT SPOT NEAR. RIGHT
BECAUSE- RIGHT TAXES MOVE
THROUGH IN YOUR YOUR ABSOLUTE
CORRECT. OKAY THINK THAT THANK
YOU I LOOK FOR TO MINOR AND I
HOPE THAT THAT BECOMES A- OF
OUR- WE GOING- CLOSE. WITH- I'M
OF THAT THAT NUMBER THE LGBT.
AND OUR LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS- I
HAD A CONCERN I WANT TO PASS ON
FROM A LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS YOU
NEED TO FIND THAT. OUT REALLY
SEE SOME OF THE DISTRIBUTION ON
THE ISSUES FAILING- LGBTQ
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES- AND
I'M WONDERING THIS WASN'T
REALLY MEANT FOR THE LOCAL
PANEL THAT PERHAPS YOU CAN
SPEAK TO SOME OF YOUR GUIDANCE.
FOR LOCALITIES MORE BROADLY FOR
THOSE WITH ACCESSIBILITY
ISSUES- THEY CAN'T DEAL WITH
LONG LINES THAT NEED ASL
INTERPRETATION- THAT HAVE
WHEELCHAIR CHALLENGES- IS NOT
BEING A PART OF THE GUIDANCE
AND THAT THE- RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT YOU'RE MAKING TO. ANY
WEATHER TO SUPERCENTER ANY
POINT OF DELIVERY- SAID THAT-
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES OR
THOSE CHALLENGES ARE- YOU
BLEED- AND TREATED. SO
CURRENTLY BOTH ARE. COMMUNITY
COMMITTEE. AND OUR DRAFTING
GUIDELINES COMMITTEES WORKING
ON GUIDELINES TO ADDRESS THAT
SPECIFIC ISSUE. IT MAY BE FIVE
TO AGE THE OTHER CATEGORIES
THAT WERE ADDRESSING IS PERSONS
WITH CHRONIC MEDICAL CONDITIONS
THAT PUT THEM AT HIGHER HIGHER
RISK FOR DYING. AND PERSONS WHO
HAVE DISABILITY AND SO WE'RE
ACTUALLY WORKING ON THAT RIGHT
NOW AND WE'RE WORKING WITH-
DISABILITY ADVOCATES TO MAKE
SURE WE GET IT RIGHT. AND WE'RE
WE'RE WORKING ON IMPLEMENTATION
PLANTS OKAY. YOU SHOULD SEE
THAT HOPEFULLY WITHIN- PROBABLY
WITHIN DAYS BECAUSE IT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU
THAT'S GREAT NEWS TO HEAR FOR
THEM ALL PASSED THAT ON LAST
WEEK- FOR I HEARD I THINK FROM
THE- MISS RODRIGUEZ FROM THE
OFFICE OF THE OVERNOR. A NOTE
THAT YOU WERE GOING TO WORK A
LITTLE BIT MORE TO MAKE SURE
THAT ACROSS ALL OF OUR- AREAS
OF EQUITY WHETHER IT'S- BASED
ON. RACE OR GENDER OR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION. OR DISABILITY THAT
WERE LOOKING FOR HE'S ACTUALLY
EQUITY METRICS FOR TRACKING-
VACCINE DISTRIBUTIONS AND I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THAT YOU
MIGHT BE AWARE- WE'VE HAD A
FROM A CAUCUS PERSPECTIVE A
CHALLENGE UNDERSTANDING ABOUT
THE IMPLEMENTATION. OF SB NINE
THIRTY TWO FROM LAST YEAR AND-
UNDERSTOOD WAS- DIRECTED- DPH
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
TRACKING COOL THEY TEST
RESULTS. ARE BASED ON
ORIENTATION OR GENDER IDENTITY
IF THEY SO CHOSE TO DISCLOSE
THAT SO HOW ARE WE ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND WE STILL HAVEN'T
REALLY UNDERSTOOD WE'RE HEARING
FROM- PARTNERS ACROSS THE STATE
THAT STILL IS NOT BEING
COLLECTED. HOW DO WE KNOW THAT
WE ARE REALLY REACHING THE-
POPULATION OR NOT COMMUNITY
THROUGH VACCINATIONS- EVER
STILL CHALLENGE OR CAN YOU TELL
ME WHERE TO FIND IT THAT'S IT
HAS NOT BEEN- CIRCULATED BACK
TO US. THE CODE TEST RESULTS
BASED. ON ORIENTATION OR GENDER
IDENTITY. I'M THANK YOU FOR THE
CORE. I DON'T KNOW IF THE MY
CELL RODRIGUEZ HAS HAS AN
ANSWER TO THAT- BUT OTHERWISE.
I KNOW I KNOW THAT'S A GAP
AREA. WE MET RECENTLY WITH-
CENTER SCOTT WIENER ON THIS
VERY ISSUE. TO SORT OF GET GET
EXACTLY WHAT'S HOLDING US BACK.
BUT IT IS IT'S AN AREA THAT
WE'VE IDENTIFIED THE HAS TO BE
FIXED. WELL I DON'T HAVE THE
SPECIFICS AT THE MOMENT BUT I
CAN I CAN MAKE SURE TO GET IT I
DON'T KNOW BUT IT'S A LOT HAS
ANY. ANYTHING TO ADD TO THAT.
YES I WANTED TO AND THAT
WOULDN'T THIS IS WHY IT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO LAYER DIFFERENT
DATA POINTS SO THAT WE CAN
CAPTURE- AS MUCH OF THE
POPULATION THAT HAS BEEN- AND
DISPROPORTIONATE PACKET BY CO
THAT AND- AND TAKING SORT OF.
YOU KNOW INSIGHTS FROM WHAT
WE'VE DONE IN THE PAST. THIS IS
JUST SIMPLY THE DEFENSIVE
EFFORT BY MENTION WORK. LOOKING
AT H. P. I WERE LOOKING AT THE
HARD TO COUNT AND THAT
SOMEWHERE LIKE LOOKING ECHO THE
POSITIVITY DATE. DATA AND SO.
HOPING WITH THE FLARING OF DATA
THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE
TRAVELING- THE RIGHT
POPULATIONS AND THEN AS WE WORK
WITH OUR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT THEY HAVE TO
REACH INTO THOSE PARTICULAR
COMMUNITIES- SO LAYERING ON
DIFFERENT APPROACHES DIFFERENT
DATA. AND TO TRY AND INFORM OUR
EFFORTS AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
OKAY THANK YOU I Y. PRESET THAT
RESPONSE IF YOU CAN KEEP OUR
CAUCUS AND SENATOR WIENER
APPRISED OF- AGAIN CONNECTING
THESE DOTS GOING WHAT'S GOING
ON WITH DATA. FROM D. TESTING
INFORMATION AND SO WE CAN
REALLY CONNECT WITH OXIDATION
IS TO SEE IF THERE ARE. FURTHER
DISPARITIES ABOUT REACHING
PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITIES- TO
MY EARLIER POINT ABOUT EQUITY-
IT CERTAINLY APPRECIATE ABOUT A
CAUCUS ON THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THE PRESENTATION. FOR THE TIME
TODAY FOR QUESTIONS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON. THANK YOU
MADAM AND THAT IS WHAT I AS OUR
PAN FOR BEING HERE TODAY WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR
PRESENTATION- YOU KNOW I KNOW
THAT THE VACCINE PRIORITIZATION
FRAMEWORK HAS CHANGED FOUR
TIMES SINCE SINCE DECEMBER AND-
I HAVE SEVERAL OF YOU
MENTIONED- YOU KNOW THE
CHALLENGES WITH. GETTING
ACCURATE DATA- BUT I'M JUST
CONCERNED ABOUT- ESSENTIAL
WORKERS POSSIBLY BEING LEFT
BEHIND. IN THIS VACCINATION
ROLLOUT IN PROCESS- YOU KNOW
THERE SEEMS TO BE A LOT OF
CONFUSION- FROM GROCERY CLERK
SAID DON'T KNOW WHEN THEY CAN
GET VACCINATED BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT SURE BECAUSE THE
INFORMATION KEEPS CHANGING. SO
I'M WONDERING IF YOU COULD
SPEAK TO THAT. I'LL GO AHEAD
AND MAKE THEM MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS AND SO RIGHT NOW WE
ARE IN THE PHASE ONE B. E. R.
WITCHING WHICH INCLUDES- AS WE
MENTIONED EARLIER ABOUT SIXTY
FIVE IN THE THREE THE THREE
SECTORS. WHICH IS EDUCATION
EDUCATION CHILD KERR FOOD AND
AGRICULTURAL AND THEN EMERGENCY
RESPONDENTS. SO WE HAVE PUT UP
ON THE WEBSITE THERE IS IN AND
OUT. MAKING OPERATIONAL DOES
REQUIRE A LOT OF EXTRA A LOT OF
EXTRA WORK BECAUSE THEN PEOPLE
ASK OKAY- IF I IF I WORK IN THE
FOOD INDUSTRY DO I QUALIFY. AND
SO THAT'S BEEN ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES OF DOING SEX THAT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY IT SLOW
IT SLOWS THINGS DOWN. I'M HONOR
WEBSITE THERE IS A LINK THAT
HAS THAT THAT'S BASED ON OUR
ESSENTIAL- ESSENTIAL JOB
CLASSIFICATIONS THAT HAS BEEN
UP THERE FOR A LONG TIME WHICH
THAT DEFINE THE SOCIAL WORKERS.
AND IT HAS THOSE SPECIFIC BILL
SPECIFIC CATEGORIES ARE DEFINED
ONLINE AND THAT WILL HELP THAT
WILL HELP IN TERMS OF THE OUR
REGION AND THE TARGETING. THE
CHALLENGE WITH SECTORS IS
REALLY GOING TO BE
VERIFICATION. AND SO THAT'S
ALWAYS BEEN A TREND THAT'S
ALWAYS GONNA BE A CHALLENGE
WITH SECTORS- AND THAT'S WHY
WORKING WITH EMPLOYERS WORKING
WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS REALLY HAVING
TARGETED OUTREACH. AND
VACCINATION SITES THAT ARE MORE
DIRECTLY INTERACTING WITH THOSE
WORKERS IS IT'S GOING TO BE OUT
I THINK PROBABLY MORE
SUCCESSFUL STRATEGY. AND HOW
THAT PLAYS OUT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE IT'S GOING TO TAKE TIME.
AND I THINK THIS IS PART OF THE
OUTRAGE IS GONNA BE REALLY POOR
THE STOCK UP ON MY CELL-
RODRIGUEZ IS WORKING ON- I HOPE.
THAT ANSWERS THE MOST YOUR
QUESTION. YES THANK YOU.
ACTUALLY HAVE A FOLLOW UP
QUESTION ALSO RELATED TO THE
PRIORITIZATION FRAMEWORK- AS
THE NUMBER CALDERON NOTED IT'S
CHANGED BOB I THINK FOUR TIMES
SINCE SINCE DECEMBER IT SOUNDS
LIKE WE'RE STILL. FINALIZING
SOME ADDITIONAL CHANGES TO
THAT- I GUESS CAN YOU SPEAK TO
WHY THIS IS CHANGING WE'VE HAD
WE'VE HAD ADVISORY COMMITTEE
MEETING SINCE APRIL WHY DO WE
KEEP CHANGING THIS AND-
BECAUSE- QUESTION ONE NUMBER
TO. THINK RECOGNIZING THAT
CONSISTENCY AND CLARITY IS A
REALLY REALLY CRITICAL BOTH FOR
THE PUBLIC AND FOR OUR
PARTNERS- ARE YOU GONNA KEEP
CHANGING THE FRAMEWORK OR CAN
WE SAY THIS IS THAT THIS IS OUR
PLAN. AND IT'S ALL SYSTEMS GO.
YES SIR IF YOU LOOK AT THE
FRAMEWORK THAT WAS PUBLISHED
ONLINE THERE WAS ONE A- ONE
EIGHT DID NOT CHANGE. ONE B.
HOW TO TEARS. PEOPLE HAVE
ALREADY STARTED PHASE ONE B.
TIER ONE- THAT INITIALLY HAD
ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE IN THE
SECTOR GROUPS. SOME AREAS
STARTED TO DO THAT BECAUSE THEY
HAD ALREADY MOVED THROUGH PHASE
ONE DAY IN THEIR AREA FOR
EXAMPLE THIS IS MORE TRUE OF
NON URBAN AREAS THEY HAD
ALREADY VACCINATED HEALTHCARE
WORKERS AND THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND THEIR EVENT AND DEPENDING
ON THEIR THEIR WORK FORCE THEY
HAD ALREADY GOTTEN THROUGH FOR
EXAMPLE BXLEY THE TEACHERS AND
PEOPLE THAT THAT QUALIFIED AND
THEY WERE READY TO MOVE ON TO
PHASE ONE B. SO WE SAID IF
YOU'RE READY TO MOVE ON TO
PHASE ONE BEATS HERE ONE GO
AHEAD. THE FIRST CHANGE WE MADE
WAS WE TOOK IT WAS AGE SEVENTY
FIVE IN A BOX. WE ACTUALLY
MOVED IT DOWN TO SIXTY FIVE IN
A BAR IN THERE REALLY WAS JUST
LOOKING AT THE DATA- OF THE
DEATHS IN CAPTAIN CALIFORNIA SO
75% OF DEATHS WERE OCCURRING IN
PERSON SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER AND
MOST OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
DYING WERE PEOPLE WHO WERE
AFRICAN AMERICAN. AND LATINO.
AND SO THAT. SO WAS WHAT I WAS
THE OUR DATA WITH. AT THAT WE-
HAVE TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. AND
WE'RE RECOGNIZING THEIR SEX
DEBATE SECTOR BASED APPROACH.
IS SLOWER BECAUSE OF THE
VERIFICATION ISSUE. I DON'T
REALLY ACROSS THE UNITED STATES
PEOPLE RECOGNIZE INCLUDING
OFFICES. RECOGNIZE THAT TAKING
AN AGE BUT IT'S TAKING A MORE
DELIBERATE AGE BASED APPROACH.
WAS NOT ONLY MORE ETHICAL WHO'S
GONNA BE MORE EFFECTIVE IN
SAVING LIVES. AND ALSO IN TERMS
OF IN TERMS OF EQUITY IN TERMS
OF. PEOPLE BEING ABLE TO SEE
WHERE THEY ARE AGE WISE. AND SO
THAT WAS A THAT WAS THE FIRST
CHANGE THAT WE MADE. ON THE
SECOND THE SECOND CHANGE THAT
WE MADE IT IS REALLY NOT WHAT
HASN'T COME IS GONNA BE THIS
WHAT'S GONNA COME NEXT. WHICH
IS GOING TO BE A RECOGNIZING
THAT. AGES IMPORTANCE AGE IS
REALLY THE FIRST ONE TO FOCUS
ON BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THE
BIGGEST RISK IS YOU HEARD
EARLIER AND SOME OF THE
TESTIMONY. WE ALSO HAVE TO DEAL
WITH PEOPLE HAVE CHRONIC
MEDICAL CONDITIONS THE PERSON
WHO HAVE SEVERE DISABILITIES.
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES NOT
ONLY HAVE THE RISK OF. DYING
FROM KOBE. WHICH SHOULD THEY
GET INFECTED THEY HAVE THEY
HAVE. CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF
GETTING THEY MAY BE HOME BROWN
THEIR CHALLENGES. THEY MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO GET THE SITES WERE
VACCINATIONS AND KERR. SO THEY
PROVIDE UNIQUE CHALLENGES AND
SO WE'RE REALLY COMMITTED TO
MAKING SURE THAT WE ADDRESS
THAT FROM AN EQUITY ISSUE. SO
THAT'S REALLY THAT THAT'S
REALLY THE SECOND CHANGE IN OF
ALL MENTION OF THE LAST ONE.
THE LAST ONE IS THE ONE THAT I
JUST MENTIONED TO YOU WHICH IS.
ONLINE GIVING MORE SPECIFICITY
TO WHAT WE MEAN BY THOSE. GAPS
SECTORS. ARE BECAUSE PEOPLE
NEED MORE SPECIFICITY SO HEALTH
CARE WORKERS NEED TO KNOW WHERE
I'M A HEALTH CARE WORKER BUT-
WHERE EXACTLY. ARE THESE
INCLUDE TENSES OF THAT INCLUDE
OTHER SECTORS. SO THAT'S ALL
BEEN CLARIFIED ONLINE SO THAT
PEOPLE. HAVE THAT HAVE A
SPECIFIC. GREAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THAT I'M SO.
CURRENT PRIORITY OF ONE A AND
ONE. HOW MANY THE ADULTS IS
THAT MEN LIKE TEND. ADULTS FIVE
I DON'T HAVE THE NUMBER ON THE
BUT IT IS ONLINE WE GO ONLINE
AND YOU LOOK AT IF YOU GO TO
COPE WITH COVER NINETEEN DOT CA
DOT GOV. AND YOU ARE YOU ARE
FIND A VACCINE LINK WHEN YOU GO
DOWN TO THERE THEY ACTUALLY HAS
THE ACTUAL NUMBER FOR
CALIFORNIANS THAT FIT THAT
CATEGORY. OKAY DID I GET SO
IT'S THERE BUT IT'S IN THE IT'S
IN THE MILLIONS IT'S A BIG
GROUP IT IS IT'S A BIG GROUP OF
SENIOR I MEAN SIXTY FIVE AND
OVER LOAN IS NOT MILLION SO
IT'S SOMETHING TO. CORRECT
CORRECT SIX SIX BILLION IN
SERVING OUT ON OUT ON THAT THE
SECT THE SECTOR GROUPS AND THEN
THERE'S GONNA BE SOME SOME
OVERLAP BECAUSE YOU HAVE PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN THAT SECTOR GROUP
INTERNAL DISCIPLINE SIXTY FIVE.
AND THAT THAT TOTAL NUMBER
MIGHT BE TEN MILLION BUT. I
HAVE TO FIND A LIKE TO BE MORE
PRECISE. AND SEVEN IT. ACT AS
MAY AN ANSWER. AND THEN. AND
AFTER. QUESTION SO. THE UP. IS
THAT WHEN WE ARE. MADE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT SOME TEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS WERE NOW
ELIGIBLE IS PART OF A PRIORITY
GROUP FOR THE VACCINE- AT A
MOMENT WHEN WE WERE ONLY I
THINK RECEIVING FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND VACCINES PER WEEK.
THAT REALLY DID CREATE
SERIOUSLY UNREALISTIC
EXPECTATIONS FOR MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS AND- THAT.
RESULTED IN DISAPPOINTMENT AND
FRUSTRATION AND I THINK
CONFUSION SO I MIGHT MAKE. OR
MY REQUEST IS THAT. AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WE CERTAINLY WANT TO BE
ASPIRATIONAL. WE CERTAINLY WANT
TO SET AMBITIOUS GOALS BUT MY
REQUEST IS THAT WE SET REALLY
CLEAR GOALS THAT WE CAN DELIVER
ON SAID THAT WE DO NOT SET
OURSELVES UP FOR DISAPPOINTING
OUR CONSTITUENTS. AND IF YOU
HAVE A COMMENT ON OUR
REFLECTION YEAH. WE AGREE WITH
YOU- YEAH IT IMPROVING
IMPROVING COMMUNICATION
BECOMING FASTER SCALING UP. AND
THE CHALLENGE TO IT WHAT YOU
DESCRIBED- ABSOLUTELY AND
INTERACT WITH JUST THE VERY
ABILITY IS ACROSS COUNTIES. AND
SO THAT THAT FEEDS INTO THE
FRUSTRATION SO YEAH WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMENT THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT- MR GALLAGHER.
YES I SERVICE THROUGH THE
QUESTIONS HERE ON. FIRST OF ALL
WE TALKED ABOUT TRANSPARENCY
EQUITY AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND I
THINK WE ESTABLISHED IN THE
SYRIAN THERE'S BEEN NONE OF
THAT UP UNTIL THIS POINT. SO
THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE FAILED ON
THOSE ISSUES SO. TO DEAL WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY FIRST GOT TO
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY. SO WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT HAS
HAPPENED THUS FAR. IS THE
GOVERNOR RESPONSIBLE. R. R.
THIS IS A DOCTOR AND I'LL GO
AHEAD AND GIVE YOU- LIFE BY THE
IS A STATE HEALTH OFFICER I'M
AND AS A FORMER OF LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICER- KIRKER CITY COUNTY YOU
KNOW I THINK IT'S I THINK WE
ALL HAVE IT ALL OF US ALL OF US
COLLECTIVELY HAVE A SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY- WORLD NEWS
LEADER. WHOSE WE- WHEN SAY THAT
WELL WHEN I SAY WHEN I SAY WE
YES OF FOR ME WE I'VE WORKED
AND I WORKED FOR GOVERNMENT ALL
MY- PUBLIC HEALTH CAREER SO I
SEE IT I SEE IT AS GOVERNMENT
HAVING A REAL CENTRAL ROLE BOTH
LOCAL LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT REALLY HAVING. LOCAL
ROLE AND REALLY DELIVER
DELIVERY DELIVERING ON WHAT
YOU'RE DESCRIBING OKAY BUT I
JUST WANT TO KNOW WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE AND WHO DO WE GO TO
THE TO HOLD ACCOUNTABLE RIGHT
IS THAT YOU BECAUSE I CAN TELL
YOU RIGHT NOW NONE OF THESE
MEMBERS HAVE HAD ANY SAY IN HOW
THIS IS ROLLED OUT I WASN'T IN
THE ROOM WITH YOU. DECIDE HOW
THIS WOULD BE DONE HOW I GET
DISTRIBUTED YOU KNOW THE CHAIRS
OF THIS COMMITTEE WEREN'T THERE
SO ARE YOU RESPONSIBLE BECAUSE
AS FAR AS I KNOW IT HAS BEEN
THE GOVERNOR AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND HEALTH
OFFICIALS WHO'VE BEEN
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS SO ARE YOU
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS FAILURE
YES OR NO. I'M I'M RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
PUBLIC HEALTH- IT'S I MEAN I'M
NEW TO THE DEPARTMENT OF IT
THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF MY SIX
WEEK FOR YES ARE ARE
RESPONSIBLE AND THE DECISIONS
THAT YOU'RE DESCRIBING ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT DECISIONS AND
WE REALLY RELY ON THE
SCIENTIFIC WORKGROUPS MOWING I
MENTIONED EARLIER ON. WE HAD
THREE THREE GROUPS WANT TO
FOCUS ON SAFETY THE OTHER ONE
FOCUSING ON DRAFTING GUIDELINES
AND THE COMMUNITY ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WHICH REALLY
REPRESENTS BROUGHT BROUGHT
STAKEHOLDERS NOT FROM NOT JUST
THROUGHOUT THE STATE BUT ALSO
SCIENTIFIC EXPERTISE TO REALLY
HELP US CRAFT- AND DEVELOP
DEVELOP DO DECISIONS ARE REALLY
SERVE THE BEST THE BEST
INTEREST IN TERMS OF. SIZE
SCIENCE AND ADVOCACY AND ALL
AND EVERYTHING TO GET ALSO
DESCRIBED SO THAT'S GOOD AND
THAT'S WHERE I WANT TO START WE
JUST WANT TO. ACCEPT
RESPONSIBILITY THAT'S KIND OF
WHERE WE MOVE FORWARD NOW LET
ME GO TO THAT BECAUSE I THINK
THERE WAS A LOT OF. THERE'S
BEEN VERY SMART. DOT SCIENCE
AND IN THIS- BUT DO YOU THINK
THAT ONE OF THE PROBLEMS IN
TERMS OF HOW THIS IS GONNA IN
TERMS OF DISTRIBUTION GETTING
THE VACCINE AND ARMS IS IT
MAYBE THERE WASN'T ENOUGH
PEOPLE IN THERE WHO KNOW HOW TO
DISTRIBUTE. IMPLEMENT. THAT
THAT'S NOT YOUR EXPERTISE IS IT
I MEAN WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH YOU
KNOW PRIVATE. BUSINESS FOLKS
WHO ARE USED TO GETTING OUT
THINGS ON A MASS SCALE DO YOU
THINK THAT THAT WAS ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS. WITH WHY WE DIDN'T
GET THINGS OUT AS- AS QUICKLY
AND AS EQUITABLY AS POSSIBLE.
YEAH THAT'S A THAT'S A REALLY
GOOD QUESTION AND SORT OF BY AM.
THE WELCOME THIRTY WAS WHEN WE
WERE FIRST DOING TESTING EARLY
ON IN TESTING WHEN IF YOU
REMEMBER EARLY ON AND TESTING
IT TOOK AWHILE FOR US TO GET
ALL THE INFRASTRUCTURE UP TO DO
TO DO TESTING ADDED IN A
REQUIRED IN ORDER FOR TESTING
HAPPENED IT DIDN'T IT REQUIRED.
REALLY PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE
PUBLIC SECTOR THE PRIVATE
SECTOR TO MAKE TESTING MORE
SUCCESSFUL. RUSSELL IS A RIGHT
AND I THINK IT'S ALSO GOOD TO
BE TRUE FOR THE VACCINATION I
FEEL LIKE. WE'VE BEEN
VACCINATING THAT WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER THAT THE VACCINES FOR
SPROUT HERE DECEMBER
FOURTEENTH. AND THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME IN REALLY IN US
HISTORY THAT WE HAVE A MASSIVE.
VACCINATION PROGRAM. AND SO IT
BEGINS YOU KNOW IT WOULD BE
EXPECTED THAT WOULD TAKE
SEVERAL WEEKS FOR US TO SORT OF
FIGURE OUT TO. TO GET THROUGH
THE- TO GET UP AND RUNNING SO
TO SPEAK SO TO SPEAK. ND IT'S
GOING TO IT IS GOING TO TAKE
IT'S GOING TO TAKE IT'S GOING
TO TAKE MORE THAN PUBLIC
HEALTH. YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
IT'S GONNA TAKE PHARMACIES.
HEALTH CARE SYSTEMS COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS EMPLOYERS.
FIVE IT'S GONNA TAKE ALL OF US
WORKING TOGETHER PRIVATE AND
PUBLIC SECTOR ARE COMPLETELY
FREE. RENSO MAVI I MEAN I'M I'M
NOT A QUESTION TO YOU BUT JUST
FROM THAT. OBVIOUSLY IF WE
LEARN THAT FROM TESTING WHY DID
WE APPLY THOSE THINGS NOW. AND
AGAIN IF WE KNEW THAT'S THE
CASE WHY DIDN'T WHY DIDN'T WE
INVOLVE ALL THOSE PEOPLE. AS WE
STARTED TO ROLL THIS OUT I
THINK THAT'S- SOMETHING THAT WE
BETTER MAKE SURE WE DO GOING
FORWARD- PRIORITIZATION. THIS
IS A BIG ISSUE- WE'VE ALL KNOWN
FOR A LONG TIME NOW THAT IT WAS
THOSE SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER WHO
ARE MORE LIKELY TO DIE FROM
THIS VIRUS. SO IF WE'VE KNOWN
THAT FOR A LONG TIME WHY WASN'T
THAT IN. YOUR TIER ONE EIGHT
TWO ONE B. FROM THE BEGINNING.
YOU KNOW. I MEAN WHY WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN IN THERE FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING TO PRIORITIZE
THEM FIRST NO IT WAS ACTUALLY
IT WAS ACTUALLY IN THERE FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING SO WE WORK
FROM THE NATIONAL GUIDELINES
THAT INCLUDED FROM THE CDC-
NATIONAL ACADEMIES OF SCIENCE
ENGINEERING AND MEDICINE AND
ALSO THE- ACIP THEY MENTIONED
EARLIER SO ALL THE SCIENTIFIC
BODIES GAVE US THAT INITIAL
FRAMEWORK THAT INITIAL
FRAMEWORK INCLUDED HEALTH CARE
WORKERS BECAUSE OF THEIR HIGH
RISK AND WE NEED THEM TO TREAT
US. SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES
AND ASSISTED LIVING FACILITIES
WHERE YOU REALLY HAVE THE MOST
VULNERABLE WE NEED FROM THE
DATA SO THAT ONCE FACED ONE
DEALT WITH THE MOST AND THEN
TEAR ONE OF BE ONE HAD SEVENTY
FIVE AND OLDER SO THAT WAS THE
THAT WAS BAKED IN FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING BASED ON DATA. OF THE
SEARCH THE SEARCH AND LOOKING
AT OUR DATA MADE US MADE US
RECOGNIZE THAT WE NEED TO
REALLY TIGHTEN THAT UP AND WE
TIED IT UP BY MOVING DOWN TO
SIXTY FIVE BUT THAT WAS IN
THERE IT WAS IN THEIR FRONT
FROM THE BEGINNING BASED ON
SCIENCE I'M AT THE CRIB- AT THE
NATIONAL LEVEL. RIGHT WITHIN
YOUR DEPARTMENT AND DR SISI ON
POINTED THIS OUTTHE FIRST
PANEL AND SHE SHE LAID OUT THE
TIMELINE VERY WELL ON JANUARY
THIRTEENTH YOU WERE TELLING
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS
YOU HAVE TO DO SIXTY FIVE PLUS
IN ORDER OR OLDER FIRST. BEFORE
YOU GO TO PHASE ONE B. IS THAT
RIGHT. NO NO NO IT'S- WHAT WE
SAID WAS WHAT WE SAID WAS-
WHICH WE DROP THE H. DRIVE THE
H. AND WE ASKED THEM TO
PRIORITIZE PRIORITIZE AGE AND
THE SECTOR GROUPS STILL STAYED
IN THERE AND WE ASK THEM TO
ALSO ANSWER VACCINATING OLDER
PERSONS ALSO PRIORITIZE THAT
THE GROUPS AS A SUB CATEGORY
WELL THAT'S WHAT AND THAT'S NOT
LIKE A PUBLIC HEALTH. IS THAT
MEMBER GALLAGHER CAN YOU AS ONE
MORE QUESTION SO CAN MOVE ON TO
YEAH MISTER SEA ARTISTS AND
GIVE I'M SAYING THAT'S NOT WHAT
THE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS
HAVE SAID IS THAT THAT WAS THE
DIRECTIVE AND THEN ON FEBRUARY
FOURTH YOU GOT THE GOVERNOR
CAME OUT WITH THE DIRECTIVE
THAT YOU COULD DO BOTH.
CATEGORIES OKAY CORRECT CORRECT
CORRECT BUT NOW IT WOULD BE ON
THE ON THE SECTORS AND RAISES
MY LAST QUESTION BECAUSE IT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT NOW WE HAVE
CONFUSION. WE HAVE SOME
COUNTIES. THAT ARE SAYING NO WE
CAN ONLY DO SIXTY FIVE AND PLUS
WE WILL NOT MOVE TO THE OTHER
ONE BE. CATEGORIES SO GROCERY
CLERKS- FARMWORKERS- TEACHERS
AND OTHER STAFF IN OUR IN OUR
SCHOOLS THEY CANNOT GET
VACCINATED IN THESE COUNTIES
BECAUSE THE PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS HAVE TAKEN A DIRECTOR
THEY SAID THEY FIRST GOT FROM
YOU GUYS. TO ONLY DO SIXTY FIVE
AND OLDER FIRST SO SOME
COUNTIES HAVE THAT AND OTHERS
ARE VACCINE AS WE SAID A
VACCINATED. HAVE GONE WAY INTO
ONE B. AND VACCINATED NOW WE DO
MY TURN. IS THAT GONNA CHANGE.
WHEN A PERSON SIGNS UP IN YUBA
AND SUTTER COUNTIES WERE AT
WORK ONE OF THE COUNTIES I
REPRESENT. IF THEY SIGN UP ON
MY TURN IN THEIR OVER SIXTY
FIVE OR THEIR OR THEY'RE A
WORKER IN ONE B. ARE THEY GOING
TO GET AN APPOINTMENT OR
THEY'RE GOING TO GET TOLD NO
YOU'RE COUNTY DOESN'T ALLOW
YOU. TO MOVE INTO THOSE ONE B.
UNIFORM ACROSS THE STATE OR NOT.
IT'S GOING TO BE UNIFORM AND
THAT AND THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY WE NEEDED TO MOVE
TO MY TURN FOR THE PROBLEMS
THAT THE CHALLENGE THAT YOU'RE
DESCRIBING ABSOLUTELY I WE
AGREE WITH YOU WE NEED TO HAVE
UNIFORMS WE NEED HAVE UNIFORM
STANDARDS. OKAY AND WE'LL COME
BACK TO YOU AND HOLD. YOU
ACCOUNTABLE IF THAT'S NOT THE
CASE. RIGHT. WELL IT'S A IT'S A
WHOLE TEAM IT'S A WHOLE TEAM OF
FOLKS- I DO RUN THE DEPARTMENT
BUT AS AS MENTIONED EARLIER
YOU'LL SEE THAT WE REALLY ALL
HANDS ARE ON DECK ALL ALL THE
IS NOT NOT JUST NOT JUST THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH BUT
WE ALSO HAVE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES- WE HAVE A-
SECRETARY A LOT OF RICHARDSON
AND HER AND HER GROUP SO IT'S
REALLY IT'S A IT'S AN ALL STATE
EFFORT RIGHT WILL COOK WILL
HOLD YOU ALL ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THAT BECAUSE I DO HOPE THIS
CHANGES. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT AS
FOR THE NUMBER SEVEN HI DOCTOR
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS REALLY-
THESE ARE ARE PRETTY PROBABLY
BASIC AND EASIER TO ANSWER SO
THE ALLOCATION OF VACCINES
BECAUSE WE'VE HEARD A LOT ABOUT
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH VACCINES
THAT'S WHAT YOU HEARD BEFORE ON
THIS FIRST PANEL AND- IT'S ALL
ABOUT GETTING MORE VACCINES IS
THAT ALLOCATION- FROM THE FEDS
ARE THEY THE ONES THAT
DETERMINE THE ALLOCATION GIVEN
TO THE STATE OR IS IT UP TO US
TO ASK FOR WHAT WE NEED AND
THEN. IN ORDER THAT FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- I BELIEVE.
IS WHAT THEY ALLOW US AYE I'M
NOT TOO SURE BLOCKER IS ON THE
LINE SHE CAN SHE'SACTUALLY MAY
ACTUALLY KNOW THE EXACT. THE
EXACT DETAILS MAY SEEM IF TO
TRASH I CAN ANSWER THEM. SURE
GOOD AFTERNOON- IN TERMS OF THE
ALLOCATION WHERE WHERE
ALLOCATED FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- WALKING ONCE A WEEK
AND WE TAKE THAT ENTIRE
ALLOCATION AND SPLIT IT UP
ACCORDING TO THE ORMULA FOR
THAT. ARE THE PRIORITY GROUP-
AT THAT TIME. HOW DID THEY
DETERMINE WHAT OUR ALLOCATION
SHOULD BE- WE THEY SHOULD. BE
GIVING US. ACCORDING TO THE
FORMER. THEY THE DOES. THEY
HAVE DOES IS TO GIVE THE
FEDERAL. FOR TO PER. AND THEN
THAT THAT AND THE TURN IS TO
THIS. PER THEIR A- SO WE SHOULD
BE REQUESTING WHAT ARE COUNTIES
NEED IN THERE ARE MAXIMUM
CAPACITY. BECAUSE THAT HELPS US
MEET THAT GOAL OF REPEATEDLY
YOU KNOW GETTING THINGS OUT IN
A RAPID FASHION. AND I'M JUST
KIND OF CURIOUS. WHERE THAT
THAT BOTTLENECK IS. BECAUSE WE
KEEP HEARING WE CAN DO MORE IF
WE JUST HAVE THE VACCINE. I'M
I'M NOT AWARE OF- KIND OF US.
BEING ABLE TO REQUEST A
SPECIFIC AMOUNTS FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND WE I
UNDERSTAND THAT IT TRACKS
PRETTY CLOSELY TO THE
POPULATION OF EACH STATE AFTER-
WHATEVER WEEKLY ALLOCATION AS A
TERMINATION WIDE- AND IS YOU
KNOW GIVEN TO. OUR FEDERAL
ENTITIES AND THEN THE REST PUT
UP AMONGST THE STATE INSTANCE
ON THE OTHER FOOT. SO THAT
WOULD BE ONE SUGGESTION I WOULD
SAY IS THEY REALLY SHOULD BE
TRACKING THAT ARE ALLOCATING IT
MORE BASED ON. OUR ABILITY TO
DELIVER IT- IF WE HAVE THE
DELIVERY CAPABILITY OF EIGHTY
ONE THOUSAND IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY A WEEK. DEPRIVATION
BEGETTING EVERY WEEK NOT NOT
TEN THOUSAND AND IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS SAYING THAT AND I
THINK OUR GOVERNOR NEEDS TO
TALK WITH THE PRESIDENT FIX
THAT. SO BECAUSE THAT WOULD
HELP THAT BOTTLE NECK AND THEN
THAT WOULD NOT WE WOULDN'T HAVE
TO HEAR THAT ANYMORE THAT WE
JUST DON'T HAVE THE VACCINE WE
HAVE THE CAPABILITY TO DELIVER
BUTWE DON'T HAVE THE VACCINE.
SO I CAN MOVE ON TO MY SECOND
QUESTION REALLY QUICK- SO YOU
KNOW YOU GUYS HAVE TALKED
ABOUT. TRYING TO UTILIZE THE
COMMUNITY BASED AGENCIES IS
THAT A STATE AGENCY- STATE
DECISION OR A COUNTY DECISION
ON WHICH AGENCIES GET UTILIZED
AND I WAS AND I SPEAKING
SPECIFICALLY I TALK ABOUT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. THAT HAVE THE
CAPABILITY OF GETTING ALL OF
THEIR TEACHERS PRETTY MUCH
VACCINATED WITHIN TWO DAYS. AND
YET. THAT'S JUST NOT HAPPENING
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO GET
OUR KIDS BACK TO SCHOOL IN
ORDER TO HAVE THE TEACHERS.
HAVE ACCESS TO GETTING
VACCINATED BECAUSE THAT
ALLEVIATE. THAT THAT ONE OF
THOSE ISSUES. COOLEY AND IS
CURRENTLY FOR THE STATE OVER
THE PAST FEW WEEKS. I THINK
IT'S GONNA BE IT'S GONNA BE A
COMBINATION- IT'S OF BOTH
WORKING WITH AGENCIES I HAVE
SAVED STATEWIDE SO FOR THE
SCHOOLS SCHOOLS SCHOOLS AS IT
IS A GOOD EXAMPLE. AND THEN
ASSOCIATIONS THAT REPRESENT
STAKEHOLDERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THAT'S HOW WE'VE BEEN
PRIMARILY. DEALING WITH OUT OF
THIS AT THE STATE LEVEL GETTING
GETTING IN COURT. AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. I WOULD SAY THAT'S WHERE
THE RUBBER REALLY HITS THE
ROAD- IT REALLY YOU REALLY NEED
TO HAVE BOOTS ON THE GROUND TO
REALLY BE ABLE TO BE EFFECTIVE-
ACROSS THE STATE SO YOU HAVE TO
WORK WITH. LOCAL LOCAL-
POLICYMAKERS ELECTED OFFICIALS-
AND GOVERNMENT TO REALLY BE
EFFECTIVE- IF IT CAN'T BE IT
CAN'T BE JUST AT THE STATE AT
THE STATE LEVEL BECAUSE- THAT
THE LOCALS ARE REALLY CLOSE TO
CLOSER TO WHERE EVERYTHING IS
HAPPENING. RIGHT AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT AND THAT'S WHY
I THINK. AS YOU CAN. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER HAD TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER IS AND WE KNOW
OUR OUR COMMUNITY'S BEST. AND
WE REALLY SHOULD BE INVOLVED IN
THE PROCESS OF TRYING TO
DETERMINE HOW THESE THINGS
WORK- BECAUSE WE DO HAVE I
THINK THERE ARE GOOD IDEAS OUT
THERE. TO BE ABLE TO- MAXIMIZE
DISTRIBUTION AND GET IT OUT
BECAUSE THE MOST EQUITABLE
THING TO HAPPEN IS FOR A 100%
OF THE PEOPLE THAT WANT A
VACCINE. TO GET IT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE OTHER
PROFESSION BURKE I WOULD I JUST
HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS ON
AS THE BLUE SHIELD PLAN- IS IT
AND IF YOU WERE LISTENING TO
OUR FIRST PANEL OF BOTH OF OUR
REPRESENTATIVES FROM BOTH
YELLOW COUNTY ANTRIM L. A.
COUNTY DID SHARE THAT THEY
STILL DO NOT UNDERSTAND HOW
THEIR ROLE IS GOING TO CHANGE
WHEN THAT. IS IMPLEMENTED AND-
I THINK THAT CONFUSION AND
FRANKLY I THINK THE MAIN
VARIETY IS CONSISTENT WITH
FEEDBACK I'VE HEARD FROM MY
COUNTY AS WELL ON THURSDAY
AUGUST DOES THAT SURPRISE YOU
THAT THEY'RE STILL NOT SURE
WHAT WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN- AND
B. WHAT IS OUR CMMUNICATION
PLAN TO ENSURE THAT OUR
COUNTIES UNDERSTAND THEIR ROLE
AND THAT WE CAN MAKE A SEAMLESS
TRANSITION AND NOT LOSE. FIVE
NOT LOSE ANY TIME. I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR QUESTION AGAIN THIS IS
MARK AGREED WITH THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY. SO WE ARE
ACTUALLY JUST FINALISING OUR
CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS WITH BLUE
SHIELD AND WORKING OUT SOME OF
THOSE OPERATIONAL DETAILS THAT
WE CRAVE IN THE COUNTIES CREDIT
SO. CLEARLY UNDERSTAND THE
CONFUSION AS WE TRY TO FINALIZE
THOSE DETAILS WE HAVE STARTED A
WEEKLY STEERING COMMITTEE WITH
COUNTY LEADERSHIP WILL MEET ON
A WEEKLY BASIS ON TICKETS FOR
ALL THE VARIOUS QUESTIONS. IN
ADDITION WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
VERY METHODICAL APPROACH TO
ONBOARDING COUNTIES IN THREE
DISTINCT WAVES AND MEETING
DIRECTLY WITH THE COUNTY PUBLIC
HEALTH LEADERSHIP. I'M
QUESTIONS GETTING ADVICE ON
NETWORK CONSTRUCTION PROCESS
INTEGRATION WITH MY TURN AND
ALL OF THE VARIOUS DETAILS THAT
NEED TO BE WORKED. OUT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE TRANSITION IS NOT.
GOT IT AND- I WILL SAY WE'VE
ALSO AND IN A THINK THAT THE
SUBJECT IS EVEN COME UP HERE-
WE'VE HEARD FROM A LOT. OF
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS AND
ESCAPE SEES WHO REALLY DO PLAY
AN IMPORTANT ROLE AS TRUSTED
PROVIDERS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND- OUR PLAY A PARTICULARLY
CRITICAL ROLE FOR COMMUNITIES
WHERE THAT ARE HARDEST TO REACH
AND ASMARA'S. VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. THEY ARE REALLY
WORRIED THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
KIND OF GET LEFT IN THE DUST-
AS AS WE MAKE THIS TRANSITION I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THAT'S YOUR
INTENTION. TO CAN YOU SPEAK TO
WHAT WE ARE DOING TO. ENSURE
THAT THEY REMAIN IN THE
DISTRIBUTION NETWORK.
ABSOLUTELY FEDERALLY QUALIFIED
HEALTH CENTERS COMMUNITY CLINIC
THE VERY IMPORTANT PARTS OF THE
DELIVERY SYSTEM SO WE'RE GONNA
BE WORKING INDIVIDUALLY IN EACH
COUNTY. TO ON BOARD THOSE THAT
CAN INTEGRATE WITH OUR SYSTEM
AND PROVIDE RESOURCES TO HELP
THEM GET ON BOARD. OKAY AND
WHEN SHOULD WE EXPECT THIS TO
BE HAPPENING SO I KNOW YOU SAID
THE FIND THE CONTRACT GONNA GET
FINALIZED ON FEBRUARY
FIFTEENTH. FIVE FIFTEEN AND
THEN WHAT WHAT HAPPENS FROM
THERE WHETHER IT'S THE
MILESTONES THAT WE CAN-
APPOINT. POINT ARE COUNTIES TWO
AND POINT HER COLLEAGUES TO IN
TERMS OF THAT RAMP UP STRATEGY.
CERTAINLY SO THERE'S GONNA BE
THREE WAVES THEY'RE GOING TO BE
ABOUT TWO WEEKS EACH THEY'RE
GONNA START NEXT WEEK WHEN WE
FINALIZE THE CONTRACT WE HAVE A
LIST OF COUNTIES WHICH WE CAN.
PROVIDE IN A TENTATIVE FORM OF
WHICH COUNTIES WILL BE WAKING
pTHINKING ABOUT THE COUNTY- TO
BRING ON FIRST WE REALLY LOOKED
CLOSELY AT THOSE THAT HAVE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACTS OF
COVERED NINETEEN. AND BRINGING
THEM ONLINE TO GET- VACCINES
DELIVERED EQUITABLY FASTER. AND
SO OVER A TWO WEEK PERIOD-
ONBOARD THE FIRST WAVE AND THEN
WE WILL GO TO THE SECOND WAVE
AND THEN TO THE THIRD WAVE. SO
THAT BY THE MIDDLE TO END OF
MARCH ALL FIFTY AND WILL BE
ABLE. GRABS GREAT THAT'S
HELPFUL I'M AND- A- QUESTION
RELATED ALSO TO THE COUNTIES
BUT- SPECIFIC SPECIFICALLY TO
MY TURN I THINK WITH WITH WITH
MY TURN AND I THINK WITH
THINGS- BUT THIS TRANSITION
MORE BROADLY. FOR COUNTIES THAT
ARE BEING SUCCESSFUL THERE IS A
CONCERN THAT WE'RE GONNA KIND
OF THREW THE BABY OUT WITH THE
BATHWATER. AND RATHER THAN
BUILD ON THEIR SUCCESS KIND OF
START FROM SCRATCH. AGAIN HOW
ARE WE GOING TO ENSURE THAT.
THAT DOES NOT HAPPEN. SO GONNA
WORK WITH OKAY PARTNER TO
INTEGRATE THEM INTO THE STATE
WIDE DATA SYSTEM. I WILL ADMIT
I AM NOT THE EXPERT MY TURNED
ITSELF WE WANT TO DELIVER THE
DETAILS OF HOW THE SYSTEM WORKS
I REMEMBER CALLING TO GET UP.
BUT WE WILL WE WILL BE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS TO BUILD ON THEIR
SUCCESSES BUT WE- DO WANT TO BE
CLEAR WE DO NEED TO INTEGRATE
ALL OF THE DATA SYSTEMS INTO A
SINGLE DATE. STATE STATEWIDE
DATA STREAM SO WE CAN HAVE THAT
LEVEL OF TRANSPARENCY. AGAINST
OUR SUCCESS AND DELIVERING
VACCINES SO THAT WE FEEL GOOD
ABOUT IT YOU FEEL GOOD ABOUT IT
THE PUBLIC CAN SEE WHERE
VACCINES ARE FROM THE MOMENT
THEY HAD TO THE STATE UNTIL THE
MOMENT THEY ENTERED SOMEBODY'S
CAR. WE KNOW. EXACTLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE TAX. GREAT AND
I DO I DO THINK THAT THAT MAKES
EMINENT SENSE- I CERTAINLY WANT
TO BE FOCUSED. LOOKING FORWARD
AND FOCUSED ON SOLUTIONS- I
THINK IT REALLY REALLY WOULD'VE
BEEN. INCREDIBLY HELPFUL IF WE-
HAD. THOUGHT THROUGH THE FACT
THAT WE WERE GOING TO NEED THIS
STATE WIDE. DATA SYSTEM. BACK
IN AUGUST SO THAT WE COULD
HAVE. BEEN DOING THIS WORK. AND
ONBOARDING COUNTIES AS WE WERE
BEGINNING TO START ROLLING OUT
THE VACCINE. MANY COUNTIES
INCLUDING MINE OF INVESTED
TREMENDOUS TIME. EFFORT AND
RESOURCES. IN CREATING THEIR
OWN DATA SYSTEM FROM SCRATCH
BECAUSE THEY WERE. THEY WERE
TOLD. THAT WE WERE NOT GOING TO
PURSUE A STATEWIDE SOLUTION.
I'M SO I THINK THAT'S
CERTAINLY. A LEARNING. THAT- I
THINK COULD BE TAKEN. FOR NEXT
TIME. AT WITH THAT ABBASI O
FURTHER NUMBER QUESTIONS I
BELIEVE WE'RE READY TO WORK ALL
TRANSITION TO MY COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ THANK
YOU JUST A NUMBER PRETTY MUCH
COMING TOWARDS AND THE TIME
BUDGET AFTER A COUPLE QUESTIONS
JUST WANT TO TALK TO KIND OF
BACK TO THE T. PAY WITH BLUE
SHIELD I KNOW I THINK WE'RE
LOOKING AT FINALISING NOT BY
THIS FRIDAY IS THAT CORRECT. IS
THERE A TIME PHARMATECH THE
CONTRACT WITH THE BANK SHOWED.
ME THAT CONTRACT WILL BE
FINALIZED BY THE FIFTEENTH.
OKAY REQUEST REGARDING THAT ON
A VERY GOOD ANSWER ON THE TOP
OF IT IN MY OPENING REMARKS
PARTNERSHIPS AND I THINK-
DOCTOR ARE GOING YOU TALKED
ABOUT YOU KNOW BEING INCLUSIVE
AND HEARING EVERYBODY'S-
IMPORTANT HOW WEAK AND- HELP.
DISTRIBUTE THE VACCINE IN THE
PROCESS OF DOING THAT. SO IS
THERE ANY THOUGHTS TO WORKING
MORE WITH OUR FIRE SERVICE OR
EMS PROVIDERS ESPECIALLY IN OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. AND IF SO IS
THERE A AVENUE FOR THEM TO BE
REIMBURSED FOR THEIR SERVICES.
THAT THAT'S A REALLY GOOD
QUESTION AND I THINK- I THINK
IT'S GONNA DEPEND I THINK
THEY'RE PROBABLY GONNA HAVE TO.
WORK AS A AS A PROVIDER IN THE
WEIGHT OF THE WEIGHT MARTIN
GREEN JUST DESCRIBED IT- I'M
NOT SURE HOW THAT'S GOING TO
WORK ONCE BLUESHIELD THAT ONE
CITY PA IS UP AND RUNNING. BUT
I'M SURE I'M SURE AS WE GET
LOTS OF VACCINES AND THEY IF
THEY QUALIFY THEY'RE ABLE TO I
DON'T SEE WHY NOT BUT THAT'S I
CAN'T I CAN'T ANSWER THAT
SPECIFICALLY IT AT THIS POINT.
OKAY IN ANOTHER ONE REGARDING
THE BLUE SHIELD- HOPEFULLY
SOMEONE HAVE A QUICK ANSWER TO
THIS AND DOES ANYBODY KNOW. HOW
LONG IT WOULD TAKE BROUGH
SHOWED A DEMO FAR. PROVIDERS
THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
VACCINATE FOLKS BECAUSE I YOU
KNOW THE STATE DOING RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE FOLKS WHO NORMALLY
DON'T- GIVE ACTIONS ARE DOING
IT JUST TO. HELP OUT- GET MORE
FOLKS VACCINATED- SO IS THERE A
PLAN IN PLACE BECAUSE AS MORE.
FACTIONS STARTED COME AVAILABLE
WE'RE GONNA NEED FOLKS MORE
FOLKS OUT THERE SO THEIR TIME
FRAME. THAT WE KNOW BLUE SHIELD
WILL HAVE. A DINNER PARTY FOLKS
TO WILL BE. ABLE TO HELP
DISTRIBUTIVE ACTION. YES I'LL
JUST .COM I'LL JUST REPEAT WHAT
MY COLLEAGUE. MS GREEN. ARE
LAID OUT SO. THAT WE WILL.
BLUESHIELD WILL START THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE COUNTY
NEXT WEEK AND WILL BE FINISHED
BY MID MARCH IN TERMS OF
IDENTIFYING. THE PROVIDERS-
THAT CAN BE IN THE NETWORK.
OKAY- JUST SO YOU KNOW JUST A
QUICK QUESTION WHAT CRITERIA
WERE USED TO EVALUATE WHETHER
PROVIDERS APPROVED TO BE IN THE
NETWORK. ALL I SO WE'RE STILL
FINALIZING THE CONTRACT WITH
THE CRITERIA THAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING AT THIS TIME IS
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE WELL
POSITIONED TO BE DIRECTLY
PEOPLE'S. WHETHER THEY CAN MEET
OUR DATA INTEGRATION GOALS. AND
HOW THE PERFORMED AGAINST BOTH
ADVOCACY AND SPEED AND-
OFFICIALS SIX. CAN GET AND SO
THERE'S A KIND OF THAT THE
TEARS BUT EQUITY BEING
NORTHSTAR. IN JUST A THREE ONE
NINE DEPARTING I GUESS MY FOR
PARTING THOUGHTS BEFORE
TRANSITION TO PUBLIC COMMENT
AND I. WANT TO THANK ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS FOR JOINING US TODAY
AND- FOR EVERYTHING THAT YOU
HAVE DONE AND ARE DOING RIGHT
NOW TO HELP OUR STATE. NAVIGATE
THIS THIS UNPRECEDENTED PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS AND TO DEFEAT
THIS PANDEMIC SO THAT WE CAN.
GET TO WORK REBUILDING
CALIFORNIA WE ARE WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL TO YOU IN YOUR TEENS-
IF I COULD LEAVE YOU I GUESS
WITH. THEY MIGHT THREE BIG
PICTURE REQUESTS AND I FIGURED
SOME OF THESE AS WE WENT BUT I
THINK NUMBER ONE REALLY IS.
SETTING CLEAR AND ACHIEVABLE
GOALS- FOR THE PUBLIC AND- AT
FOR OUR PARTNERS- NUMBER TWO IS
LET'S NOT CHANGE THE CRITERIA
AND LET'S NOT CHANGE THE PLAN
UNLESS THERE'S A REALLY REALLY
COMPELLING REASON TO DO SO.
BECAUSE CHANGE CREATES
CONFUSION AND IT IT IT MAKES IT
SEEM LIKE. WE'RE NOT MAKING
GRANTED DECISIONS AND THEN
THIRD I WOULD I WOULD REQUEST
IMPROVE COMMUNICATION WITH OUR
COUNTIES AND WITH OTHER
PARTNERS I KNOW THAT THINGS ARE
MOVING INCREDIBLY FAST- BUT WE
GOTTA BRING THEM ALONG ALONG
WITH US. SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE
THAT WE DELIVER A SHARED
SUCCESS FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA- AND WITH THAT WE'LL
MOVED PUBLIC COMMENTAND
TEACHER RECORDS. IN WITH THAT
ALSO JUST WANT TO SHARE. THE
SAME CONCERNS AND ISSUES THAT
ARE- MY CULTURE HERE SHE TALKED
ABOUT RICK- THE BACK. ARE
THINK- A LOT AND CLEAR THE
MESSAGE FROM A LOT OF OUR
MEMBERS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT. MOVING FORWARD THERE WERE
ALL EQUALLY- COMMUNICATOR WITH
AN ADDRESSING THE ISSUES THAT
WE'RE ALL FACING OUR
COMMUNITIES. OF ISSUE A LOT OF
TALK ABOUT REGARDING EQUITY AND
ACCESSIBILITY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE ESPECIALLY ON OUR HARDEST
HIT COMMUNITIES SO. JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT- THE POINT IS
WELL TAKEN BY EVERYONE- THAT
PARTICIPATED. HERE TODAY AND
WANT TO THANK YOU ALSO FOR
PUTTING. TIME ASIDE TO TALK
ABOUT THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
YOU'RE FACING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN THIS NATION AND
THE WORLD FOR THAT MATTER SO
THAT WE'LL GO AHEAD AND GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. BUT BEFORE
START THAT I'LL HAVE THE BRIEF
STATEMENT TO SAY. SO WE'RE
GOING TO START PUBLIC COMMENT
BY THOSE IN THE ROOM AND THOSE.
WHO ARE CALL AND THE PHONE
NUMBER IS. 900-187-7692 EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE CODE
IS TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN. ON BUDGET A CALL IN NOW
IS EXPLAINING THE RULES FOR
TODAY'S PUBLIC COMMENT.
ASSEMBLY HAS LIMITS ON THE TIME
PLACE AND MANNER HOW IT
RECEIVES PUBLIC COMMENT. IN THE
FACT THAT CALIFORNIA.
CONSTITUTION REQUIRES US TO SET
RULES. FOR HOW WE RUN OUR
PROCEEDINGS. THIS IS THE TIME
AND PLACE FOR YOU TO COMMENT ON
TODAY'S TOPIC OF COVERT
NINETEEN FACTION DISTRIBUTION.
AND ONLY TODAY'S TOPIC. WE WILL
NOT ACCEPT DESTRUCTIVE BEHAVIOR
OR BEHAVIOR THAT INSIDER TRENDS
VIOLENCE. EVEN VILE THREATS
TODAY'S TOPIC OF VACCINES HAS
ATTRACTED GREAT ATTENTION AND
LEAD TO DESTRUCTION FOR THE
LAST FOUR YEARS. IN TWENTY
NINETEEN ANTI VACCINE
PROTESTERS CALL SISTER
DISTURBANCE THAT THE SOMEBODY
HAD RECESSED THE SESSION'S
FINAL DAYS. THERE WERE
PROTESTING INACTION BILL THAT
THE GOVERNOR HAD ALREADY SIGNED.
LAST YEAR THE MISSILE COVE IN
NINETEEN PANDEMIC THE ANTI
DOCTOR PROTESTS HAVE APPEARED
AT THE CAPITOL AND ON SEVERAL
OCCASIONS. THIS YEAR BACK IN
SACRAMENTO ANTI VACCINE
PROTESTERS HAVE APPEARED AT
LEGISLATIVE HEARINGS REMOVING
THEIR MASKS YELLING FROM THE
AUDIENCE. AND ISSUING VEILED
THREATS ABOUT THE USE OF GUNS
THE SENATE CLOSER TO GALLERY
THE NEXT DAY. TO MAINTAIN ORDER
IN TODAY'S HEARINGS WILL
STRICTLY ENFORCE THESE RULES TO
THE TIMELINE LOOKS WILL BE
LIMITED PUBLIC COMMENT TO TEN
INDIVIDUALS ON THE PHONE AND
TEN INDIVIDUALS AND ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER. TO ONE MINUTE PIECE.
IF YOU DO NOT HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR WRITTEN COMMENTS TO MY
COMMITTEES EMAIL AT. ASM DOT
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT
GOV PUBLIC COMMENTS CAN RELATE
ONLY TO THE TOPIC OF TODAY'S
HEARING. KOVIN NOT NINETEEN
VACCINE DISTRIBUTION. IF YOU
ARE HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
YOU MUSTKEEP YOUR MASK OVER
YOUR NOSE AND MOUTH AT ALL
TIMES EVEN WHEN YOU OFFER YOUR
COMMENTS. WE WILL NOT ALLOW
BUILT THREATS OF REFERENCES TO
GUNS OR VIOLENCE. THE LAST TWO
POINTS MASK THE BILL THREATS
YOUR NOT GET ANOTHER WARNING
YOUR COMMENT WILL BE CUT SHORT
AND YOU'RE MOVED FROM
DISCONNECTION FROM THE
FOLLOWING SO WITH THAT LET'S
GET STARTED AND WE'LL START
WITH FOLKS ON THE PHONE. OR
OPERATOR DO YOU HAVE SOMEBODY
ON THE PHONE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
CAROLINA. YOU'LL BE CALLED ON
BY YOUR LINE NUMBER WHEN IT'S
YOUR TURN. IF YOU'RE USING A
SPEAKER PHONE PLEASE PICK UP
THE HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING THE
NUMBERS. ONCE AGAIN THE COMMAND
TO MAKE A COMMENT. IT'S ONE
ZERO AND OUR FIRST COMMENT
COMES LINE. TEAM PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS SHEILA
GUNN CUSHMAN AND I LIVE IN
OAKLAND. I'M FORTY NINE YEARS
OLD I HAVE MULTIPLE CHRONIC
CONDITIONS ASTHMA AND DIABETES
BEING THE ONES THAT ARE OF
CONCERN HERE- I WANT MY VACCINE
VERY MUCH BUT NINE MCCARTY
MEMBER AND THEY ARE ONLY DOING.
SEVENTY FIVE YEARS NOT I LIVE
IN ALAMEDA COUNTY- WHICH IS AN
OBVIOUS STATEMENT YOU KNOW OUR
OPENNESS BUT I'M JUST FOR THE
RECORD. I LIVE IN NINE FOUR SIX
OH ONE ZIP CODE WHICH IS ONE OF
THE WORST IN ALAMEDA COUNTY AND
ONE OF THE TWO WORST IN OAKLAND.
ALAMEDA COUNTY IS A- CONTINUAL
OF HAVES AND HAVE NOTS. AND MY
INCOME IS ROUGHLY A THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH. I AM A MEMBER
OF HAND IN HAND WHICH IS A
DOMESTIC EMPLOYERS ORGANIZATION
AND I EMPLOYEE ONE I. HFS
WORKER. I HAVE A LOT OF FRIENDS
WHO ARE GOING MORE THAN THAT
THE WORKERS COME IN AND OUT OF
OUR HOUSE THEY ARE ALREADY
BEING VACCINATED MINE DOESN'T
WANT THE VACCINE. SHE IS A
PERSON OF COLOR WHO LIVES WITH
TWO FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ALSO AND
HER LEAVE HER HOUSE AND SHE
WORKS WITH OTHER CLIENTS OKAY
MEMBER ALMOST TEN TIMES ALMOST
UP YOU HAVE A THE QUICKER. IN
WE CAN ON O THE NEXT CALLER.
AS WE NEED OUR VACCINES THREE
WEEKS AGO AND IT IS
DISAPPOINTING TO ME THAT ONLY
THREE TIMES IN THIS WHOLE
HEARING WHICH OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WRONG WHO'S NEXT. BUT
OUR NEXT COMMENT COMES FROM THE
LINE THIRTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MICHELLE GIVEN THAT
THE COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVE
DISSIPATION OF CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING THE LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE I THANK YOU FOR HOLDING
THIS IMPORTANT HEARING TODAY
FOR THE THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSION
AND FOR INCLUDING A LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT PERSPECTIVE.
OF THE HEALTH DEPARTMENT'S ROSE
TO THE CHALLENGE TO ADMINISTER
VACCINES QUICKLY AND ARE DOING
SO IN EQUITY IN MINE WE DON'T
LOCAL VACCINATION SITE PARTNER
WITH PROVIDERS THROUGHOUT THE
COMMUNITY MANY THAT SERVE THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE CRITICAL
TO THE STATE HELP TO THE STATE
EQUITY FALLS. AND CONTINUE TO
EXPLORE AND LAUNCH NEW STRATEGY
TO REACH VULNERABLE COMMUNITY.
HEALTH DEPARTMENT CAN DO EVEN
MORE BUT ARE LIMITED B THEIR
SUPPLY AND ONE INCH INSURE OUR
EFFORTS ARE ONLY ENHANCE AND
NOT LOADER HINDERED BY THE
ADDITION OF THE TVA. WE
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
INTENT TO WORK WITH LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO MORE DETAIL ON WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE AND WANT TO
REITERATE THE FOLLOWING WEEK.
FIRST TO THE PARK EQUITY BY
INCLUDING THE EXISTING PROVIDER
NETWORK BUILT BY LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS INTO THE TV
NETWORK. DENTURE ALLOCATIONS
ARE DONE WITH LOCAL HEALTH-DEPARTMENT AND PLAN FOR THE
NATIONALLY AND ONGOING IF YOU
CAN'T CAN'T TELL YOU WHAT OUR
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT CAN
ABOUT THE PROVIDERS AND WHAT
THEY BRING TO THE VACCINATION
STRATEGY IN EQUITY EFFORT. AND
FINALLY ENSURE THAT DATA IS
ACCURATE AND THEN TRANSPARENT
WE CANNOT GUARANTEE EQUITY
WITHOUT KNOWING HOW MACINNES
BEING OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR A TIME AYE PERFECT. I'M
GOING THE NEXT CALLER. IN NEXT.
COMES A LINE. FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO YES YOU HAVE ONE
MINUTE YOU'RE ON. YEAH BUT I
HAVE A QUESTION WHAT KIND OF
IGNORANT IDIOTIC HUMAN BEINGS
ARE IN THE EMERGENCY COMMENTING
SAYING. THAT INJECTING A
COCKTAIL OF SYNTHETIC TOXIC
MATERIALS FROM ALL TOWN. TAGS
ALONE HI THIS ANAPHYLAXIS. ALL
OF THOSE WHO DIED IN BY JANUARY
TWENTY NINE OLD FIVE HUNDRED
AND ONE OF THEM. WHAT COULD YOU
TELL THEM. WHAT YOUR SKILL
PROMOTE FAIR TRADE BACK SAYING.
THEY COULD NOT OF ACTING OKAY
THANKS VERY MUCH COMMON
KNOWLEDGE NUMBER IS ONE DOLLAR.
IN OUR NEXT COMMENT COMES FROM
LINE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU TEARS BETWEEN NORTH
AND RODRIGUEZ THIS IS MITCH
SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION PREEMPTIVELY
TO TESTIFY TODAY AND THAT WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE GREAT WORK
OF STATE LOCAL AGENCIES IN
TACKLING THIS MAJOR WITH
LOGISTICAL CHALLENGE GOT A
WHOLE LOT ABOUT ACTING
DISTRIBUTION BUT WE'LL JUST
FOCUS ON THE MOST PRESSING
CONCERN WHICH IS THE- CURRENT
PLAN TO FURTHER DE PRIORITISE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS THAT WAS
ANNOUNCED ABOUT A WEEK AGO.
WHERE WORKERS WHO ARE IN TIER
ONE A OR EXCUSE ME TWO ONE A
PHASE ONE B. WILL BE MOVED TO
THE BACK OF THE LINE WE THINK
THIS IS REALLY UNFAIR AND
UNWISE PROPRIETY OF REASONS
BUT- THE MAIN WAY THAT WE THINK
IT'S UNFAIR IS THAT. IT'S
IMPORTANT TO CONSIDER THAT
THESE WORKERS ARE BY DEFINITION
UNABLE TO ISOLATE OR HIDE FROM
THE VIRUS OR QUARANTINE AND IN
MANY CASES HAVE TO DEAL WITH
HUNDREDS IF NOT THOUSANDS OF
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC OVER THE
COURSE OF THE DAY. AND THAT
INABILITY TO ISOLATE AND
MINIMIZE THEIR OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH RETURNS ON. THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AN OUR NEXT
COMMENT COMES FROM THE LINE
FIFTY THREE. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THE MEMBER SERVICE ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS
HOPE YOU'RE DISTRICTS OPERATE
HOSPITAL CLINIC FEEL NURSING
FACILITIES AND PROVIDE A
VARIETY OF COMMUNITY HEALTH
SERVICES. HAVE BEEN ESSENTIAL
TO A COMMUNITY RESPONSE THE
COMBINATION IN THE BACK RIGHT
COULD BE CAJUN BY DIFFERENT
SERVICES INCLUDING TO RESPOND
FOR. OKAY DISTRICT ARE FULLY
ENGAGED IN NUCLEAR SITUATED
HELD BACK THEIR COMMUNITIES SO
FAR HEALTHCARE DISTRICT ALL
TYPES OF CIRCUIT COURT HEARS
FACT METER AND PROVIDE CRITICAL
BACKING INFORMATION EDUCATION
IN OUR COMMUNITY. DISTRICT HAVE
BEEN RECOGNIZED FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS FOR
EXAMPLE THE OTHER HEALTHCARE
DISTRICT IN THE COACHELLA
VALLEY HAS DELIVERED OVER
TWELVE HUNDRED KOPEN NINETEEN
BACK THE NATION'S TO FARM
WORKERS. MOVEMENT ON A
COMMUNITY HEALTH CARE DISTRICT
IN CONTRA COSTA AND CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY PARTNERED WITH
KAISER TO CONTINUE THEIR
EDUCATION OUTREACH AFRICAN
AMERICAN AND BLACK COMMUNITIES
REGARDING BACKSEAT. DISTRICT
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXCEL AT THEIR MOST ESSENTIAL
FUNCTION BUT THE COMPANY AND
DEMOCRATS BONTA MAC NATION
EFFORTS HAVE NOT CONTINUE TO
PREVENT YOU I'M NOT ABOUT THAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF TIMES
OKAY. THE NEXT. CALLER AND OUR
NEXT COMMENT COMES THE LINE
TWENTY SIX. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NUMBER
THERE ON THE PAINTING ON BEHALF
HEALTH STATE OF COUNTIES THANK
YOU FOR THE SUPPORT OF THE
HEARING. COUNTIES AS HEARD ARE
AT THE READY TO DESTROY AND
MANY THESE CALL. WE UNDER THE A-
PROPOSAL FOR THE PARTY THAT
COUNTY. ARE NOT JUST ANOTHER
FOR. WE ALSO WARMLY WELCOMED
DATA EFFICIENCIES AND OUT ONE
OF NOTE THAT CURRENT DATA IS
INCOMPLETE AND ENCOMPASSES
INACCURATE. SO WE ADOPTION ANY
DECISIONS MAJOR DECISIONS BEING
MADE UPDATE ON THE CURRENT
INACCURATE DATA THINK ****
LASTLY OUR MAIN CONCERN IS
ABOUT A VACCINE ALLOCATION WELL
WE ARE IN A- ELEMENT OF. CITY
IN FACT THESE OVERALL- COUNTY
SHOULD BE AT THE FOREFRONT OF
REMIGES. OPERATOR THE NEXT
CALLER. IN ORDER COMMON COMES
FROM LAW. WELL WE'VE AHEAD. YES
MY NAME IS EIGHTEEN BY LIFE- IN
A BACKROOM AND I AM DEEPLY. BY
THE THREE HOURS THAT I JUST AND
LISTENING TO ALL OF YOU MEMBERS
GOT. I MONEY FIRST AND FOREMOST
THIS IS NOT A VACCINATION THIS
IS N. AND M. R. N. EIGHT
EXPERIMENTS AND THROW OUT ALL
OF THE DAY. I ALL AID IS A
LOGISTICS A LOGISTICAL ISSUE
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT BRINGING
IN A THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR
TO STOCK UP FINE YOU ASK ANY
MEDICAL PROVIDER THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATORS ARE A NIGHTMARE
COME TRUE WITH PCPS PHARMACY
CLINIC AND READILY AVAILABLE
INFORMATION FOR ELECTRONIC
MEDICAL RECORD. ESPECIALLY
THROUGH THE COVER. CALIFORNIA
PLANS. OVER THE NEXT CALLER.
AND ARE NOW COMMA COMES FROM
THE LINE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THANK YOU MEMBERS
OF THE BAND AS A WITH AT THE
ARE YOU CALIFORNIA FIRST DIBS
ECHO- THE COMMENTS MADE BY
MISTAKE EARLIER ABOUT THE NEED
TO INCLUDE ESSENTIAL WORKERS
INTO THE PRIORITY PATIENT THAT-
THERE CAN BE NO CONVERSATION
ABOUT EQUITY WITHOUT INCLUDING-
OCCUPATIONAL EXPOSURE AND
ESSENTIAL WORKERS MUST BE
PRIORITIZED. SECOND POINT I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO QUICKLY MAKE
IT IS THAT THE VACCINE ROLL
ROLL OUT HAVE BEEN PARTIALLY
HINDERED BY THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE UNDER INVESTED OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM FOR YEARS
AND WE MUST CONTINUE GOING
ABOUT. PUBLIC HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM JUST REPAIR FOR HER
DEFEAT- WE BIRDS STATE TO.
ENSURE THAT FEDERAL WORKERS ARE
LEFT BEHIND DIDN'T COORDINATE
WITH MORE- UNIONS INSURE THAT
THOSE WORKERS GET- THAT AFTER
SOME BACKING THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU OPERATOR THE NEXT
COURT. AND COMMENT COMES FROM
LINE TWENTY PLEASE GO. HI AT MY
NAME IS ROCHELLE. AND I
REPRESENT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA I CAN ALSO SAY THAT
I AM DISGUSTED WITH ME HE IS
THE RANKING ON A VIEWER
EVERYBODY'S INABILITY TO EVEN
KNOW WHERE BACK EITHER WAY. AND
BY THE WAY THE POPULATION HAS
BEEN WORKING VALUES FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION AND IT DOESN'T GO
TO BAKERSFIELD YOU GUYS ARE
TALKING ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT
PEOPLE OVER SIXTY FIVE GET
INJECTED THEY ARE THE ONES THAT
ARE GOING TO BE TAKEN OUT BURKE
MOST OF THE PEOPLE OVER SIXTY
FIVE HAD MULTIPLE UNDERLYING
CONDITIONS. ON THE VACCINE
INSERT THEY STATE IF YOU HAVE
ANY UNDERLYING CONDITIONS YOUR
IF YOU'RE AT A HEALTH RISK TO
BE INJECTED. YOU GUYS AREN'T
EVEN PAYING ATTENTION TO WHAT
YOU'RE DOING YOU'RE TAKING
MONEY SPENDING IT AND NOBODY
KNOWS WHERE IT'S GOING YOU GUYS
SHOULD BE EMBARRASSED OF
YOURSELVES YOU'RE NOT. YOU'RE
NOT HELPING ANYBODY CAN OPERATE
COLOR NUMBER FOR COMMON THIS
WILL BE OUR LAST PUBLIC COMMENT
FOR VIA PHONE. OPERATOR SO DO
THE LAST ONE WE'RE GOOD. AND
ALLOW COMMON COMES FROM LAW.
FIFTY EIGHT PEOPLE AT. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS GONNA
ABOUT THIS AND THE INITIATIVE
DIRECTOR AT MEDIUM COLOR OUR
MISSION IS TO SUPPORT ELEVATE
THE VALUE OF COMMUNITY MEDIA AT
THE TIME- WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT COMMUNITY AND I THINK
MEDIA OPERATE- IN CONJUNCTION
AND COLLABORATION WITH THE
STATE TO ENSURE THAT ATTRACTED
MESSENGERS HOW. WE CAN PROVIDE
ACCURATE INFORMATION TO
COMMUNITIES WHO NEEDED THEM OUT.
AND FELLOW- WE FEED INTO THE
NECK WITH ISSUE WE NEED TO THAT
ALL ESPECIALLY THOSE MOST ARE
EVEN IF THE READER TO CONSIDER-
MEDIA OUTLET AND YOU WERE OUT
AND OFFERING HER. WE LOOK TO
COLLABORATING THANK YOU. OKAY
THANKS VERY OPERATOR THAT. ARE
CALLING. FOR PUBLIC THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WHAT DOES SAID WILL
ON MY- ANYWAY ONE MEMBERS HERE
IN THE GALLERY. WHO A COMMON.
REMEMBER ONLY HAVE ONE MINUTE.
AND WE'LL START WITH- WE ONLY A-
TEN. TIME FOR TEN- COMMENTS
WOULD LIKE TO SERVE YOU'RE
READY OUR GOAL AROUND- A
HOSTILE GROUP. TODAY GLAD TO
HEAR SOME OF IT BUT THE PROBLEM
IS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BUDGET
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MONEY WHICH
IS GOING TO BECOME VERY SCARCE.
AND THE PROBLEM I HAVE WITH THE
VACCINE IT IS HOW WE'RE
SPENDING SO MUCH MONEY TO TRY
TO PUSH IT. MISINFORMING PEOPLE
NOT READING ALL INFORMATION BE
OUT THERE AND AVAILABLE ON THIS
ON THE SCHOLARS POINTED OUT.
THE COMPULSION. TO BE
VACCINATED TO HAVE A JOB. OR TO
KEEP A JOB YOU HAVE TO BE
VACCINATED THAT'S FORCED
VACCINATION AND IT'S AGAINST
THE INTERNATIONAL LOS ACTUALLY
CONSIDERED A WAR CRIME. AND WE
SHOULD BE SPENDING ANY MONEY
FOR FORCEDVACCINATION ARE
ENCOURAGING IT WHAT SO EVER.
AND WE SHOULD BE FAIR ENOUGH TO
REALIZE WE SHOULDBE SPENDING
MONEY TO SCARE PEOPLE TO BE
VACCINATED WE JUST NEED TO HAVE
AVAILABLE FOR PEOPLE THAT WANT
TO. AND I TRY TO FORCE IT ON
PEOPLE MAKING IT MORE SCARCE TO
TRY TO USE FEAR MAKING A
VACCINE MORE SCARCE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK VERY MUCH
US OR ANYBODY ELSE.
OKAY GO
HEAD TO FOR MONEY A ONE MINUTE
OKAY SO I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING
THAT HE JUST SAID IT SHOULD NOT
BE MANDATORY THAT'S
UNCONSTITUTIONAL WE DON'T WANT
IT AS A PEOPLE AND ESPECIALLY
TO OUR CHILDREN IF YOU'RE GONNA
TRY TO PUT THAT ON OUR CHILDREN
GO TO SCHOOL THEM UNDER THE
BACK SEAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE OVER
EIGHTEEN YEARS YOU HAVE TO BE
EIGHTEEN OR OVER TO GET. AND
THE BY THE ONE YOU HAVE TO BE
SIXTEEN OR OVER TO GET SO
PLEASE I MEAN WHAT ARE WE
THINKING FOR THE STUDENTS AND
KIDS GOING BACK TO SCHOOL YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT WHAT MAXINE
ARE THEY GOING TO GET. OR ARE
YOU GOING TO TRY TO. FORCE ON
THEM WHICH SHE BETTER NOT. OKAY
THANK YOU USER ANYONE ELSE.
OKAY GOOD GOVERNMENT. THE COSBY
NINETEEN VACCINE CAN EVEN CALL
IT A VACCINE IT'S NEW I AM NOT
M. ARE ANY TECHNOLOGY THAT HAS
NEVER BEFORE BEEN USING HUMANS
WHAT COULD GO WRONG GRANTED
EMERGENCY USE AUTHORIZATION
THIS IS CONSIDERED EXPERIMENTAL
ALTHOUGH FROM ONE TWENTY NINE
THIS YEAR. FIVE HUNDRED ONE
DEATHS HAVE BEEN REPORTED TO
THE BEARS. I THINK THREE CDC.
THAT'S ONE IN SEVENTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE TO THEIR THAT DO THEIR
LIVES MATTER. THERE'S NUMBERS
ARE UNDER REPORTED FACT THAT
INJURY IS NOT RARE THAT. THE
VACCINE MANUFACTURERS ARE
EXEMPT FROM LIABILITY FACT YOUR
MANDATE AND NOW THAT YOU WILL
YOU'LL FIND WAYS TO POOREST
PEOPLE BY TAKING AWAY THE RIGHT
TO WORK TO GO TO SCHOOL OR
TRAVEL. WHAT IS THE POINT IT
DOESN'T PREVENT TRANSMISSION WE
STILL HAVE TO MASK UP AND
FILLED WITH NEVER GONNA GET
BACK TO NORMAL. OKAY THANK OUR
MAJOR TIME IS UP IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE. AND JUST REMINDER
CAN YOU PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
FOR THE RECORD THANK YOU. YES
MY NAME IS SHANNON WYLER HELLO
AND I IMPLORE EVERYONE IN THE
ROOM TO PUT YOUR PHONE DOWN-
ONE OF THE BIGGEST THINGS AND
THINK YOU MISS KERRY FOR YOUR
ATTENTIVENESS- I MAY NOT AGREE
WITH ALL YOUR VALUES BUT I CAN
SEE YOU'RE ACTUALLY LISTENING.
AND EVERYONE ELSE WHO IS- I'VE
BEEN A PUBLIC SPEAKER FOR
THIRTY YEARS I'M AN EDUCATOR
ONE MINUTE IS SIMPLY. NOT
POSSIBLE TO ACTUALLY PRESENT
MUCH ALTHOUGH I DO COMMEND YOU
ON YOUR WORK. I'M I WILL JUST.
LEAVE YOU WITH THIS QUOTE BY
ABRAHAM LINCOLN. LABOR TO KEEP
ALIVE THAT LITTLE SPARK OF
CELESTIAL FIRE WITHIN YOUR
BREASTS YOUR CONSCIENCE. OKAY
THANKS VERY MUCH OF TIME IS UP
ANYONE NEXT. HELLO MY NAME IS
AUTUMN ANGEL- AND I AM FROM
PLASTER COUNTY. AND I WANT TO
SAY THAT WE IS MEDICAL FREEDOM
ACTIVIST WE'RE NOT FEELING
UNWANTED ANXIETY OR FEAR ABOUT
THE VACCINE AND THOSE WHO
CHOOSE TO RECEIVE IT. DESERVE
THE RIGHT TO INFORMED CONSENT
AND THE RIGHT TO KNOW THAT
THERE ARE RISKS TO TAKING A UN
TESTED NEWLY DEVELOPED VACCINE.
WHERE THERE IS FEAR. WHERE IS
THE FEAR FROM THE FIVE HUNDRED
ONE DEATHS PLUS THE TEN
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED FORTY
OTHER INJURIES. REPORTED FROM
THE CALL THAT VACCINE ALONG
WITH SIX HUNDRED AND NINETY
REPORTED. OF ANAPHYLACTIC
REACTIONS HOW IS THAT AT THE
POOL THE GREATEST FEAR HAS
ALWAYS BEEN THE DEATH. THE
GREATEST FEAR HAS ALWAYS. BEEN
THAT PEOPLE WILL DIE WHO DIDN'T
NEED TO DIE FROM VACCINES DR
PAN. AND WHO IS GOING TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE VACCINE
INJURY THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
OKAY THING REMOTE FOR COMMENT
IS THERE ANYONE NEXT.
MY NAME
IS ANDREA HAD STRONG. I'M FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY. AND I AM
VACCINE INJURED I HEPATITIS B.
VACCINE NEARLY KILLED ME TWENTY
YEARS AGO. I HAVE BEEN IN THIS
BUILDING A HUNDRED TIMES I HAVE
BEEN LABELED A TERRORIST. AND
WHERE THERE IS A RISK THERE
MUST BE CHOICE. AND TO QUOTE ST
AUGUSTINE OF HIPPO TRUTH IS A
LIKE A LION YOU DON'T NEED TO
DEFEND IT YOU'RE REALLY SETS
AND- WELL DEFEND ITSELF. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. BORN ONCE POINT
TWICE I DON'T THINK THERE'S
NOBODY ELSE THERE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. WITHOUT THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PUBLIC
COMMENTS AND I THINK WITHOUT
SAID. AS CHAIR EARTH CULTURE I
THINK WE'RE DONE THIS MANY COME
TO THEM THANK YOU ALL FOR
PARTICIPATING THANK YOU AND
THANKS FOR EVERYBODY
PARTICIPATING TODAY. THIS MAN
IS A JERK.